[Music]
[Applause]
a
[Music]
he
[Applause]
[Music]
can go I see
you
the world number one ranked player 17
world championship titles the highest
ever feeder rating in the history of
Chess considered by many the greatest of
all times Magnus Carlson will be taking
on a never seen before challenge Welcome
to our coverage of the freestyle goat
chest
challenge
[Music]
welcome everyone we are so excited to be
here in vion house in Germany eight top
Grand Masters including the world number
one will be playing freestyle chess over
the next week to decide who is the
strongest alongside me breaking down
each and every move for you along the
way is Grandmaster Peter Leo Peter are
you excited yes hello Tanya hello
everyone super excited about this lovely
event what a fantastic setting in the
vion House hotel resort I'm just loving
it and can't wait the action to start
and in just a few moments from now the
action will start as the players are
getting ready to take their seats and it
is a format that is very very new to the
Chess World we will have freestyle chess
we start with the round robin each
player plays against each other it will
be seven rounds of round robin over the
next two days every game will have a new
position in the rapid we've got 25
minutes with a 10 second per move and uh
the start of the match with the players
with the new position being revealed to
the players just a few minutes before
the start of the game that just Bing
brings in such an exciting aspect Peter
yes absolutely 10 minutes before the
game start there will be a big draw I
think we will be also having uh live
action from the playing Hall super
excited uh which position we're going to
get and I believe the players are very
eager to figure out what kind of task is
ahead of them they're very eager we're
very eager to see what position In
freestyle chess 960 positions are
possible from the very start one of them
will be randomly picked up and the
players are going to find out just
moments before they make their first
move it's all about creativity it's all
about skill uh let's also discuss what
the players are fighting for there is a
lot of prize money at stake here yes
priz prize money is very important of
course but I believe it's it's about the
prestige yeah challenging Magnus Carson
that's that's the real challenge
everybody wants to take the title not
just the
$60,000 and there we see the top price
at $60,000 a player who finishes last as
well finishes eight out of these Grand
Masters will also go home with
$8,000 but it's more about the challenge
of playing in this format of playing
Fisher random of playing freestyle chess
they have to show their skill from the
very first move what makes this event so
exciting Peter I think everything the
whole format uh I like that we are
talking about Fisher and don't freestyle
chess and the players have time to think
yeah in the starting we start with the
rapid portion with 25 minutes games
after in The Knockout phase we're going
to be seeing classical chess because as
you said here the players have to think
right from move one yeah the the
strategy starts very early you have no
common patterns to the Li on you have to
figure out all by yourself right from
the very beginning and there was a
technical meeting discussing all the
rules with the players and it was very
interesting to see how you've got these
household names these very best players
in the world actually discussing the
rules of castling yes that's one of the
biggest challenges yes we know exactly
that the rule uh castling is kind of
normal but there are so many different
scenarios and I think we're going to be
seeing and we're going to be discussing
life while analyzing the games we'll be
breaking down all the castles the world
of Chess in a completely new light we
call it freestyle chess played according
to the rules of of Chess 960 random 960
ensures surprising games from the very
first move the games are played with
classical long thinking time why because
the arrangement of the chess pieces is
drawn at random before the start of each
game players can't rely on memorized
opening strategies but must think from
the beginning and manage their time for
40 moves instead of effectively 20 in
total there are 960 different basic
positions the PA remain as usual in the
second and seventh rows the arrangement
of the pieces in the first and eighth
rows is random but symmetrical the only
condition the king must always stand
between the Rooks and the Bishops on
different
colors the super grandmas see positions
they have never seen before and must
still make Swift decisions under time
pressure from the third tournament day
the super Grand Masters then have the
chance to play high class 960 games
because For the First Time in the
history of ch chess they get the time to
do so chess in a new dimension to be
experienced at the freestyle chess goat
challenge
2024 and Peter we will have the drawing
of positions happen very soon uh a very
exciting ceremony is about to start to
me the big question is how does a player
really prepare for these events and also
to break down more of the action we've
got more help at hand we've got grandmas
Nicholas joining us as well Nicholas how
hyped are you for this one thank you
Tanya also from me a very warm welcome
to the freestyle go challenge here at
weison house at the Baltic Sea and I'm
very excited I'm very very happy to be
here and watch the absolute best in the
world and some aspiring young players as
well who are already established top
players to battle it out to challenge
for Manny the go Magnus Carlson and my
task is to have a look at all the games
going on because we always have four
games happening uh simultaneously so
while you guys are focused on one game I
can check the other ones and see if any
big mistakes are happening or maybe any
excellent genius moves so I hope that we
can compliment Us in this way and I'm
really looking forward to a commentary
with you we're super excited about it
and a really great point there that it's
also a clash of generation we've got a
total of eight players four of them we
can say are very experienced players
belong to a certain generation and four
upcoming youngsters say that Peter yes I
think it's also symbolized yeah that we
have four Kings yeah the established
Superstars and the four upcoming and not
even upcoming already established
Superstars but still not has not not
with all this track record yeah that
that all the all the kings uh the Jacks
yeah the four jacks super exciting to
see this concept it's it's a very fresh
concept and let's take a look how the
Kings will handle the challenge of the
Jacks and you say Kings and Jacks uh
because here as well for the first time
the four experienced players have been
handed over the King cards there are
actually these booths that the players
have their resting areas with this big
King on the board and for the young
upcoming well I can't call them upcoming
anymore Peter as you said they're
already super established players
they're making their Mark at the very
best fighting at the doorsteps of the
world top 10 uh the likes of Winston
kaimer GES nbec abdat Ali Resa I don't
know where to put
do we call him uh the absolute Elite do
we call him a youngster both both
Nicholas is there a favorite in this
event well I mean in any event in which
Magnus Carlson is competing he must be
the favorite this is clear because he
has shown again and again in every time
control that he is the absolute best
player in the world but one has to point
out he has never been chess 960 official
random world champion so far these two
championships have been claimed by
Wesley son tar Nakamura last year so it
is definitely a discipline that for
Magnus Carson has been also challenging
but it is challenging for everybody so I
think Magnus is very motivated to win
this title and it will not be easy
because every player here is so so
strong they're all I feel like already
Giants in their own right so it will be
tough for Magnus to to win but he must
be the favorite inter say it is hard to
bet against Magnus Carlson regardless of
the format he plays in regardless of uh
the the tournament he's at but that said
Peter in this in chess 960 in Fisher
random freestyle chess as we're calling
it it's from move number one that you
start thinking there is no opening
preparation do you think that then
favors Players whose biggest Forte is
their creativity their intuition well I
think we are talking about the very best
players in the world I think that they
are all extremely creative uh you
normally have to be Universal player to
to be able to handle any any kind of
scenario perfectly uh and we also heard
that Magnus was in sou of Spain for
three weeks preparing for for this very
event it just shows uh that how
seriously Magnus is taking goal is he
was preparing for those events but we
did interview him during the Champions
test and he said the results he had in
his training games while preparing for
freestyle chess and I think it was
against Grandmaster David H his partner
his trading partner his good friend he
wasn't very happy with the results he
had in that well but it was practice
yeah that's that's kind of I'm actually
always little bit scared if if already
practice goes very well yeah then how do
you add how do you improve when the real
action starts so I think it was most
probably magnus's strategy we also know
that he's famous for starting a little
bit slow uh he does have the wi pieces
in the very first game against Vincent
kimer but all the all the pairings are
just stunning and and I can't wait for
the action to start and this is a fat
that Magnus has really favored it's
something that he's been really looking
forward to playing he's been wanting
classical time controls in Fisher random
what do you think it is about freestyle
chess that makes it so attractive to the
world number one well I think there are
two components that make it attractive
to probably all the top players for one
they don't have to worry about opening
preparation usually before the game
players have to prepare several hours
and find some small idea maybe to
surprise the opponent to get him into
uncomfortable position here they don't
even know the starting position up to 10
minutes before the game then they can
discuss a little bit about what they can
think to themselves or they can discuss
with the other players what they're
going to do but there will not be hours
of preparation so this is one thing and
the other thing is there's no ELO rating
to be worried about to be afraid of
losing points especially for Magnus
Carlson as he is the favorite in every
single game he always has to think about
his ELO as well and the other players
also so they can just play without
worrying about prep they can just
without woring about ELO and they can
just play and just enjoy the game and I
think this is a nice change for all the
players here especially also for many of
the players here who will play in the
candidates because they they can just
focus on chess and not worry about these
other parts so I think this is why a lot
of the players also decide to come here
and play because it is just such a nice
event where you can just do what they
love playing chess and not worry about
these other things so much
freestyle chess taking away that element
of opening preparation of memorization
where very often these days we only
truly start seeing the players in action
after move 20 sometimes not even till
the end of the game but in this format
from the very first move it will be an
absolutely unique position for the
players to start fighting on and they
will have just 10 minutes from the
drawing of the position to the start of
the game how do you expect the players
to be spending those 10 minutes yeah it
was very interesting I was also present
at the Players meeting just to get some
inside info from the players and we are
seeing now already the show is about to
begin that the the white players so the
four white players can actually separate
into one team discuss for for the 10
minutes if they want if they prefer to
do that but we have live action we're
going to head straight over to Fiona as
the opening of the position the first
game position is about to be
revealed
here in a second and in a second we're
also uh going to go to the I'm very
excited to in a moment call H Holly and
Teresa Sarah Miss Angola International
to the stage who will be doing the
drawing of lots so I'm just G to wait
for the queue H to when this is going to
start so once again 960 balls on this
table one position will be drawn very
soon once we have the number the players
will get a few minutes to relax to Think
Through uh what their strategy is going
to be for the games as you can see on
the sides the players have their own
booths where they can
either prepare by themselves or as a
group okay and now thank you so much
Tanya and Peter in the studio welcome
here to Vice in house we are about to do
the drawing off Lots so I would now like
like to welcome to the state please
Holly and Theresa Sara Miss Angola
International please warm Round of
[Applause]
Applause so the way this is going to
work is Holly is going to be the one uh
activating the table making sure all the
balls roll into this ball into this bowl
and then H Teresa Sarah is going to pick
a number that is the number of the
position that will be played welcome
thank you so much for joining us and I'm
going to see if we are ready I think we
are ready so Holly three two one let's
go and please So the lucky hand is going
to pick the first position of the day
and it's going to be position
number number
49 let's show that into the camera let's
show it to the players if everything is
working we should be seeing the position
behind us in a second and thank you so
very much we put theall in
here and please give a warm Round of
Applause for Holly and Theresa SAR once
again we'll be seeing them again later
on for round two three and four so
number 49 and you can now all see the
first position on the screen I think
that is going to conclude uh this part
of the ceremony I'm going to hand it
back to Tanya and Peter in the studio
and I think the players can
now we are live so we have to
position we saw there a position being
revealed and the pieces they're not your
standard setting up of the starting
position Peter what was the first thing
uh that stood out to you in our game one
position of the freestyle chesco
challenge well I think it was a very
special position because the King was on
G1 and on G8 and exactly between the two
Rooks Rook on H1 Rook on F1 so we are
having some very tricky kind of castling
the king from G8 can go all the way to
C8 and then the Rook from f8 goes to d8
but also if the Rook moves from f8 then
black can just Castle simply by keeping
the King on G8 and putting the Rook from
h8 to f8 so many different strategies so
many different strategies and of course
for many fans watching out there it can
be confusing the many rules the many
different setups of freestyle chest but
the bigger picture that one has to
remember in the starting position is
that out of the 960 position one fun
fact the standard chest position is
number
518 and the other thing to remember is
that in every starting position the King
has to be between the two Rooks the
Bishops have to be an opposite color
everything else can switch around and uh
Peter it gets exciting now because the
countdown has started the players need
to decide their approach in this
position that they perhaps never seen
before yeah for sure they have never
seen it before and uh I was just uh
stopping there that yes uh the agreement
is that the white players the four white
players can discuss between themselves
the position if they want and the same
applies to all the players playing with
the black pieces they also have the
chance to discuss strategy or first
couple of moves but everybody has its
own kind of strategy own Vision I think
that it's nice to gather the information
but I wouldn't be surprised seeing the
players sit down at their board and
think quite a lot for move one
already we will have the positions up on
our screen really soon and we've got a
confirmation coming in Nicholas that
it's position number
49 yes out of Chess 960 that we're going
to be starting with take it away tell us
your first
impressions yes so here we see it next
to me we have like Peter pointed out the
King on G1 and G8 we have the Rooks both
here on the queen side already so on H1
and F1 h8 of f8 and then all the minor
pieces very interesting all the minor
pieces are on the queen side so we have
the bishop here in the corner already
the two knights this is quite a unique
position I would say already and as
Peter pointed out the king can Castle
King's side then he would just stay here
and The Rook would come over or the king
could Castle Queen side of course if all
the pieces in between it has to be
cleared and then the king would jump
over here to C1 this R Rook would jump
to D1 so we have some very interesting
possibilities here and
I think this is a very fun first
starting position what do you guys think
I have I have the same feeling this is
kind of and one of the first thought
that I'm having already is maybe even
not clear if white needs to castle at
all yeah because the light pieces are
perfectly placed yeah they can be
brought into game very easily white can
also eventually just go H4 we know this
uh kind of strategy and then the H1 look
is alive immediately as so there are so
many angles just incredible
and this is our starting position really
nicely pointed out there we divide the
board into two halves and we see a lot
of major pieces on the on the king side
the minor pieces all stacked up on the
queen side and the big question to me
always in these uh 960 positions in
freestyle chess is to look for hanging
Pawns in pieces Peter to start thinking
how to develop your pieces that might
come out with a
Tempo yeah there are so many things to
to look at first of all what I do see
also as an important factor that the
bishop on A1 it's on already on the long
diagonal yeah normally people like to
fian get to that Bishop but now if you
move the B2 Pawn with to B3 or to B4 it
already opens up the long diagonal so
very interesting we are waiting for
information did the gamees already start
we're going to get a confirmation and
just a few moments from now the players
will set in to make their first moves in
this position perhaps right now they're
just trying to think and discuss Also
let's point out to everyone that within
this much time that they have between
the revealing of the position and the
start of the game the players have no
access to engines they
have world number two Fabiano Carana
takes on the recent winner of division 2
in the chessable Masters wincon kaimer
and I think they're having a little bit
of a talk about the position that uh
Peter yes exactly yes so they are in the
camp of
uh playing with the black pieces yes
exactly and now they are discussing and
look at this it's kind of very nice and
no back is joining the discussion that
someone is sitting from the white side
as well yeah so that they are trying
good moves they are trying good ideas
and they only have the wec Magnus
enjoying his time with
leavon and uh Peter you mentioned it
players starting with the white pieces
have the have the privilege to discuss
it with each other um how they think
about the position just for a few
minutes before they start the players
playing with the black side can also do
the same to understand the position with
just a few minutes this is all they have
this is a position that the world's best
have never seen before and there we see
one of the most creative chess players
uh in modern chess Leon aronian
discussing it out with Magnus Carlson
yes I also feel like this is the the
quiet before the storm right that okay
now you have this 10 minutes to discuss
without any pressure you can move the
pieces back and forth uh however when
the players are then SE at the board the
game is about to start and the clock
will start then the pressure is on you
finally have to make that responsible
decision what will be your first move
and I'm really interested to see what
will be the strategy of the players that
do they dare to rely on this 10 minutes
pregame uh preparation or will we see
also Magnus spending quite some time at
the board as well m
and as we see the players discuss it out
and is that GES at the back also leaning
forward to take a look at what's going
on there trying to decide their first
moves uh Nicholas I'm looking at the
position that we have and the one very
interesting thing about it is that the
players already have a castle on the
board on the king side we see in the
very starting position White's King is
on G1 The Rook is on F1 so they can
already start thinking about developing
their pieces and not about King
safety yeah that's absolutely right so
the king is already on tucked away on
one side of the board it's just a
question what you do with the rook in
the corner in this position
[Music]
and what you focus on with your other
with your minor pieces if you fight for
the center so there's a lot to discuss
and like you guys said it's not a lot of
time yesterday I was talking to Fabiano
kanano who has played in these events
before and he said to me well you know
10 15 minutes that's pretty much nothing
and then after 10 or 15 minutes
discussing you get to a board you play
the first move and the computer already
says it is a mistake and you're worse
after the first move of white so this
can happen and this just goes to show
how difficult this chess 960 this
freestyle chess really is so we see
magnos we see aronian discussing the
moves and they're really going quite
into some some lines already so they
really make use of their time but in the
end you really have no guarantee that
you are making a good first move you
just you just try to to get into a game
and like you said I think a very
important factor is the time here
freestyle chest is very difficult and 25
minutes and 10 seconds increment per
move is not a lot of time so they
probably don't want to spend that much
time in the first few moves then again
these first few moves are really
important so what do you guys think what
will be this
strategy it's very important because it
determines the middle game position that
you get and that's why we see Levon and
Magnus really discuss the very start of
the game the very first moves that
you're pointing out in Rapid they start
with 25 minutes on the clock with every
move that they make every press of the
clock they get an additional 10 seconds
eventually in we will move on to the
classical time control and the time is
up it's time to take their seats and to
get started with round number one of the
round robin the discussions have
happened this is all the time the
players got and there we see perhaps a
player Peter uh that might be hard for
you to be neutral towards yes Vincent is
facing Magnus cars in the first game and
we did see the insights of Magnus and
Levon discussing things and we have seen
some aggressive approach there some F4
and E4 moves had been played and uh I
also feel like from the black side how
do you prepare how do you discuss
because you have no idea at all what's
your opponent's first move going to be
and the the possib really I do believe
that the first two three moves maybe the
first two moves are the most important
because the players know that they are
extremely strong if they already have
the right direction if they get a kind
of clear cut situation then they will be
also speeding up and making the uh
following decisions much faster and this
is our first position that is in front
of you it is go time and this is what we
were discussing that interestingly
enough at the very start we already see
the Kings have a castle on the board
Black's King on G8 White's King on G1
with the Rook next to it the other Rook
on H1 discussing how that can come
forward maybe channeling a bit of alpha
zero there at some point we could look
at the H Pawn moving forward to develop
the Rooks but first Peter it's going to
be about where you want to place those
minor pieces minor pieces but also the
classical chess rule is to occupy the
center and the big question is how do
you do that in in a freestyle chess yeah
that is it worth going for the center
how your other pieces are playing and I
think one of the biggest dangers playing
from the black side is that you don't
know exactly should you copy should you
repeat the moves that your opponent is
doing because there is no guarantee at
all that this one extra Tempo that white
has will not come in beneficially for
for white Magnus is taking his seat and
the players are getting ready and
Nicholas I'm looking at this position
thinking about what Peter said about
grabbing the center the one move that
would come to my mind is start with E4
you want to open the bishop you want to
get your queen out the king's already
castled uh what do you think about
starting with the traditional as Bobby
Fisher said E4 best by test yeah there
are definitely many different approaches
like you said here just putting the pawn
in the center this looks to me like a
very sensible move because and I'm just
playing this on the analysis board right
now so this has not happened in the game
but you open the bishop here on
D1 seems to agree and I was thinking I
would also like to get this guy in the
game already maybe in the first move by
playing the pawn four to B3 or B4 to
have this long diagonal open directly at
the king this also looks quite quite
attractive to me personally here opening
the bishop just pointing towards the
black king already what do you guys
think about
that t what is your take you know B3
adan's a good friend of mine uh the
Cowboys Will Rejoice be Adon says B3 in
any position is good I really like that
idea as well but I think we're getting
our first moves in and we're going to
try and pull
up the game between Magnus and Winston
and I believe E4 has been played I
believe so too yeah
wow E4 E5 classical
chess E4 E5 okay well basically if you
know Magnus Carson and you know Vincent
kimer and they have been debating uh the
Spanish uh quite some anti- martials in
their World Cup match last year and also
in the word uh rapid yes that's a rook
not a bishop so we're probably not going
to see a bishop to B5 like the Spanish
exactly yeah so I think after E4 E5 the
terror end and we are in Uncharted
Territory now let's take a look yeah
Magnus has slowed
down uh this means that this wasn't
really part of the prep anymore and B3
so combination of the two
moves you mentioned it Nicholas it's on
the board and to me it's the first time
that I'm seeing the player on each and
every move at the very start of the game
we're so used to seeing them just Blitz
out the moves really really quickly
they're taking their time they're really
understanding the position uh and that's
what's so special about freestyle chess
yeah for sure and uh maybe it would be
also very interesting just to run
through all the four games to get a
feeling what what the other players are
up to as well
so already in the third move there is
something crazy going on which I have to
share with you I have the computer on
here and in this position so just to
take you through the first three moves
and Dingle ran against Fabiano kanano
with
D4 F5 C4 so what we would call a a Dutch
defense here in a classical chess game
B6 B4 and now
Believe It or Not There is the move
Bishop from A8 taking on G2 a sacrifies
in the third move the king takes and the
queen comes out to G6 and suddenly the
king is already on the rod the King has
to go here because if it goes to H3 it's
Checkmate already and how many moves was
that five moves so the King has to go
forward and the queen can hunt the
king or he already there are other
options but you can hunt the king and
then win the Knight on B1 how crazy is
that how crazy is that and what's the
evoluation the evoluation is somehow
equal which I don't quite understand
because black seems to be up a pawn but
somehow of the bishop C3 there's the
threat to to trap the queen with the
bishop to C2 so the queen has to I was
thinking has to come out but all right
we're getting really into details here
but it goes to show
that already after three moves some
crazy sacrifice are possible in
freestyle
chess what a line that was Peter not
something that you get to see very often
but even just this position not a single
piece has been developed uh standard
traditional chess wisdom is take out the
pieces but here we see the world
champion ding Len he's going for a pawn
storm on the queen side meanwhile Fabby
the world number two yet to develop but
they're just opening up the space to
eventually land with these pieces in the
center of the board yeah and it also
shows that how dangerous how tricky this
uh game is yeah that you don't have any
safety right from the very beginning uh
we also do see some confusion I don't
think that this is not the wrong
position no that that we are having or
it's only only us yeah this is wrong
maybe maybe if you refresh I'm not sure
but this is obviously a normal chess but
now and this is the position that we had
with a very similar opening uh with
playing with the white side against
aliad the crazy line that you just
showed Nicolas and we've had some moves
and I'm doing a pawn count here material
still in Balance but a really strange
position out of the opening The Rook is
attacked it wasn't grabbed on the last
move uh because there was a Checkmate on
G7
Nicholas yes exactly after Queen
G3 The Rook could not be taken
because excuse me again this bishop is
very important we pointed this out in
the beginning already this bishop all
the way don't forget about it pointing
to the black king so here black could
not could not take on F4 because of a
Checkmate on G7 we really see in
different lines and different games how
vulnerable the king can be on G8 because
of this bishop in the corner so this did
of course not happen alira played F6 to
protect the bishop and also to stop the
the white dark scared Bishop this
diagonal stop it from exerting so much
pressure on the king Now The Rook is
attacked on F4 so drop back to F2 and
the Knight is coming out to D6 and black
seems to be in okay shape here Knight E4
is a threat now forking Queen and Rook
this seems to be a good start to Ali RZA
for this game but of course A lot can
still happen it's just such unusual
positions we we're not used to to seeing
those really well my first feeling was
that GES is doing some magic yet were
talking about this that how will we
castle and what and he made perfect
sense he opened the f file with F4
captured with the Rook from F1 on F4 and
now when he's castling he will be
doubling the Rooks and now we have some
crazy action C5 Knight E4 Bishop B3
check look F7 so black is sacrificing
The Exchange back uh but also black is
winning the exchange on F2 so this is
kind of a trade black is also getting
ready to castle with simply moving The
Rook from h8 to f8 then uh Miss
accomplished short Castle has been made
and the same applies for white as well
but for the moment also the White Queen
on G3 is hanging and it's a big question
what do you recapture with that on that
F7 square if you were to step up with
your queen takes Bishop White's Queen
can actually jump in on C7 watch out for
hanging Pawns in freestyle chest the C7
Pawn is undefended black could not have
captured the bishop with the queen steps
in with the King but this actually
allows white to give a check on B3 and
sidestep the fork that we are seeing
Peter
yes that's true and then we are talking
about some positional exchange sacrifice
it's it just completely insane I also
feel that we should be even going back
all the way to move one to to break down
the action that how did all this madness
happen because in other games we have
seen a much slower approach from the
players Nicholas perhaps you can just
break it down for us because this is
already a wild position uh and we're
seeing white is current up an
exchange yes let me let me update my
board so we are in this position here
after Queen
E6 and
yes white is up an exchange but you see
the black piece are very very active the
Knight is out on e4 the bishop is out on
G5 this Pawn is hang the bishop on A8 is
also playing a role and it seems that
even though black is down in exchange
black is already better computer is
giving a an advantage here clear
advantage to black and it seems that ala
he is a very Dynamic player who can
really understand well the elements that
are important
to create create strong play with his
pieces and he knows when to sacrifice an
exchange that's what I'm trying to say
so here he has taken the he has taken
charge from the beginning and it seems
that that he's in excellent shape also
on the clock and that's a very important
factor 6 minutes ahead on the clock
already with the rapid time control we
have to be really watching that as well
now the queen were traded Queen E6 and
probably the pawn will take back the
Rook can swing to d8 the black pieces
are just looking much better than white
piece here which is giving black an edge
yes it's it's a very scary position to
be with white yeah the Knight on e4 is a
monster probably you will have to
sacrifice The Rook on F2 but the black's
Bishops are extremely
powerful and not liking this for gues I
I was a big fan first I saw that wow and
then this Knight D6 Knight E4 came out
of nowhere just stunning stunning play
alza 20-year-old ala fuja known for his
intuitive play for his creative
sacrifices and as Nicholas pointed out
he has this understanding of where the
pieces belong it's all about peace
activity and here we see that white does
have the extra material what material
are we talking about those Knights still
on B1 C1 not developed the Rook on H one
far from Play The Rook on F2 hanging
you've got to waste time do you defend
that do you give up the D2 Pawn it's
already starting to look a bit shaky for
GES gkes is a player who's known so much
for his opening preparation as well uh
and perhaps not having as much
experience in freestyle chess do you
think that's going to come at play as
well uh Peta how important is experience
in this format I think it's very ex very
important and uh we do remember that Al
has been playing has been part part of
the grest tour and there had been many
many events there has tones of
experience and uh gash probably has only
played in be uh but but that's a little
bit
different and Nicholas as this one heats
up you've got more insights on the world
number two facing the current world
champion yes Tanya thank you um we're
going to another game here because also
there an exchange sacrifice has happened
between dingl Ren and Fabiano kanana we
left around here with there was this
option of sacrificing the bishop on G2
already which was very interesting but
kanana did not go for it so we'll just
see briefly which moves did happen E6 F3
the Knight is coming out this is a move
we see again and again in this in this
position Knight comes out and now F4 the
Knight is jumping to F5 and E3 a very
powerful Outpost for this Knight so this
is something that dingl ran absolutely
had to stop he trades the Knight off
takes on F5 Knight D3
and now the queen is coming in going to
the giving a check the rook and now we
see the exchange sacrifice or maybe it
was born out of necessity here Bishop H4
attacking the pinned Rook on F2 once
more so the Rook is is being lost and it
goes into his end game but this seems to
be a position now well I was just going
to say where where the side with the
exchange is better but now that we
reached it apparently trading the Queens
here was not the best idea to keep the
Queens on the board going back to E7 was
Stronger probably with the idea to play
against the white king later on but
after queens were traded now and D5 is
played we see that even though white is
down an exchange white is also better
here and it's very interesting that we
see two exchange sacrifices already and
in both cases the side of the exchange
down is better but it is switching back
and forth with every move to be honest
it's just very very difficult to play so
here right now kaana is in front but it
is an open battle between the
two it's more about peace activity in
these uh in these positions as we're
seeing especially as the starting pos
position had this Rook stuck on H1 as
long as that Rook stays there you're
really fighting to get uh to make the
most of the material advantage in the
position also Peter let's get an update
on uh Magnus Carlson against Winston
kimer as that position heats up it
started with the move E4 as we were
predicting and to my eyes this looks
like more like a standard opening play
that we're seeing yes but if you are
talking about standard and white is
occupying the center and black is not
able to challenge it I'm slightly
worried uh for Vincent also we do see
that White's Bishop on A1 is doing
extremely good job it's on an open
diagonal protecting the D4 Pawn while if
black for example pushes B 6 he might be
confronted with a D4 D5 move a typical
move that locks out that Bishop from A8
also the Knight on C8 has nowhere to go
if the pawn is pushed to B6 Vincent's
pieces are crammed while if you occupy
the center like Magnus did he has tons
of space eventually the Knight is
heading to
D3 it's it's already a clear Advantage
for white that's at least my
feeling it's really fascinating here and
uh Nicholas what do you think think in
this early stages despite seeing that
Black's the one who first gets the miner
piece out is it more free flowing for
white to make uh the next couple of
moves here yeah definitely I agree with
Peter we we see that white has more
space and when you have more space in
chest that means you have more options
to place your piece to maneuver your
pieces to bring them to uh better
squares and in this way to improve your
position consistently so I think Magnus
is in good shape I want want to go over
to another game right now where there is
a lot of action we haven't seen this
game yet but look at this position we
saw this bishop sacrifice in the other
game as a POS possibility here it did
happen here it did happen if we go a few
moves back so in this position after the
opening there was this bishop sacrifice
on G2 Bishop takes G2 and the King has
to take it otherwise one of the Rooks
would fall plus white has no
compensation for being down a pawn in
exchange so the king takes and now the
king is on the run the queen is coming
out to G6 the King has to step to H3 no
it didn't have to step to H or did it
well both moves are possible actually
doesn't make a big of a difference
because here after Queen H6 King G2
Queen G5 now the king had to go to F3
because if it went back to H3 and Rook
F6 and The Rook swing on the six rank
would be already game over for white so
the king had to step step to
F3 and now there's another check coming
in the king is being pushed into a
center King E2 and
here now the computer says bring just
the bishop in instead up to the tur
played a more human move giving another
check on H5 provoking F3 which is
absolutely forced and wow what a
position guys he sacrificed the peace
what do you what do you make of this
absolute Madness and that is what
freestyle chess is about from the very
start we are on move number 13 and a
position that you would not expect in
standard chess White's King on E2 right
in the center of the board a check with
that Queen on H5 the Rooks still on
their starting positions on h8 and H1 as
the positions heat up we're going to
quickly break down the rules of a
freestyle chess so that we can get into
the middle game action the world of
Chess in a completely new light we call
it freestyle chess played according to
the rules of Chess 960 random 960
ensures surprising games from the very
first move the games are played with
classical long thinking time why because
the arrangement of the chess pieces is
drawn at random before the start of each
game players can't rely on memorized
opening strategies but must think from
the beginning and manage their time for
40 moves instead of effectively 20 in
total they there are 960 different basic
positions the pawns remain as usual in
the second and seventh rows the
arrangement of the pieces in the first
and eighth rows is random but
symmetrical the only condition the king
must always stand between the Rooks and
the Bishops on different
colors the super Grand Masters see
positions they have never seen before
and must still make Swift decisions
under time pressure from the third
tournament day the super Grand Masters
then have the chance to play high class
960 games because For the First Time in
the history of Chess they get the time
to do so chess in a new dimension to be
experienced at the freestyle chess goat
challenge
[Music]
so to go back because we don't have the
keyboard you have to
go
[Music]
ever World rapid Champion he is an
Olympic gold medalist and right now nck
has a big task ahead of him as he faces
Leon aronian in a very difficult
position there is already attack on
nock's King Peter you were excited to
break down this position as levon's
creating his threats yes because first
of all as Nicholas highlighted it was
not back Abdul satov who sacrificed that
Bishop on G2 started hunting White's
King and all of a sudden we have also
seen that uh n back has slowed down here
and let's just go back this was the
position we left uh Queen H5 check FC
was played I was wondering what will
happen after Bishop H4 why is n back
taking his time clearly the answer is
that he has sported the genius response
to this White Queen seems to be kind of
Trapped By the bishop but white ignores
this threat and plays look F1 to G1 now
if you take that Queen on E1 with Bishop
takes E1 then you are in for a very
nasty surprise look take G7 Checkmate
and Nicholas has already been
highlighting that this G7 Square
especially thanks to that monster Bishop
on the long diagonal is doing some
tremendous job so n back had to play the
move Rook F7 protecting the G7 Pawn but
if one would think oh black had lost the
tempo what will happen but he's most
probably planning to Castle next move
with Rook h8 jumping to f8 completing
development then Rook can go to eight
let's not forget white king is still
stuck in the center and can't Castle
anymore and what an interesting way to
Castle in chess you just usually you
would pick up your king put it on the
Square pick up the Rook put it on the
Square but in freestyle chess this is
one of the ways to Castle if your king
and Rook haven't moved your king is on
the right spot you can simply move that
h8 Rook to f8 finish castling in one
move like that and also finish your
development how are we evaluating this
position Nicholas uh it is a very very
exciting moment in the middle game white
I think has eventually decided we've got
some more moves coming in Peter in this
position after nbec made the castle and
now it's Levon on the think with that
King out in the open King stuck on E2
white has extra material but I would be
terrified with white playing with my
king out in the open I agree absolutely
with you Tanya I would hate this
position with white yes the computer is
maybe giving a equal position or maybe
even a little bit better for
what okay well there is some pressure on
G7 that's true but for now is defended
the Rooks are lined up the knights are
ready to come into action to D6 and to
C6 and what about these pieces what
about this Knight on D2 what about this
Knight on C1 both of them cannot even
move at all right now because these
pawns are so strong the king is right in
the center so if the E file opens up
there's a lot of pressure on the king so
I'll be terrified with the white pieces
here but objectively it should be fine
if you make space for the king to hide
away on D1 play a move like Bishop C2
but still in a practical game I would
choose black any day and I I think
nybeck is really in his element here
he's an attacking player he's a dynamic
player and that's why he went for the
sacrifice also because in Practical
terms in a rapid game like this with
little time to defend this will be so
difficult so I think nck is in good
shape here but we'll see if leevon can
defend this and leavon is an extremely
resourceful player he finds these
creative ways to to manage to save the
position but it is an uphill task let's
bring up our bird's eye view really
quickly Peter and do an overview because
while this one is fire on the board I do
see a lot of the other boards have
pieces traded off so if we just zoom out
for a moment uh and there we have it
Peter uh if we bring up our current
positions on the bird's eye view we see
several end games in play while this one
heats up yes okay we did see there that
uh
Ali had the pair of Bishops I think
White had sacrificed The Exchange back
white stabilized the position but black
is slightly pressing and I don't think
that's correct on our extreme right we
see a result on ding versus fabbi
board or what happened there yes it is
correct actually wow it is correct we
have the first win of the tournament of
the freestyle go challenge Fabiano cor
has defeated dingly Ren let me just I
have not checked it myself even but it
seems a bad mistake happened so we'll
just go through the last few moves Nas
maybe you can take it from the start and
break it down to us because it's a game
that we completely missed well we saw it
I think up to this point where they
entered the the end game and white was
up in exch white was down in exchange it
was quite unclear still because white is
winning the pawn on F4 so let's take it
from
here so the Knight came out black traded
on C4 this still looks fine to me for
white even though white is down an
exchange so let's continue G5 makes
sense to protect the pawn but white is
having some play on the dark squares
here and now the bishop this bishop on a
long down wants to win back the exchange
so this seems to have been a good choice
by ding taking takes on C4 so far
everything still somewhat normal maybe
this was not a good idea to bring the
bishop back here according to a computer
play Move Like Knight B2 but not an easy
choice either way so ding was under
pressure already and now he brought the
bishop back takes on D3 takes and now
Rook d8 here actually and this is a very
funny moment black could have castled
Queen side this is the preferred move by
the end just to show it just to show
what is possible so this is I think very
comical because you're castling from a
kingside position kingside Castle to a
queenside castle in one move this is
freestyle chess everybody and this would
have been the best move actually because
the Rook is attacking the pawn the king
can help with the queen side majority
however what Fabiano was doing was also
a good choice Rook to da8 putting
pressure King E2 and the Knight is
coming out so black is better in this
end game but it should not have been
should not have been over that quickly
so I think a very terrible mistake
happened here at some point Rook A3 Rook
C2 Knight E6 6 Bishop F6 King F7 and now
a very aneristic blunder happened by
ding L Ren who put the bishop on E5 the
bishop should go somewhere back to C3 or
maybe to A1 one of D squares or maybe
even to h8 but on E5 it was lost
immediately Rook E3 check ends the game
because the kings in check and the
bishop is attacked it's a double attack
the bishop is dropping that's a full
piece and that's game over so dingl Ren
in the first game committing a
a big mistake and Fabiano is taking a
win with the black pieces so good start
for
him and Peter quite a quick win uh in
the books for Fabby that one a nicely
played game and this is the kind of
confidence that you need going into this
format going into a freestyle chess to
me that castling that Nicholas just
showed it felt like parkour it felt like
you just take something and go
completely crazy with it and the reason
that that was possible was because from
the starting position that black king
and the black Rook had actually never
moved so castling was still legal
exactly yeah but the good news for Fab
was that even his traditional move was
good enough to keep the pressure so he
will not be hunted by this missed
opportunity at the same time he gets the
experience already that yes I have to
watch out for moves like this this was
an unar uncharacteristically bad game by
dingl ran I felt like when he sacrificed
The Exchange everything was fine but
that he did not not close the position
with C5 that was my kind of feeling
that's the tigr petan position sacrifice
kind of feeling you close the position
he let the position be opened he
recaptured that exchange but that was
absolutely not necessary a very big win
for for Fabby real confident boost
booster uh but I can also understand the
opposite effect on dingl land yeah this
was a smashing defeat he he needs to
come down and find his balance to balce
back in the next games well he's a world
champion and and he definitely has it in
him to do it it is four rapid games
today so there is a lot of Chess to be
played a lot of freestyle chess to be
played and while we've had our first
result of the day action continues on
the other one if we pull up our bird's
eye view one more time and there we have
it in front of us I also see uh on our
extreme left we see on the screens gkes
in big troubles uh alar has got the
bishop beir and Peter you call this out
that after that exchange sacrifice the p
activity was so strong for ala and with
threats on F3 to me it looks like black
can actually just pick up a pawn at this
moment well but the position is so
beautiful that I even don't know if I
want to but he goes for it yeah takes
takes yeah the F3 Pawn is is lost white
is relying on this
powerful protected uh pass Pawn but
black look Gets behind look on C3 I
don't really see that pawn on C5 ever
advancing to C6 black is ready to put
that Bishop on E3 blocking White's rook
and then eventually just go F5 F4 F3
with devastating effect I don't really
see how gkes can stay in stay alive here
for the next couple of moves it looks
very bad and if white was to activate
his own drook trying to stop himself
from getting captivated after Bishop to
E3 I think that might be checkmating
ideas on White's King Black's Rook could
come to C2 if white was to jump in for
activity with his own rook and start to
threaten the white king with some back
rank problems Peter yeah probably white
has no other move white has to give the
Rook E4 check and when you highlighted
that yeah that Rook needs to be
activated yes that's probably the way to
go rookie for che at least kick that
King away uh kick that King away that
monster King yeah rookie for che has
been played Black has many possible
options even maybe going to H5 in order
to keep the idea of of but King F5 is
more was my also first thought but then
I noticed King H5 pushing F5 targeting
the H4 Pawn but it does not really
matter black is in the driver seat KES
in big trouble in this position he's
down upon and interestingly enough he
has to also watch out to not fall into
any mating ideas allowing Black's King
and Rook forward big trouble for gkes uh
and I think as these end Games The Grind
continues in this one I see Nicholas you
have your eyes on the most exciting
position of the round with leevon
aronian taking on nck Whit's King in the
open the KN has jumped in what is going
on here yes Tanya this is definitely the
most exciting game of the round for sure
nck has sacrificed the bishop a few
moves ago to bring the king out here
right into the center of the board and
for everybody this is the same whether
freestyle chess or normal chess you
don't want your king been running around
in the center of the board that's not
good so even though black is down a
piece the position is about balance but
we were saying already earlier it is
probably much more easier it's much
easier to play with the black pieces so
for up to zov however so far Aran is
hanging in he's defending and there's no
clear way through somehow everything is
more or less defended the king is
dreaming to get to B1 or maybe even to
A1 to be tucked away again safely on the
queen side but so far it's not possible
yet because the Knight is on D4 and this
is the current position no this is not
quite it Queen H6 was played F4 and and
now Knight E7 this makes a lot of sense
the Knight was the only piece which was
not in the game yet so the Knight is
coming in coming to C6 to G to B4 or
maybe even going to G6 and hitting this
Pawn on F4 objectively still around
equal but it is still a very tough
position for example the computer
suggesting now that the Knight is coming
to E2 to get rid of this Knight on D4
but then again this would allow a fork
on F3 and potentially giving this Rook
but I think most important as we as I
pointed out is that the king can run
away here and get to safety and I think
if aronian manages to do that then he
could maybe even fight for a win but
this is definitely still very much
exciting and and completely open game
how's the time situation arunan twice as
much on the clock 15 minutes against
seven we always have to keep an eye on
the clock as well because as time is
getting lower this is also gaining in
importance so here tan and Peter it
seems that if aronian is managing to
make a few more consolidating moves
maybe he can take over the advantage and
speaking of the time situation it's a 25
minutes with a 10c increment to me Peter
that's always been a very close to a
classical format it's sort of like the
long rapid you can't really rely on
playing extremely rush just to bring
your opponent down on the clock because
there's enough time to counter that what
do you make of the Dynamics with this
long Rapid Control yeah I really like it
because you have time to to to really
get into the essence of of a position
yeah you don't have to speed up if you
really feel at the beginning or in the
middle game phase that you need to
invest time like for example n Leon yeah
that he did economize on time at the
beginning I'm perfectly with Nicholas
already when I looked at this position
for the very first time my intuition was
telling me that yes the King has to run
away I want to challenge that Knight
with Knight one E2 and I'm so happy to
forget about the hanging look on G1
because the hanging Rook is in fact not
hanging at all please take that Rook
that means that the Rook on H1 which is
not part of the game at all captures
back that night and uh we are talking
about safe King and on the other leevon
goes Bishop A3 wow uh that's kind of a
stunning move in the sense that I didn't
see that one
coming incredible because the night on
C1 is such a problem piece in this
position and it's more important to get
the activity in it's about the pece
quality and not as much about the pece
quantity when the king is out in the
open on that D2 Square so sacrificing
that exchange on G1 would have eased out
the position but leavon going for a
different approach he wants to hold on
to that extra material the bishop on D1
is still controlling that F3 Square the
bishop on A3 now uh pinning that Knight
on E7 it looks like a beautiful position
Peter for black White's King on D2 The
Rook on H1 not playing the Knight on D4
really nice nicely placed if we just
highlight these pieces and I was going
to ask you where is the Breakthrough
coming in and nck is showing the way
he's sacrificing a pawn in this position
that can be picked up by White's Pawn
but what he wants to do then is to start
advancing that D Pawn up the board
control over the D Square I like this
move from the Practical perspective it
gives up more material but in return
you're playing for the initiative yeah
you play for initiative the reason why I
don't like Bishop AC intuitively that
from the black side I would even happy
and tempted to give the Rook on f8
please take that give me the dark Square
Bishop yeah because we see the pawn
structure the pawn structure is very
special white has uh White has this Pawn
on F4 black has this Pawn majority all
on the light squares and the dark
squares with that monster Bishop on H4
the queen is also on H6 so lot of lot of
uh dangers looming at White's King
evocating that King as quickly as
possible in my opinion had clear
priority on the other hand leavon is a
big Maestro so he did come up with a
move Bishop AC something had to be in
his mind so let's ask Nicholas what do
you think of all these well before we
get to this I just want to briefly point
out that we have another result there
was a draw between Magnus Carson and
Vincent kimer and we did not really look
at this game a whole lot which is we did
not look at it because it was a fairly
normal game for freestyle chess even if
you look at the end at the final
position you wouldn't even think it has
resulted
from such a strange starting position so
in this position they agreed to draw
it's equal material rook and Knight and
Five Pawns against rook and Knight and
Five Pawns and I think Vincent did a
really good job after the opening which
did not go as well to to neutralize and
to equalize and he can be happy about
getting a draw in the first game so now
let's go back to the game that is really
captivating us between live on aronian
and nor up to Z Turf and I absolutely
agree with you Peter the bishop on B2 it
seemed to me to do a great job here to
defend the dark squares to point against
the king and now you really never want
to give up this bishop neither Against
The Rook or against the Knight
definitely not so after B5 here opening
up the position Aran is getting under
pressure his time is getting lower and
this is only heating up more and more as
they both get into time pressure still I
would prefer to play Black and I believe
nck can can get a win here in this very
first game nbe Abdus satra one of the
most dynamic combative players in the
chess Scene goes with B5 another
sacrifice on the board the idea is to
get those Central pawns moving as
Peter's highlighting on our screens if
white was to get greedy capture on B5 we
will see the dwn advancing down the
board uh The Rook perhaps will
eventually find find its way to the
defile or the C file and start putting
pressure on white species this is bad
news for Levon who himself likes to be
on the attacking side but is on the
defense now nck has to be enjoying
himself in this position for sure yeah
this is a dream come true uh exactly as
he envisioned while going for this
stunning sacrifice with Bishop take G2
uh very much in this true Spirit of of
attacking at all cost and what did Levon
do we do did see that he made a move
Bishop C 5 wow okay this is a very quiet
move okay targeting that Knight on D4
the Knight on D4 is a monster it kind of
makes sense but does white really have
the time to do
this we see Bishop C5 on the board black
does not have the time to capture on C4
I'm already looking at options of
perhaps retreating and we see on our
screens there just for a moment but I'm
going to finish my thought here that
maybe Knight E6 is a move that could
come to your mind to hit that Bishop on
C
which would be hanging but I see Ali RZA
on our screens on our screen there he
seems extremely happy with the outcome
of his game and we've got another result
coming in ALA fuja gets the job done
against gkes it's a great start for uh
for the French player there with the
black pieces getting a win in in quite a
masterful style yeah and the what a day
what a game round one we have seen
Fabiano winning with the black pieces
alas are winning with the black pieces
no de back having the chance of winning
with the black pieces black is very much
alive and very much okay in this in this
tournament in this tournament and maybe
in this format maybe the fact that
freestyle chess has a unique position at
the very start of the of the game you
take away the opening element are you
taking away White's Advantage from the
start as well we see black performing
really well yeah I'm very happy to see
this yeah because sometimes there's also
this danger that maybe some starting
position will heavily favor white yeah
that's one of the the kind of critical
moments and there was also this
discussion right from the beginning when
uh Fisher andom chest started that maybe
should some position be eliminated well
this one we felt right from the go that
it's a stunning position with so many
possibilities and uh black is making
perfect uh making perfect sense out of
of all his POS possible options we've
had three results out of four games it
is all eyes on leavon aronian versus nck
ABD satra of leavon in big pressure
right now he has made this last move
Bishop to C5 hitting the Knight that we
were highlighting what are the options
here for nck well we see a move on the
board so he answers the question Queen
to F6 he wants to keep that Knight on
that Central Square he's getting the
queen to defend on uh with that move
with the move Queen to F6 how are we
seeing this progressing now for white
well I think it's also not time to
include Nicholas back into the
conversation what are your Source
Nicholas what is what is happening yeah
Queen F6 is a very nice move because the
queen on H6 was not doing that much
anymore was hitting a pawn F4 but now on
F6 you can already Envision some ideas
here on this diagonal that this Knight
is stepping away and the queen is coming
in on the weaken dark dark squares in
the white Camp also next maybe The Rook
can swing over to C8 hit the bishop on
C5 and in general there's some pressure
some possibilities on the C file where
the position could open up so quite like
this move Queen F6 the engine also likes
this move quite a lot and white is in a
lot of trouble the computer line here is
to play Bishop H5 which in my eyes
doesn't do that much and then G6 oh
apparently this was played also G6 and
now to to trade on E7 but you really
never want to trade on E7 you never
really want to just give up your Bishop
against the Knight so I would not play
this as a human maybe Knight E2 is more
of a human move I think so to get rid of
this Knight on
D4 finally I think this is probably what
Arona is going to do I don't really see
him trading this this dark Square Bishop
against the Knight on E7 which is not
doing that much right now but in either
case black is better here and also has
the much easier practical play so nybeck
also with the time getting more and more
even he is definitely looking for uh
he's he seems to be going for the win
here n back Abdus satov playing for the
win he's down a piece he's down
materially but it is all about the
activity against Whit King still stuck
in the center you just compare each of
Black's pieces right now to White's
counterparts and it's clear that it is
nbe playing for more in this position
attacking the bishop now the C5 Bishop
can also come into attack there are
threats of the Knight jumping onto F3
the troubles continue for Levon but at
least the clocks are Level now Peter
well uh actually leevon was up on the
clock yeah he had like twice the time of
of Abdu satov uh Nicholas was
highlighting all the time that he would
love to be black and normally when we
talk about this that we love to be black
it means that the moves are coming in so
much more easier for the side that we
like and that's exactly the point that
Abdu satov did spend quite a lot of time
in the opening for the sacrifice and
everything he sense that yes it's uh
it's perfect judgment if I going to get
the type of position that I really enjoy
I'm liking and putting practical problem
to my opponent then the the clock won't
be the decisive factor and all of a
sudden he's already up on the clock and
also has the attack this is getting
really scary and big decisions to be
made by leavon in this position do you
take the Knight on E7 as Nicholas was
pointing out do you come back with your
own Bishop in a sense giving a Tempo to
Black to improve the position of that
Rook on f8 by sliding over to that C8
file coming in with a Tempo Bishop takes
Knight which was the best move point out
by Nicholas it is such a difficult move
to make because you really need your
pieces to defend your king to give away
a key Defender like that but I think the
point of that move is to gain control of
the D5 Square when black would recapture
uh that Bishop on E7 White's Knight can
jump into activity into opponent's camp
and finally white will have an active
piece in the position yes but it comes
at the cost of giving up the dark West
forever yeah that's kind of the reason
uh we we don't really want to do that L
is taking his time he might do it out of
Desperate Measures not because of he's
happy uh the move Knight C1 to2 first of
all this Knight has not yet participated
in the game it has not moved so far so
it's also very tempting to develop that
Knight U and get rid of that monster on
on
D4 such a tough practical question I we
just now the players under 5 minutes on
the clock and the position position is
just starting while it's been exploding
for a while but it's reaching that Peak
culmination where the players have to be
accurate and we see some moves coming in
the night trade Nicolas has been offered
you approve of this move you said it is
the more human move in the position and
that monstrous Knight I don't think you
can call it a knight the Knight on D4
more of a stallion is finally off the
board yes so I'm sure that aronian is
breathing a s of relief here after the
Knight has been traded apparently it was
maybe a better option to bring the
Knight back to E6 hitting the bishop on
C5 and keeping more let's say pieces for
white on the board which are not that
well coordinated here with the bishop on
H5 also always a bit hanging if the king
steps to a side suddenly a bishop
doesn't have any squares on H5 but
nybeck did not go for this he traded
Knights and now it feels like the
position is becoming more coordinated
more harmonious for white to play the
bishop will probably take back and I'm
guessing that nordbeck want wants to
immediately open up with D6 or D5
further open up up against the the white
King open up the D file open up with the
cfile just hit the king as long as all
these pieces look at these pieces
they're all stuck here on the king side
Queen and both Rooks they're not doing
anything right now so black really needs
to use the time to open up the position
and attack the white king and I think
this is what this is what nck is going
for here the bishop takes E2 we have
seen a move was it D5 was D5 played yes
I believe so yes so again uping up the
pressure against aonan
and well what to suggest here I mean you
cannot allow D4 you cannot really you
have to react in some way you could take
on E7 but again this is not the move
that that white wants to play you can
take on E7 and then take on on take on
D5 but then like Peter said you give up
the dark squares
forever Queen A3 looks like a potential
move for me Rook d8 seems to be the best
move and it is getting really really
sharp and really really difficult and so
difficult to play with four or five
minutes on the clock who will prevail
here what do you guys think it's time
for predictions while with the clock
running low leavon Aron touching the
4minute mark and we've been pointing
this out from the start of this game
that King in the center King on D2 a
potential opening up of the D line uh
Peter if I had to predict I'm going to
go with another back win here what about
you yeah well and also the move knightx
B5 had been played I I almost got a hard
attack because we did mention the the
move Queen H6 to F6 had the purpose not
only to protect the Knight on D4 but
eventually entering into White's camp
with Queen B to check and Queen B to
check how does white react to that I I
just can't believe what I'm seeing and
look at leevon did he just noticed
holding his head like did I really miss
did I let Queen B2 check
happen wow Leon's got to be feeling the
pressure finally black pieces are about
to strike on White's king queen B2 check
on the board there are two options there
are two legal moves in the position for
white here you can either come up with
that King to E3 or King to D1 to me both
of them feel like you're walking into
some kind of a checkmating idea I'm
scared to even make that move on the
board to E3 will we see a D4 at some
point or maybe the Knight will jump from
E7 to
D5 but be a king to D1 also doesn't look
any more safe with the black Rook coming
on to The dile Rook d8 to follow up both
very scary Alternatives yes I do feel
like King E3 is very much in Levon style
and I do know that he's a big bu House
Fan yeah and I'm I absolutely know
nothing about it so I just asked Leon
what to know about bakos and he told me
Peter if they ask attack you have to run
into the attack and and basically King
E3 is a move very much in the
spirit yeah and actually King E3 is
absolutely necessary if you play King D1
T you were already your intuition was
right on spot you just lose the game
instantly because of well for example
the queen can can First grab this Pawn
on A2 and and grab the pawn on B3 also
the king is just not safe there's no
coordination The Rook can come to d8 or
C8 white is not going to survive this so
King E3 is absolutely necessary and in
fact in fact white is having the
advantage here believe it or not because
there's no clear way for for black to
continue I was I'm expecting NC's idea
was to play A6 because if this Knight
was to move now let's say here or here
it doesn't really matter then Queen C3
is absolutely deadliest Checkmate in the
next move because the king is having no
no squares the Bishop is protecting this
one can only put a bishop in between
well it's not Checkmate yet to be fair
because the queen is still defending it
but actually check out this move check
out this move Bishop E1 oh man that is
that is quite a move Bishop E1 that's
beautiful queen takes Bishop you take
with a check and queen F3 Checkmate yes
those are the moves that a computer of
course spits out in seconds for a human
would be quite difficult to find but
there are also other options in this
position in either case I believe that
would be nbe's idea but after A6 of
course white doesn't have to comply and
move the Knight but instead can play
another move for example Bishop D4 looks
very sensible to once again control
these important squares on the long
diagonal and here it seems after let's
say queen takes A2 the Knight is coming
back white is consolidating wow the king
is somewhat safe on E3 and white can
bring the queen and the Rooks the heavy
piece into the game and maybe take over
so maybe a very smart decision by
aronian to invite Queen B2 check which
apparently was not the best choice for
black and now it seems that white could
maybe take the advantage unbelievable
leavon known as the magician Peter has
he just pulled off a Houdini run here
could easily be yeah this is very much
uh leevon in his true Spirit yeah he
loves all this artistic this incredible
kind of scener finding balance Harmony
out of total chaos yeah the move Knight
takes B5 it's it's almost caused us a
total heart attack and it turns out that
it's a fantastic judgment yeah Queen B2
check seems to be a devastating check
but after King EC suddenly white is kind
of safe what do did the players d8 was
played actually so we might have been
mistaken it seems Rook d8 instead of
Queen B2 was played oh wow after all so
an a different approach by nck instead
of coming in with a check the lines that
we were analyzing perhaps nck felt that
White's King on E3 is surviving he did
see the construction of Defense with
white pieces and first brings another uh
Toy to the party brings that Rook from
f8 to d8 lining up against the king to
D2 a big threat now not only to take
that C4 Pawn but to further push the D
Pawn up the board D4 a big Pawn roll
it's all about the compensation for that
piece and once that pawn moves up the
board it's clear with the D4 and the E4
Pawn there is a long-term compensation
yeah and those DTX C4 check yeah opening
up some more files is is very much in
the air Luke d8 was the move in the
spirit because Queen B2 check King EC
would have given white the perfect
harmony as long as the king stays on D2
white is in a big danger yeah so he
needs to find some incredible miracle I
was even wondering if Queen A1 is a move
or not but that allows D Tak C4 check
okay who who knows what's going on but
Peter I think what you said first
intuitively that you really want to S
step your king from this defile if this
is a blitz or a bullet game I think 99%
of us would make the move King C2 but we
see leevon he's still thinking both
players now on almost at a 2- minute
Mark nck a little over leavon under 2
minutes King C2 would be the most
natural move to me in this position and
it is the best move in the position in
fact it has been played King C2 has been
played and in inant reply by nbec Knight
C6 which is a big mistake in fact after
Knight C6 white can now take on D5 which
is a natural move to stop D4 happening
and if the Rook is taking back to drop
back with the bishop to A3 and Bishop C4
lining up here the Rooks and the King on
this A2 G8 diagonal is a very strong
threat and very difficult to stop the
king is slowly finally getting to safety
to B1 this bishop is out of place on H4
we would need on G7 or h8 and I don't
really see how how black is continuing
the attack maybe A6 looks sensible to
get access to the D4 square but even
then after Knight C3 Knight D4 check it
is just one check the king drops back to
B1 and the attack doesn't continue white
is threatening to take to place Bishop
C4 Play Bishop B2 consolidate further
yeah so well we have to get back to the
position because honestly it some a lot
is happening here now if every move they
are solo on time it will be an absolute
time scramble right now guys this is
chaos this position is complete chaos
and it just shows we see the evalar
going up and down how difficult it is
for the players to be accurate in these
position uh Peter once again black moved
forward with the Knight Levon comes back
with the Knight the D4 Pawn lands on the
board and we see the moves are being
blitzed out I see that our evalar likes
white but I'm I'm Still Loving those
Central pawns that nck has yeah this is
a total mess I I wouldn't really be
daring to judge to anyone's favor uh and
we do see the clock situation yeah 11
one down to 1 minute 10 seconds against
2 minutes uh the big question is if
white will be able to coordinate all his
pieces then things will be kind of clear
yeah he's up material but as long as uh
let me just highlight The Rook on H1
Rook on G1 and leevon finds a way to
activate his Queen with a Tempo hitting
that Bishop on
H4 I'm loving this and eventually also
Rook G3 and then activate that hook from
H1 finally The Rook on H1 which has been
there from the starting of the position
can see the end of the tunnel can see
the light at the end of the tunnel and
we see the bishop had to fall back Will
Leon take this time to bring that Rook
into play finally make something off
that extra piece one does get the
feeling that the Firepower from the
attack has been neutralized yes exactly
now I'm even seeing some ideas like Rook
GC rook ag1 and Rook takes G6 check
might be a threat clearly black will
somewhere push D4 D3 which however can
even sometimes be answered by a peace
sacrifice with Bishop D takes D3 and we
get clity but also black is not for
white is not forced to do that but
leavon takes the bishop okay that's a
completely different approach and we see
trades and now with the players uh
playing on the clock as well as much on
the board the moves are coming in really
quick and we see the attack shifting
from the center of the board to the
queen side as Nyack strikes with A4
trying to open up the B line it's still
anybody's game Peter yeah it's now a
strategic battle because actually uh
black just keeps his Pawn on D4 yeah A1
immediately activates the bishop and
Bishop C4 check now where does this
black king go this is a very big
question probably should go to to G7
yeah because after all we have this D4
Pawn but look at this cemented Bishop on
B3 which means that black eventually
will have to Target it with Knight A5
and double on the B file to to make good
use of it but then all of a sudden the
D4 Pawn will be weak uh why dark Bishop
from B2 will be hitting the D4 pawn and
look at all the pieces all the problems
that if that pawn Falls that will be
game over for black so you have to be
careful I'm trying to think of ways how
black can continue this attack because
in a sense Nicholas white has an extra
piece and that Bishop on B2 the absolute
monster that Peter is highlighting the
bishop on B3 taking away key squares
from Black's Army as well how do you see
the way forward how does black continue
to find compensation for the material
here well honestly there are not many
ways forward Peter pointed out Knight A5
Knight takes B3 to get rid of this
Knight to get rid of this bishop and to
somehow get through to the white King on
the B fou but this has its drawbacks
since the pawn on D4 which is very
important also protecting the black king
would be weak and queen E7 has been
played yeah it seems to be dropping this
Pawn as both players do get low on time
here's a pin on the G file and white can
take a very important Pawn because they
was stabilizing the center and it seems
that arunan is taking over completely
and should win this game but with little
time in the clock you never really know
in either case even though Queen E7 was
a mistake already white was winning
because white has stabilized and and
there's no way really to get through but
now if he plays Queen takes F5 yeah and
he has played it I believe then he
should win it's on the board and the
fact that nck slows down after Queen
takes Pawn Peter did nck miss this idea
completely that the G6 Pawn is pinned
yeah obviously yeah it's now he pushes
the pawn to E3 it's it's more like a
panic reaction he has to do something
but he knows exactly that he has a
losing
position uh but as Nicholas said it
wasn't just because of the blunder yeah
it already everything went wrong white
stabilized white has the the the extra
material the extra piece and that Bishop
finally got back to B2 guarding White's
King there is not much Levon needs to
worry about
anymore what a turnaround this has been
Lan aronian under pressure from the
start of the G game his King being
chased all the way from the G1 Square in
the starting position lands on the B1
Square now complete control of the
position look at that beautiful queen on
D3 stopping the advance of the pawns
putting pressure on the D4 Pawn
eventually the white Pawn can also dream
about getting to F5 starting to think
about attacking the black king The Rook
from G1 could slide over to E1 or a rook
lift to G3 putting more pressure on that
E3 Pawn notice how that Bishop on B2
pins the D4 Pawn suddenly nbec feeling
the pressure we can see it on his face
on the
camera yeah this is some incredible
advertisement for freestyle chest this
this game is Just stunning yeah what we
have witnessed here and also this
Mastery what we are also talking about
that what kind of challenges the players
are faced with here with all these new
constructions and all the all kind of
new motifs just
incredible and now NC's the one with 10
seconds on the clock he needs to make a
move but it's the panic button one more
time as we see a sacrifice on the board
uh Peter I don't think this is about
calculation I don't think this is uh
anything but desperation by nck yeah but
on the other hand it's the right
practical choice because you have to
eliminate that monster bishop and after
8 xbc he wants to jump Knight B4 kicking
that Queen away and if White's Queen
moves to C4 then suddenly black gives
Queen E4 check and black might be
winning you might take on D4 after
Knight B4 yes there are many possible
but I'm just highlighting that yeah it's
still not over yet it's it's chaotic
absolute chaos and in this kind of a
position he does fall back with the king
so now he's sidest stepping that check
your idea of Knight jumping onto B4
give black one more move Knight B4 D3
and we're suddenly talking about a
completely different game exactly yeah
so Le also done to 15 seconds so this is
not over yet yeah this is definitely not
over because he finds the best move
Bishop A3 and not very an easy move to
play to move the bishop away from the
diagonal but it was so important to stop
this Knight B4 move that you guys were
highlighting and Bishop A3 was clearly
the best best move Rook B8 but how much
time do they have 20 seconds both
players oh my God this is so difficult
now arunan should win but anything can
still happen he's up an entire rook and
we're still talking about nb's chances
it's all about that White's King
position it's all about King safety here
if nck is able to press the chaos button
put more pressure on B3 and as you're
highlighting a really nice defensive
move by leavon aronian a second rank
defense Rook was not only coming to B2
to protect B3 but also defend the that
key Bishop on A3 which is stopping
Knight B4 yes basically this is the
first moment when we can really feel
humanly that okay yeah that's it uh but
with 10 20 seconds on the clock if you
suddenly manag to ask one more question
and the move Queen E6 is a very nice
move look at Black's construction Knight
on C6 Queen on E6 Perfect Harmony black
might be going for Rook B8 hitting the
Beast three one after Rook B2 we gonna
be hitting the bishop back again with
Rook a eight so leevon needs to break
the king side with F5 and I want to
follow up that line that white cannot
step up with the King to A2 to defend
that Bishop on A3 cuz suddenly there'll
be a FK on B4 with the Knight jumping in
so still lot of tactics to play for but
Levon is now on the attack the rook and
the queen lined up putting pressure on
the F5 Pawn for NRE it's not about
defending the pawns but he needs to find
the tempos to put in his own attack if
white was to capture on F5 Rook B8 your
move will be in the position yes but now
he is opening up on the other hand yeah
Queen takes F5 one needs to C Queen
takes F5 Queen takes BC Rook B2 and then
probably we are mating but L goes King
C1 wow what is this queen E4
positional he's he's offering a queen
trade but yeah L F4 is just in time King
E6 King D5 will be
played down a rook offering a queen
trade for those Pawns in the center
black king finding activity nyback still
fighting Nicholas are there chances hold
this I mean those pawns on D3 E3 look
menacing um honestly his position is
much better than husand a few moves ago
he could even win this the computer
right now is saying small adventure for
white but this doesn't mean anything
right now look at these pawns on D3 on
E3 look at the black pieces they're
perfectly placed the king is active The
Rook is pinning the bishop the Knight is
ready to jump in I would take black here
especially with 20 seconds on the clock
this was so well done by up to keep on
the pressure to keep keep posing
questions and that that's what you need
to do in a losing position and now he
Place The Rook over to G2 this is losing
he can just take the bishop but he
misses it he plays D2 check what is
going on now white has to take on D2 and
eliminate all the pawns it should be a
draw finally so here instead of D2 he
could have taken on A3 and win the game
but
D2 yeah he takes he takes very sensible
very practical decision takes an h s so
now it should be a draw uh rook and
Knight Against The Rook my goodness what
a roller coaster guys yes and we have
seen the body language of Levon Leon
cannot believe what we have just
witnessed yes it's true that he was in
danger in the middle game but afterwards
he stabilized he was definitely already
dreaming of winning this game and all of
a sudden he has to settle in for this
position where he still needs to show
some accuracy I don't think we can
believe I don't think anyone can
watching can believe what we've just
witnessed in this game an absolute
roller coaster up and down so many
twists and turns and for our newer
audience let's point out that the rook
and night versus Rook even if white did
not have these two pawns on the board is
a theoretical draw it is a draw it will
be held to me it feels the kind of Chess
that we saw in this game Peter an entire
book can be written about this game with
all the complications and somewhere both
players deserve to win but a draw would
that would you call that a fair result I
I would feel like it's a fair result I
think that probably both players
eventually can leave with it on the
other hand clearly Levon will be the one
more disappointed because he s like it
had been already in his bag but now
talking about the position actually
white will set up this rooke h8 H7
construction is black even able to pick
that pawn up or is this just some kind
of a total
Fortress and the reason you go King to
D7 and not King to E7 if we can just
highlight with arrows if white was to
Black was to ever make the move King E7
white goes in with your idea of Rook to
C8 uh is probably the square you're
looking at and you take on 87 there
would have been a check grabbing The
Rook so none of that so instead nck
trying to get a rook Knight versus Rook
he wants to hit that Rook on h8
eventually grab on H7 it's still a draw
yes it is a it is a draw uh and it will
be played yeah Mo well I don't know if
50 but basically if the opponent signals
that he wants to play it can be a very
long game yeah it's there are some
players who believe that this is dead I
have zero chances but knowing Abdus sat
being an incredible fighter he will be
enjoying
this and Nicholas we've enjoyed this
game so much from the very start NC
sacrificing a peace for attack against
levon's King playing a really beautiful
Masterpiece of tactics of how to
continue the attack and then Levon
pulling a Houdini somehow escaping with
his King from the king's side all the
way to the Queen's side just phenomenal
play do you think perhaps nbak would be
slightly more disappointed with the once
this ends in a draw well like Peter said
both players will probably be
disappointed I think leevon will be
disappointed more because his position
was completely winning I mean he was up
rook after all he was in full control
but you really have to give credit to
nck for posing problems for posing
questions and when aronian was low on
time this move F5 maybe was the first
step into wrong uh wrong direction and
then the end game was very tricky with
the with the pass pawns by black and the
active King so now we are in this end
game which I was actually playing myself
this year as well in a classical game it
can take some time it is a draw but well
I don't know how you feel how you feel
about it guys I would also just play it
always because there is the chance maybe
once in 100 games or maybe more often
that you win it so you just try and notc
is a fighter and heon wants to really
really try it and I think most players
will try it in this tournament I don't
know how about you guys 100% you play
this out till the end the main idea for
black in these positions in these kind
of end games is to try to dream about
and eventually try to Corner your
opponent's king that's where you can get
mating chances if White's King could
find its way to the corner but there are
defensive setups there are enough checks
in White's position to make sure that
the king stays in the center of the
board and we see the players have gained
so much time on the clock uh that they
know exactly what they're doing the move
counter uh continues and I'm trying to
see when it started and there we see the
idea that before black could give a
check it's white that gives a check
driving Black's King back so leevon
Arona knows exactly what he's doing here
and uh Peter this will go down to the 50
move rule where with no improvement in
the position it will end with a draw uh
most probably I also want to highlight
one very important practical aspect as
well that uh the game has been such a
roller coaster ride and it was so
fascinating then it was some crazy time
trouble all kinds of tactics looming in
there and that means that the players
heart rates and heart situation nerves
had been really challenged to the
maximum and this is not kind of a
therapy situation yeah because you
suddenly have time to come down you know
exactly that there are no real surprises
anymore you are torturing your you are
grinding your opponent not really
expecting to to to win it but okay who
knows maybe the chance appears at the
same time you are calming yourself done
and uh basically it gives you also a
little bit more pause before the next
game yeah because let's not forget the
the the schedule is very demanding once
the players are finishing their games
most probably the new drawing of lots
will take place with the new position
and if you're going in from a crazy time
scramble into that situation can be very
tricky to handle very nice as you
explained psychologically it is a good
moment to calm down and Peter if you can
just see the move counter where was The
Pawn on 87 grabb that was the first big
positional change the last big
positional change that happened and uh
we're going to get a quick update on how
many more moves to go before the draw
but as Peter said it's also about
calming your nerves and this first two
days of Rapid are are very important for
the players because the standings of the
rapid will determine your seedings going
into the classical knockout stage of the
freestyle goat challenge so it will
determine who you play in the
quarterfinals uh which is a very
important point for these players so
they want to get their best performance
in and what is the move counter that
we're on well it's move 63 when black
has captured on H7 there is still tons
of action ahead uh but I also would like
to speak a little bit about the format
because when I first read about the
format i s like wow it's really clever
because first of all the players don't
have so much experience with freestyle
chess yeah so every single game will
give you so much experience and before
starting with the classical section with
The Knockout uh all of the players will
get seven valuable experiences yeah they
will be getting so much out of these
games so we are having this 25 minutes
uh uh rring section uh for seven games
and knowing that every single player is
a brilliant player here I don't really
feel like you you can have pick someone
yeah you you just see that everybody is
very dangerous the whole freestyle chess
is very unpredictable you don't know
where the danger is coming and uh this
case the players will be already
completely completely warmed up and
we'll be feeling uh ready for the for
The Knockout stage absolutely and the
classical knockout stage will begin
after the round robin of the rapid it
gives them experience we will have the
seedings we will have the pairings based
on the final rankings of these eight
players in the rapid and we see now a
check on the board with wh King still in
the center you could even move it up I
don't see a very uh a very threatening
discovered check with the knight uh he
decides to keep it Lebon decides to keep
it on the second rank far away from many
checks nbe fully focused trying to look
for his chances and now I'm expecting
the king to go up you never really want
to come down to the last rank in these
end games to hold yes yeah then then it
gets a bit scary and if it gets scary
you get nervous and you can make a
mistake yeah so that's why you want to
keep it as simple as possible on the
other hand now black has fine this
construction with Knight on if yeah King
G3 is kind of nice yeah now black is
coming closer and this is a typical idea
yeah that you pin the knight from from
behind like before LEL with from E8 or
now he switches from the side defense
with Rook B4 check he's trying to kick
that King away like this in any case
level not knows exactly that he should
be holding this but uh n back is also
still hoping for some miracle and now
again you're thinking do you really want
to put your King on H4 do you really
want to put your King on H2 these are
always very dangerous Quest so he
doesn't do it you want to keep it as
close to the center of the board being
the defender in this position and now
another 20 moves of Defense required by
Levon as we hit the move counter to 93
yeah here the the good news for the
defending side is and have to highlight
that when black has a rook and the
bishop then the defensive task is so
much more difficult and there are so
much more mating ideas uh with the
Knight the Knight and Rook combo is is
really only causing some trouble if
White's King is boxed in the corner
which Leon will never let happen and
maybe it's a good chance for us to to
jump back to to some position where we
had all this dramatic action Nicholas
take it from yes there's not that much
happening in the game right now will
most likely end in a draw so I would
like to take the chance to go slowly
through the dramatic moments in this
game where it all turned from a winning
position for Leon Ronan to for one
moment even a losing position then
resulting in the end game that we're
seeing right now so it started here with
the move F5 which is still fine but
maybe it would have been better to
prepare this move with a move like Rook
F1 or Rook G1 because in this very
moment there's not too much that black
is threatening so Rook F1 for example if
Rook B8 then white could defend this
Rook B2 and if the Rook drops back this
was an idea that you pointed out Peter
but here white has to move B4 and
everything is defended everything is
very very very safe very protected for
white so there are not too many ideas
for black and white has the time to play
a quiet move like Rook F1 or Rook G1 or
even the computer is saying H4 just
something uh not immediate action was
necessary this is still winning but it's
it's getting a little bit more tricky
because suddenly black has more pawns to
work with King E7 a very smart move by
uh nyback to step out of the ideas here
and already here it's getting tricky I
mean the the best move according to
engine Rook A1 human would probably
never play this move Rook to A1 here
looks very strange and the second best
move is H4 also not a human move by any
means and then Rook G1 this makes more
sense to me but already you can tell the
win has become more difficult and um so
in the game after King C1 Queen E4 was a
very smart practical decision to go into
his end game to rely on the pawns and to
rely on the activity and here already
after Rook F4 which apparently was a
mistake Rook G1 was necessary but you
really don't want to deal with these
pawns anyway Rook F4 makes a lot of
sense to win the pawn but already here
the advantage has mostly gone and now it
all even turned even though after King
D5 there was a moment to to win again
with Rook G4 but once again it is all
very very difficult and after Rook H4 D3
the advantage has gone and now Rook G2
was even the game losing blunder by
Ronan here nck had a chance to take the
Rook not to fear any ghost because of
the Rook G5 check which he was probably
afraid of Knight E5 and now Rook H H5
there's the genius way forward to play
King D4 King For the Win here in the end
game after Rook e E5 the the pawn is
coming forward and these pawns are
deciding the game and and black would be
even winning we have to come back to the
current position I believe we do as we
have a result coming in Nicholas you
will show us all the dramatic moments I
think there wasn't one there were plenty
of them but in the end of this chaotic
game an absolute top seater ofair it
ends peacefully nck Leon aronian shared
the point after a hard fought battle and
look at this I'm always loving this that
the the players understand that they
played something special yeah they are
discussing with each other it's also the
moment to come little bit done exchange
the ideas what did you think where
things have turned and uh it just shows
that yeah this was a dramatic game ABD
sat also shaking his head a bit like yes
I had a chance I knew that I had you but
then Leon says come on but I was winning
also it takes two to make a special game
of chess and I think both these players
lived up to that task uh not Beck not
shying away from combative play from
throwing his pieces literally and
figuratively at his opponent's Camp
sacrificing material but Lev on AR onion
also with extremely creative resources
eventually being the one who was able to
make the most of that material advantage
and in the end we saw it fizzle it out
in seconds to a draw I would love to
take this game from the very top because
starting from the starting position and
the way we saw it explode so early on it
was a very very special game Nicholas
yes it was it was a very special game if
we go back to the beginning of the game
like you pointed out it started with the
sacrifice in the seventh move already in
the seventh move in this very position
nbec decided to change the course of the
game and sacrifice the bishop on G2 and
we saw that for the next 30 40 moves was
playing without with a piece down but he
had long-term compensation in form of
creating an attack against the white
king and then in the middle
game we were always saying we like black
we we would love to take black here
practically it's very difficult but
aronia managed to defend and in the end
it was actually nck who had to be who
had to be very very lucky or had to be
very happy that he could get this draw
if I just want to finish this one line
that I was showing earlier with the
excuse me so just going here we saw I
just want to show you this one moment
where nbec could have won the game and
he played very quickly he still had some
time he had one minute on the clock and
he played D2 instantly then The Rook was
traded and then we reached this endg
game Rook against rook and Knight which
was eventually a draw but he had the
opportunity to play Rook takes A3 here
which of course he saw to take the
bishop and now the idea must have been
by Aon to go Rook G5 check and here it
was important to realize that after the
doubling on the fifth Rank and winning
this pinned Knight on E5 black can
actually step forward with the King and
these pawns D2 check they will Queen
here King B2 now Rook takes B3 check
this is not an easy line by any means of
course The Rook is sacrificing itself
for another Pawn now black is Queen in
and in fact after a king move let's say
white has to give up a rook for the pawn
and then black should win this position
with the queen against The Rook not easy
but that was a chance and then after D2
check we reached this position and it
was a draw what a game guys incredibly
impressive play by nyback down an entire
Rook but managing to find counterplay in
that end game with the pawns and the
Kings combined this is a game one for
the history books let's bring up our
results after round one of the round
robin and there we see two decisive
results for fighting games it is Ali RZA
fuja and Fabiano Karana who take their
first wins with the black pieces Ali RZA
takes down GES Fabiano with a big win
against the world champion Tingler and
Magnus Carlson Vincent ker perhaps the
most peaceful game of the Round And even
though leavon versus nbec ended
peacefully it was anything but absolute
Chaos on the board perhaps the game of
the round peder and uh we will be back
with game to action as we will have the
reveal of the next position very soon
don't go anywhere we'll be back in just
a
[Music]
few this format is completely new with
is classic uh longtime chess for
freestyle chess and so we want to begin
a new era of Chess and we are looking
forward what will happen in the next
days here and then also probably we can
make a tour or something like this Yan
want always to make the best event ever
and zo was very easy he give me give me
the chance that I can make everything
what I like the best team and with the
best location here at wison house and we
build it in such an exciting way that is
really the best tournament ever magnos
met uh Yan at Qatar at the open in
October and he was completely committed
with Yan about this tournament and to
enter new GS in chess everybody is
radiant of joy and looking forward
that's the games will begin and I think
this is so amazing here and every player
taugh to me Sebastian great I'm here and
so fantastic and I'm in a good mood and
I think I will play my best chess
ever
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
he
[Applause]
[Music]
he
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back everyone we are about to
kick off our second game of the round
robin our second game of the day and if
anything was to go by with the ACT that
we saw we are in for quite the ride uh
and Peter we were discussing so much
action that we also had the world number
one Magnus play against wincent it was a
peaceful game but there was some
highlights there yes especially in the
very beginning and I would like to show
it that was a moment we discussed yeah
so Magnus played E4 E5 yeah so
everything normal B3 D6 D4 Knight D7 and
C4 Magnus occupying the center it seems
like like okay he needs just one or two
more moves to stabilize his Advantage
with the space Advantage however Vincent
send the moment that this is a very
critical moment if he just lets Magnus
get his grip he will be in for a very
tough defense and he find a very direct
approach by going e takes
D4 Bishop takes D4 and B7 B5 break yeah
just in time to sacrifice this Pawn but
it's not the sacrifice because suddenly
white is hitting the E4 pawn and thanks
to this tactical shot he was able to
disbalance the position after C takes B5
Queen takes E4 we are getting some kind
of an end game where one could feel like
ah this is very much magnus's territory
he's such a grounder he is one of best
player in in end games but Vincent felt
like he has time to challenge this B5
pawn and Magnus never really got
anything after Knight D3 A6 very
important to get rid of this Monster
Pawn on B5 just give white one more move
to play Knight B4 and then suddenly B5
Pawn will stay forever the weaknesses in
Black scam the C6 Square for example
imagine white trades that Bishop Bishop
F3 Bishop takes F3 G takes F3 and that
Knight will jump in all the weak light
squares uh Vincent felt it he breaks it
with A6 just in time and then Magnus
find nothing better than to go Bishop F3
takes takes and this was already roughly
equal position which Vincent managed to
hold without any problems very instru
RVE nicely explained there Peter and
also very nicely handled by wincent
going for this active way to neutralize
White's pressure sacrificing the First
Pawn on B5 for that Central Pawn
eventually trading it off with A6 and uh
it ended in a draw and look at what we
have in front of us we've got Magnus
we've got Fabiano Carana sitting
opposite him and leavon aronian sitting
next to him analyzing the different
positions uh trying to understand these
intricacies that exist in uh the
freestyle format the start of the game
where is this do we have a reveal we
have our game to position it is ladies
and gentlemen in front of us the players
are discussing it we're going to discuss
it in our studio Peter what is your
first impression well first impression
is that it's a very strange position
because uh wh's Rook on A1 and Rook on
H1 is like a normal situation on the
other hand this white King on C1 and
Queen on B1 is already some kind of a
strange spot and contrary to the
previous previous game where White had a
or both sides had a bishop already in
the corner on the diagonal yet there is
no such monster Bishop uh at this stage
yeah so we see a symmetrical position as
are the rules of Fisher random In
freestyle chess your King has to be
between the two Rooks your two Bishops
have to be in the opposite color uh
squares it's all there in front of us
and also in front of us the big Indian
Talent GES he's sitting by himself in
his own Zone analyzing the start of the
position he plays with the white pieces
Nicholas it's so interesting the
different approaches the players have
before the start of the round we saw the
three greats Fabby Magnus Levon discuss
and here we have one youngster in
solitude yes and we see that he's also
playing some moves on the board and well
I I like his approach also just thinking
about the position himself because it
can be quite distracting to discuss with
the players you lose some time and he's
playing different moves over the board
and we'll see which approach in the end
will yield the better results but I
think it makes a lot of sense and it's
it's fun to see him just uh pondering
the position and figuring out what to do
with the white pieces in his game
against Magnus Carlson he was playing
against Magnus and this is of course a
very big game for him and another big
game is going to be ding versus n back
and we see ding as well by exactly
exactly this is what I wanted to
highlight immediately that both players
who lost game one and we talked about
this that for them getting the Rhythm
getting that comfort zone that they feel
comfortable and be able to show their
best yeah and they feel like no no no no
no I want to have my quiet five little
minutes before the game to have my own
thoughts the other players yeah if you
are talking with Magnus or leavon yeah
those are such great personalities also
yeah they tell you something even if you
are having some different thoughts you
might be you know confused yeah that
okay what is it what I'm thinking about
the position is maybe wrong if you don't
know anything what the big Gres are
saying you at least have your own vision
and you will trust your own
intuition you got big matchups that are
about to begin while the world champion
dingin will take on nbec Abdus satra who
had an absolutely Wild game in game one
against Levon Levon will be playing
against Winston K who was able to hold
his own with the black pieces against
the world number one Magnus Carlson
Magnus there continues his analysis
Peter this is such a special visual that
we're seeing we never get to see this in
the Chess World just before moments
before the players will make their first
move they're actually sitting with each
other trying to understand the position
that that we have and I think it's a
good moment to Deep dive into the
position that we have uh we see the
again once again the minor pieces take
most of the right hand side of the board
while the queen and the Rook are on the
left left side of the board what are the
opening ideas that you think we can
expect from the players in this one well
before we get into it let me just say
that yeah this is incredible I don't
think that it can get any stronger yeah
then Fabby Magnus and Leon sitting at
the same position discussing uh things
but uh there are no guarantees yeah this
is this is freestyle chess uh nothing is
given and uh yeah now we can start to
focus and dig in ourselves so we talked
about this that the two Rooks are in the
original position like in classical
chess yeah Rook on H1 and Rook on A1
this can be quite confusing in In
freestyle chess yeah because the queen
on B1 next to the King on C1 this bishop
on D1 Bishop G1 honestly whenever I play
Freestyle chess or fish random I really
love if my Bishop is like in the
previous run already fian in the in the
corner yeah that gives you so much
stability now you have to think about
what do I do with this bishop on G1 it
can't stay there forever the bishop on
D1 is a very special kind of piece where
do you develop it yeah which which
direction to go so many questions yeah
we saw there Fabby he brings all his
pieces back so a new approach being
tried while the players have the
analysis time they're looking at
potential opening moves uh and I saw the
F Pawn moving forward for black there to
the response of this D4 move that is an
option in this position a kind of a
Dutch in a normal standard chess uh we
can't use opening names for freestyle
chess but a Dutch in this position will
have very different implications
Nicholas yes it is a big question how to
start with the white pieces here and
that's what they're discussing or rather
how to respond also with the black
pieces and we see them try B on H3
Nicholas yes it is it immediately felt
me like it's a banker Gambit yeah they
are playing the banker gun there yes
Pawn on H3 putting the bishop on H2 to
activate the bishop on the sty this
makes a lot of sense because then it's
pointing towards the black queen that
would be a funny first move if they went
H2 H3 or H2 H4 but maybe maybe smart it
is a big question what to do with the
queen on B1 and on B8 because obviously
the queen is the strongest piece in
chess so you want to activate and you
also want to maybe get it out of the way
of the king so this feels like a more
difficult position even than the one
before it's even less clear oh how do
you guys see it yeah absolutely I I'm
completely with you yeah in the previous
game we F like there is some some some
clearness Yeah you mentioned the move E4
and B3 it was very much that yeah we
want to make those moves here I have Z
feeling and I wouldn't be surprised if
in every single game we'll be seeing
completely different first
moves and I think it is go time we do
have liftoff on our boards as we see the
players are on their seats well
somebody's missing on their seat right
now and let's also tell everyone and
there we see world number two Fabiano
Carana he comes in he's ready to go
Magnus Carlson through those Bishops and
knights awkwardly placed we saw him he's
ready to go and there's a first move on
the GES boat he starts with I'm
hesitating but I will call this the
bird's opening even though it's
freestyle chess one F4 he opens up that
Bishop that is on G1 uh and we see the
position on the board so he's opening up
the diagonal with his first move Peter
and we immediately saw a response by
Magnus moving a multi-purpose Pawn there
not only opening up the queen eyeing the
F4 square but eventually that black
Bishop on d8 also finds development
yes but this is exactly the Big
Challenge in uh In freestyle chess yeah
that if you develop the bishop for
example to C7 which looks like a very
nice square but then what do you do with
the queen on B8 yeah it's kind of a very
very complicated question with did C G3
F5 being played Magnus look at this
black is already threatening to win the
game with Bishop D5 the luk on H1 uh
okay it's not a win yet because white
can play Knight FC but certainly it's
kind of annoying um and also just get
Harmony in the position yeah I'm I'm
really liking what Magnus is doing on
the other hand Everything is Everything
depends on long-term prospects yeah
that's that's yeah Knight F3 white is
also stabilizing the position it's so
tough to play and that's what we love
about it the players really have to put
their thinking caps on from the very
start usually we see the knight from G1
jumping onto F3 and that would be
completely standard but here it lands on
F3 from that King Square white King on
C1 already a half castled position for
white if you can get and for black if
you can develop the queen and the bishop
you simply put that Rook from A8 on d8
and call it uh call it a day for your
king you say I've got my king to safety
I'm finishing my development do you
think that's going to be a priority in
this position I'm not sure yeah because
it comes at the cost of some other
things one of the problems I'm seeing
with with this position that for example
how do we develop this Knight on F1 yeah
if it jumps to E3 then it blocks the
diagonal of the bishop on G1 yeah so I'm
somehow even tempted to play something
like DC Knight one to D2 eventually
maybe bishop F2 then do something with
my C pawn and slowly develop the good
news is that it does not seem like there
is any direct confrontation in the
position yeah if if there's no direct
confrontation then we can afford
ourselves to take it slowly yeah but uh
if for example black might play
something like D6 and we threaten to
open up the center with D5 immediately
then we have to adjust to it
instantly wow Nicholas it's already an
exciting start to this game and the
players are slowing down we see a move
by Magnus and this is the one that I was
hinting at earlier you open up the
bishop diagonal if there is a trade on
B6 it would be on magnus's terms opening
up the a
file yes this is um definitely a very
interesting approach by Magnus to to
trade the Bishops to open up the AFL I
would like to jump to another game
because the players have taken a very
different approach in the opening as
expected and in the game between Abu zov
and dingl ren it has gone pretty well
for the player from usbekistan so let's
have a look he start with D4 so not like
gach with won F4 and ding respond with
D5 all right and C3 we've seen this move
actually in a lot of games as we're
going to see it makes sense to open up
the queen uh open up this diagonal for
the queen and also open up the bishop
and now after Knight D6 to to control
the center F3 was played a good move to
play E4 next to have a strong Center and
in fact dingl Ren allowed this after
Knight G6 E4 was played and here white
has a beautiful Center and believe it or
not in this position already white is in
very very good shape according to the
computer already a very clear ADV but if
you look at the position it does make
sense because white has a beautiful
Center the pieces can come out naturally
the black pieces look not so well placed
not so harmonious so quite a great start
for apto zov and dingl ran might be
continuing to struggle
Tanya very nicely pointed out and I
think the key Point here that you made
was that how easy it is for white to
develop the pieces that knight from E1
can jump to D3 that Bishop from D1 can
land on G4 as Peter is highlighting the
squares and it comes in with a check
you're getting your pieces out with a
check you already control the center
eventually the queen from B1 can move
one step ahead to C2 and that castle
Peter that I was dreaming of at the
start we might see it become a reality
yes and then it makes perfect sense yeah
because you are also immediately
attacking Black's vulnerable spots yeah
and and I do feel like Black's King yeah
Bishop G4 check is played yeah you are
kind of forcing provoking the mo Pawn to
E6 yeah not back is going Queen
C2 getting ready to Castle as quickly as
possible black is in a lot of trouble
and I feel like uh notb is some kind of
a freestyle chess monster yeah he's so
energetic so he's so aggressive putting
tremendous pressure on his opponents
right from the start he was the
semi-finalist of the Fisher random World
Championship in 2022 when Hikaru
Nakamura knocked him out in the semis
but what a run he had had in that that
one he definitely has experience in this
format which as you had pointed out
earlier in our broadcast is so key uh to
understand how to maximize your
development potential how quickly to
play with the tempos on the board and
here we see white play is just flowing
with tempos meanwhile that black Bishop
on G8 caged by its own pawns on E6 the
bishop on d8 caged by his own Pawn on F6
it's still very difficult to imagine
black getting an activity and Peter you
pointing out in this case should I call
it a long
Castle well it's short it's short I'm
going on the king side but yeah
certainly this gives some stability yeah
if if black is able to evacuate his King
from the danger zone uh and and the King
on C8 cannot really stay there forever
in fact black even cannot really afford
to Castle long because it would still
run into some
problems yeah ding is trying to
stabilize his position and limit the
damage and let's not for it's it's
freestyle chest so at the moment for
example it might look very good for
white then suddenly black stabilizes and
in couple of moves it might look like
black has a decent position yeah so I'm
still uh bit confused how to evaluate
all these things but at the moment it
really looks still very good for white
well it's a long way to shots side
castling as you're pointing out which
might be the king safety but of course
we might even see the position explode
with the H Pawn moving forward at some
point trying to get that activity
against the black king can we conclude
by saying that nck is happy with the
opening outcome in this one yes certain
certainly yeah more than happy and also
look at the clock situation yeah he he
feels that this is the type of position
that he can play by hand yeah because
you really feel already you know where
the pieces belong and you don't have to
make really difficult strategical
decisions yeah it's much more for black
that for me it was easy to highlight
Bishop C7 short castle and put your king
into safety but then black Queen on B8
will be stuck you highlighted
beautifully that H4 H5 is coming kicking
that Knight away and yeah maybe when we
have to move away from this board
because it it it just hurts my eyes to
to to look at it from Black's
perspective well if anything hurts
Peter's eyes we immediately shift the
focus let's bring up our bird's eye view
and Nicholas you can break down the
action and the opening approaches by the
players in these different openings that
we're seeing in front of us yeah let's
turn to a game that we haven't seen so
far the game between Vincent kimer and
leevon Ronan and here also a similar
approach was taken as in the game
between up Z Turf and ding so if we go
from the start D4 was played so this was
also up to Z tur's choice and here
aronia went for the let's say Dutch
approach with F5 controlling the center
opening up the bishop C3 again this move
to open up the queen hitting instantly
the pawn on F5
which is why aronian play G6 and play in
the center E4 instantly to bring the
queen out good choice by Vincent F takes
E4 Queen takes E4 and now C6 has been
played Vincent has been thinking I also
noticed this in the last game against
magnos he is taking his time in the
beginning but as we pointed out earlier
the very first moves are very very
important so does makes sense he has a
good position here the computer is
suggesting to drop the queen back to E2
which isn't very l iCal to me and I
would bring out one of the knights it's
not so easy in fact there's also this
bishop D5 idea we have to be careful for
difficult to organize here not quite
harmonious but the queen is active this
is good so Vincent is doing well right
now but he needs to figure out how to
bring his remaining pieces into the game
but once again C3 E4 Queen out seems to
be a good approach in this starting
position of freestyle chess
I have some breaking info to share with
all of you we entered the players
meeting the players meeting had not yet
started I'm there with Vincent Levon
joins us big hug I haven't seen Levon
for ages very happy to meet we start
discussing about freestyle chess and
then leevon says you know you know what
yeah people have not yet appreciated
that in Fisher random chess the Dutch
defense with D4 F5 is really strong and
what we see now Vincent was there in
this discussion leevon told me D for F5
and what did we see between these two
gentlemen extraordinary players the
moves D4 F5 and vinan probably headed
that yes yes I will not let him get his
typical Dutch defense I'm challenging
the that Center immediately with C3 G6
E4 just felt like I have to share this
info because this is so valuable and we
see it really happen between them it's
it's stunning yeah and laan Aron now is
walking the talk he me mentioned it and
now he shows that you know what I'm
going to prove my point Winston I told
you in the technical meeting about the
Dutch defense it's on the board show me
your cards show me how you handle it
with white and it also reminds me that
before the start of this round it was
GES who was actually analyzing these
kind of setups we spoke about the Dutch
then so he had it in his mind as well uh
and while Winston thinks about what to
do with this queen that's out early on
and it can come under Fire the Knight
can jump from E8 to F6 the bishop as you
pointed out can go from G8 to D5 and it
can put pressure on the white screen
Winston taking a thing Peter let's zoom
out for a moment let's get our bird's
eye view and do a quick overhaul on the
four boards uh and take a look at the
action on each one of them let's start
from our extreme left it's nbec abdat
the youngest ever World rapid Champion
he's 18 years old now he won the world
rapid championship in 2021 he's playing
Another World Champion the current world
champion ding Len and we see see a lot
more of a solid approach in that one we
will deep dive into it but let's just do
a quick overview uh what do you think
about the other three boards which one
catches your attention well I think that
we haven't really been looking at Ali
against Fabiano and uh both of them had
won their first game they are in
fantastic shape uh let's take a closer
look and look at this they are also
having tremendous amount of
self-confidence by playing so quickly
right in this format and I'm looking at
this bishop on H2 what is this bishop
doing on H2 after white was forced to
close it with G3 Nicholas do you have
any thoughts for us well I'm thinking
Peter this is probably going to hurt
your eyes to look at this position for
too long the bishop on H2 is not in
great shape let's just slowly go through
the opening moves here we saw E4 E5 so a
different approach again this move C3
that we've seen over and over Bishop B3
we also saw in the kson game now this G3
move early on if I may stop it here
quite an interesting choice G3 to
restrict the Knight coming to F4 but
this bishop is not happy about it and
will remain unhappy throughout the next
moves as we go on and Bishop B6 coming
out white occupies the center right now
H4 H5 makes a lot of sense and now
special moment here comes the long short
castle that we've talked about let's
review this once again the Special Rule
In freestyle chess the king can Castle
short if there's nothing between and the
squares are not under attack and this is
what we see here and we end up in the
typical short castle that we know from
that we know from normal chess suddenly
a king is safely tucked away here and in
fact fza did the exact same thing and
now we're almost resembling a normal
position except for this guy on on H5
which is absolutely terrible I think the
black pieces are better placed and look
very harmonious and I think Karana is is
doing an excellent job what is the endan
saying it is agreeing it is giving a
clear Advantage for black already it's
the bishop the bishop is a big problem
isn't it what Bishop that's not a bishop
that's just a big Pawn in White's
position right on H2 G3 played blocking
his own Bishop perhaps wanting to defend
uh that H4 Pawn a really strange
decision taking control of F4 but that
Bishop on H2 is a big eyesore the other
thing that stands out to me in this
position as Nicolas was playing it from
the top pater is that what we have in
front of us it looks like a standard
chess position apart from that Bishop it
just feels like you know why does Castle
develop the pieces we see this big
tension in the center who will blink
first that last move getting D5 in which
pawns do you trade but to me it looks
more like an opening out of a standard
chess game rather than a freestyle chess
game yeah actually the the first
impression that I got when I looked at
this that this is a kind of Italian
opening that went extremely well for
black and uh those who have been
watching my comment to they know exactly
that I'm mov is very critical about any
kind of Bishop G5 uh Italians because
that Bishop may end up in trouble but
getting in so much trouble than right
here right now I I haven't really seen
black has Perfect Harmony White has to
make difficult decisions and yeah now we
see that white is giving up the center
with e takes D5 not a happy Choice the
queen from E8 beautifully protecting the
Knight on G6 because this needs
protection otherwise the queen from B1
is eyeing that Knight Perfect Harmony
for black very tough very tough task
ahead for Al yeah and let's also just
point out that it's not voluntarily that
Al res up with that Bishop on H2 and the
pawn on G3 this came out of a freestyle
chess position where the players started
and maybe you can highlight the square
the bishop was originally on that G1
square and it had to come out so finding
a way to get the king into safety to get
more pieces into safety this is the
structure this is the opening that alira
has chosen the pawn was moved to G3 to
bring another piece out into the game so
it's all about like you said you
sometimes have to sacrifice one piece's
position to be able to take out another
yes but here we see that actually Fabby
managed to get everything done correctly
yeah he was able to trade that Bishop
somehow and uh yeah now we see that Alid
is trying to make sense of his position
going after Black's only defense only
defenseless Pawn the weakness on H5 I
kind of like this attitude because if it
if it's uh getting unpunished then at
least there is some kind of a new flow
in White's
position and the Knight falls back not
only attacking the queen but defending
that H5 Pawn that you highlighted
completely agree uh Peter with
everything that you said that this feels
like a really nice Italian for black
you've gotten rid of the light Squad
Bishop the dark Squad Bishop that white
has is not even a bishop currently at
some point perhaps we might see Ali Resa
go all out with the move G4 just trying
to get that piece into the game to
promote that big Pawn back into a bishop
yes basically if white gets G4 and and
King H1 luk G1 sudden only white can get
some initiative going the uh King side
clearly black is trying to get that kn
C7 to E6 but that's why I'm loving this
Manu of Queen F5 and queen HC very well
played by alar making sure that that
Knight will want land on E6 so yes black
pushes E4 and black will play F5 so that
please forever forget about G3 G4 that's
a really nice positional concept really
trapping that Bishop on H2 taking
control of that G4 Square the only way
for white to actually Break Free we will
keep an eye out on this one but let's
head over to the goat Magnus Carlson who
is taking on gkes and I see Nicholas
you've got an update for us quite an
exciting position yeah it looks very
different than what we've seen in the
other games as it often so happens with
the freestyle chess positions so let's
go back a few moves where we last saw it
after C3 we saw the bishop came out to
B6 trading Bishops and let's go through
it here the Bishops were traded The Rook
takes back obviously the Knight is
coming out trying to control the center
B5 suddenly gaining some space here to
also open up the queen on this diagonal
and now G5 a pawn sacrificed by magnos
and here we have to Curr position the
last move was Rook to E1 here was the
threat that black takes this Pawn on G5
because if the Knight was to take back
then The Rook could be taken on G1 by
the queen so this is why GES moved the
Rook out of the way and I'm still trying
to make sense of the position there's
still a lot of awkward Place pieces this
bishop on D1 the queen is not in the
game but this bishop on G8 is also not
in the game it is a very difficult
position to evaluate uh White is up a
pawn so this is good but on the other
hand the knights are well placed here
also it's a double Pawn I'm really not
sure what to make of it I look at the
engine it says white is a little better
but honestly it doesn't mean much in
this position who would you prefer here
Peter what do you think well it's uh
it's a very difficult position to to the
evaluate I do understand that I first
liked magnus's position yeah that he was
the one who sacrificed the pawn with G5
so clearly had some intentions on the
other hand I also see that white has a
clear plan of eventually going Queen D3
and queen E3 just activating that Queen
offering a queen trade we are Pawn up we
don't really afraid uh getting the
Queens traded on the other hand I do
recall we have seen this pregame
analysis there by Magnus leavon and and
Fabby and we did speak about this that
that was some Banker Gambit kind of
strategy yeah so uh this kind of
sacrifice and then going H6 G takes H6
and getting some play is maybe magnus's
mind but I don't see it really working
so nicely so I I don't believe that H6
is probably the best move here I'm
liking the extra Pawn for White
currently uh Magnus has to prove his
compensation also notice how the pawns
on C3 G3 take away some key squares from
that Black Knight on E6 not really
allowing it to jump into White's Camp
Magnus has to think about how to
actually try to get the initiative that
he sacrificed the pawn for I would love
to improve that Bishop on G8 the one
idea that comes to mind and Magnus does
it he plays the move Bishop F7 also
eyeing the square H5 maybe at some point
The Rook can line up on the G5 uh Peter
putting pressure on that G5 pawns Pawn
ideas like Bishop H5 which I think has
been stopped by this last move gkes
playing Bishop to B3 is saying now when
you move that Bishop to either G6 or H5
he's going to grab that Knight on E6
destroying Black's spawn structure yes
at least that's a serious possibility on
the other hand it gives up the light
squares and eventually if we know
already that black can Castle black can
simply castle like this then if we we
get this transformation of structure let
me just put few moves just so that
better understand what we are talking
about yeah the structure is terrible
white has this E5 Square on the other
hand if black castles then this
combination of Black's monster Bishop on
H5 the light Square bishop and The Rook
posing some real trouble against White's
coordination yeah so such a complex
stuff uh it it really requires lot of
time to to understand and to evaluate
what's really going on here and that's
why Magnus has slowed down as well he's
thinking right now after this last move
by gkes does he want to uh destroy his
Pawn structure for all these points that
you're making open files open diagonals
and unchallenged light Square Bishop the
more I look at it uh the more I start
liking it perhaps Magnus will decide for
another approach trying to just develop
his pieces further lining up improving
the position of that Rook on the H file
he goes for Bishop H5 I was just wanting
to make one more point in freestyle
chess you have to really watch out for
hanging pawns and I think if you go that
back one move the idea of Rook to G8 and
suddenly you notice that pawn on H7 is
not defended it might be a natural move
but this perhaps would have allowed GES
to step up with that E5 pawn and now
that Queen on B1 which should have been
a knight at the start of the game
suddenly opens up and everything falls
apart on the king side so I was just
pointing out Rook G8 would have perhaps
walked into the idea of E5 there's of
course Bishop G6 and things get more
complicated Peter but you have to always
think about hanging Pawns in freestyle
chess yes you have to take care
everything into consideration uh but I
also feel like there had been some move
yeah Magnus is now leaning back no I'm
not sure because that maybe my move can
Nicholas update the position wow Castle
yes whoa wow you castle and you lean
back you are enjoying yourself wow what
are we witnessing here unbelievable It's
a Long Way to the shot Castle as we like
to say In freestyle chess he puts the
King on G8 The Rook goes to f8 we were
talking about activating The Rook but 87
might be weak Magnus finds a cool style
to do it he says you know what my king
is going to go all the way defend the 87
Square uh do you like this decision
Nicholas I mean this is a shocking move
which we didn't have on our radar at all
but you always have to have it on your
radar in freestyle chest that suddenly
here actually both casts were possible
black could have put the Rook over here
I believe uh or as he did he castled to
the all the way to the other side and it
looks risky to me at first because the
king is open here there's not a lot of
Protections in front of not a lot of
Pawns which protect the king in front of
it however we see the Rook instantly
lined up on the open file and I think
magnos is really going for the
initiative here he has sacrificed the
pawn he wants to go for maximum peace
activity maybe bishop H5 next and well
the engine what is the engine saying
about this it says okay you can play
like this it's okay white is still a
little bit better maybe bring the queen
out now this was an idea we talked about
already Queen to D3 maybe Queen E3 next
it is a very open game and quite a bold
decision by Magnus to play like this
Peter yeah look at look at GES he's
completely shocked I think anyone who
would be sitting there from the right
side Magnus Carson going for short
Castle I mean what's what's wrong with
you what is that move yeah and and
probably the reason why Magnus actually
selected this move he he just noticed it
and he felt like probably this is such a
cool move I want to make it no matter
what the consequences are and as
Nicholas said yeah there are there are
lot of hidden Dynamics in the position
so castles is not as insane as it looks
but if you would have asked me before
long before the short Castle open I
would have said no no no no it will
never ever happen but it did happen it
just I'm I'm so happy that I'm here I'm
I'm witnessing this because this is just
fantastic stuff it's also the awareness
that it's even a legal move on the board
the fact because you're just thinking
about putting that Rook on d8 keeping
your King on C8 a queen side Castle but
this was just uh the shock value is
massive of this move and uh we were
making a point about how the king side
it looks like wait a second there's no
G7 Pawn you're just putting your King on
an open line but actually Magnus plans
to use gasia G5 Pawn as a defensive
Shield here gkes wants to get an H4 H5
G6 in but with that light squared Bishop
it's not going to be easy for him to
actually execute a kingside attack
notice how all of White's Army is on the
queen side it's actually perhaps the
safest Square for the black king you're
using the gepon as a shield all of
White's Army is on the other side of the
board no Rooks on the eight in the G
Line This is going to get interesting
very quickly Peter it is already very
interesting and and I feel that this is
incredible in in freeze SNES that we can
give so many arguments to so many of the
decisions and probably so many cont
arguments as well yeah if we are listing
the pros and cons and the players have
to make that decision we we do see that
actually both of these players had taken
their time uh they are more or less
equal on the clock and yes Nicholas you
have some update yes you can finish it
upon then no no I'm I'm already done I'm
I'm ready to jump to you all right yeah
I would like to jump to another game as
here Gish is taking a thing how to
continue and we'll see how this develops
so I'm looking at the game between up to
the turf in dingly Ren and we last I
believe looked at this around this
position we said white is in good shape
so let's just catch up briefly how it
continued from here we saw the bishop
coming out the long Castle in this one
the queen is putting pressure on the
pawn the pawn was dropped after the turf
did win this Pawn on E6 here and this
was just a healthy Pawn that he took and
he has been in good shape since we see
here The Rook coming forward some trades
Knight coming forward and now we
actually enter an end game maybe let me
pause here so it's not too quick so to
understand what happened
here the bishop is pinning the Knight on
this diagonal because the queen is
behind it so black played Knight to e
check Knight to E2 check white gave up
the queen because the the other Queen is
also under attack Queen takes G3 Pawn
takes wow what a wild sequence guys just
to point out here Queen takes E7 which
you could make a point let me also do
the Desperado Queen would be refuted by
Queen G5 check so the queen goes to save
safety and then black could take back
the White Queen on E7 so this is why
Queen takes E7 was not played took back
on G3 Rook takes E2 and we reach this
end game after Knight F4 Rook E3 some
more moves have been played the Rooks
have been
traded and we reach this position where
white is up a pawn still and it is quite
a healthy Pawn I would expect G4 now to
be played this Pawn is under attack and
this is quite a norble position suddenly
a normal end game which could also
result from the normal starting position
with a healthy extra Pawn for up to the
turf who's looking good and dingan seems
to continue to struggle Tanya 100% agree
white has that extra Pawn The Rook on H1
already makes sure that the black king
cannot get to the center of the board
The Rook can even slide onto the center
of the board himself Rook to E1 with
such few pieces left and Knight on D3
really nicely placed as well uh White
can slowly improve his position we might
see Rook e one king D2 coming forward
eventually the C Pawn might start
marching up the board for dingin it's a
game for two results he has to do his
best to hold this position things could
go wrong if the Rooks are traded off
here I think White's chances winning
chances increase dramatically Peter yeah
I think that white has tremendous
winning chances I also don't really see
how black can block the position yeah it
it would be desirable to get that pawn
to B5 uh and if we are talking about L
trade because white is threatening to
invade with the Rook yeah you you can't
really let this happen it means that
black also needs to play a move like
Rook e eight but then what happens after
the Rook trade with Rook e one we are PA
down we don't really want to be continue
trading pieces I think that this is
practically lost and there is another
argument that Nicholas highlighted yeah
ding is so far struggling in this
tournament he is not yet settled in with
with this Freestar chess but this is
exactly what we talked about and why we
love this format if it would be a
knockout tournament then with these two
defeats he would be eliminated from the
tournament and who knows maybe exactly
the seven round up in games will give
him the feeling that how this really
works and The Knockout stages we will be
seeing a monster dingl you just you you
can never be ruled out with with a
player like him and I think that's the
ding that everyone's waiting to see as
well ding struggled in the earlier Tata
steel right now it's not been a it's not
been a great start for him but it's a
long tournament to to go and as you said
the round robin is a great warm-up for
the upcoming classical knockout now the
move G6 of course wants to trade off as
many pawns as possible not back says no
if you trade on my terms if black was to
take on F5 that just helps nbec a lot
the pawn structure gets improved uh
you've made a lot of progress meanwhile
ding will keep the tension on because if
white was to trade on G6 it just leaves
white with the doubled G Pawn weaknesses
which would work in ding's favor so for
notak it looks like he has to show some
good technique here we'll zoom out of
this one let's get an update on all our
other boards let's bring up the bird's
eye view uh and take a look at the
action that's happening we see the
evalar it's a bit up and down on all the
boards on our extreme right nbec in the
end game that we just discussed in
driver's seat meanwhile Fabiano Karana
against alira fuja at least the
evaluation Bar says that fabbi is the
one who's doing well even though I don't
see a single piece out from no because
let's not get fooled yeah that this is
this is not the these are not the
current positions yeah this is this is
something is wrong so let's let's head
to Nicholas I think Nicholas had all the
all the updates yeah let's take a look
at the fusa game against kaana um this
is the current position that we're
seeing here I believe sorry Nicholas
maybe we can start from the beginning
because uh yeah and just see how we got
here yes absolutely we'll start where we
last looked at it to understand what
happened we are really sad about the
bishop on H2 around here we took a look
D5 I think this is maybe the last time
we checked and we were really sad about
this bishop but fuza found a ingenious
way to consolidate his position actually
create a fortress in a way so let's take
a look at it together he brought the
Knight to F4 and allowing a double Pawn
but taking control of the G5 Square
which would be one of the levers so
black to open up the position the bishop
has another Square now and it is very
ugly let's be honest it is very ugly but
is also very safe for white and in the
following moves white consolidates some
more brought his pieces to uh better
squares trying to tie down black a
little bit here on the G6 square but I'm
not sure if that really achieved so much
to be honest as we see the Knight coming
to G4 so the Rooks are coming back and
and the other Rook is coming back the
king is improved and honestly when I
look at this position now I'm thinking
this will be a draw soon because I don't
really see a way forward for either side
white has one target the pawn on A6
black can defend this target pretty well
and black has a Target on the pawn on H4
which white can defend very well there
are no real levers that I can see
because G5 A5 for black are very
difficult to Chief and C4 also seems
pretty much impossible so I would expect
a draw very soon here how do you guys
feel about it Peter well the only idea
that I see is some Bishop H6 Queen D6
targeting the F4 Pawn Yeah because
that's that's the vulnerable Pawn I'm
wondering that exactly at that moment
does white suddenly trade on G4 do we
have to be concerned about this because
H take G4 is kind of still a blockade F
take G4 with F5 and Fabby goes for
this putting pressure on that F4 Pawn
alira needs to find a way uh to hold the
defense from a positional perspective
this just looks so good for black it's
it feels like a dream position you've
got your knight on G4 you've got all
your pawns on the opposite color of your
own dark Square Bishop so you've got the
stronger Bishop look at that Bishop on
G3 it's a bad Bishop but maybe a good
defensive piece uh it does defend that
pawn on F4 but it looks like if anyone's
trying to push it has to be Fabby he
goes for your plan the Knight falls back
on G2 I think for Fabby he would have
loved to have the H file open from a
long-term perspective had alira chosen
the other defense of trading on G4 it
would have given additional chances to
Black along the opening up of the H file
after H takes G4 so more pressure but
the big question you have all these
beautiful points in the position how do
you break through and I think Fabby is
showing the way he is hinting at a
future E3 Pawn sacrifice Pawn break and
if done at the right time maybe the
Rooks will double up on the E file uh
and E3 is the plan that black wants to
achieve yeah I think that Simply Having
this position from black side is is kind
of very very pleasant yeah that you know
ex yeah Rook E6 I felt like this is also
very harmonious making sure that the two
Rooks are protecting the A6 Pawn you can
also fall back with the queen to E7
Nicholas already highlighted also that
yeah there is the weakness on H4 so if
after Queen E7 white jumps back with the
Knight to EC then we can try to regroup
that Bishop to F6 hint at H4 then try to
provoke then Knight G2 and who knows
eventually then some E3 might be a
possibility but clearly E3 often can not
only be captured but it can also be
answered with F2 F3 Fabby goes back with
the Knight another question like can we
transpose this Knight somewhere yeah
because white is completely pegged this
gives black so much time and so much
freedom and the advantage of having this
much space for Fabby is that he can move
his his pieces around from one side of
the board reroute his minor pieces
reroute his uh major pieces in a much
more fluid way than white can find
defenses white has to keep so many
things together so even if the
evaluation bar at this moment says the
position is level uh I'm not sure if it
says that to start with but if it does
it's such a difficult position to play
with the white pieces because you have
to keep so many things under defense and
you don't have enough space to shuffle
around easily you have to control the F4
Pawn you have to keep the H4 Pawn
defended threat is better than execution
always watch out for the E3 break that
might be coming up your idea of the
Knight being rerouted Fabby has got
several plans perhaps the Knight Will
land on C7 freeing up the major pieces
from the defense of that A6 Pawn
eventually we can see uh the lining up
of the alak's battery might appear on
the E file it just feels like there's so
much pressure and for alira it's going
to be an uphill task to keep everything
contained in the position
yeah so so let me take it away to
another game that we've been following
the game between GES and Magnus kasm
because I have some exciting update for
you here Magnus has sacrificed another
Pawn to take the initiative and is
really taking over in this game check
this out so Queen C2 was played
developing the queen that makes a lot of
sense now A5 hinting at the intentions
here of starting a pawn storm on the
queen side opening the white king which
can cannot Castle anymore to the king
side since this Rook has already moved
so white cannot copy what black did and
now E5 this was an unfortunate decision
the computer suggests something like G6
what a difficult move to play with the
with the pawn that if the pawn takes
then the Knight can come forward or E5
can be played even stronger to keep an
eye on this pawn and open up the king a
little bit
more and if the bishop takes then the
Knight can come forward with effect but
this is quite a difficult move to play
for white so let's see what Gish played
instead he went E5 and this is what
Carlson had seen from afar that he can
sacrifice another Pawn here so he play
Bishop
G6 allowing Bishop takes E6 check Pawn
takes Queen goes to B3 the Knight is
still attacked and the pawn is attacked
so white is winning another Pawn but it
came at at a huge price because after
Queen takes E6 Rook
F7 look at the light squares look at
this king and the threat Knight C5
Knight D3 is
absolutely devastating if this Knight
lands on D3 then it is pretty much game
over so Gish under a lot of pressure
here computer says it is close to losing
he needs to play absolutely needs to
play Knight to D4 now to even stay in
the game at all but I think after Knight
C5 Queen takes C6 I mean this looks very
very dire King D1 and maybe even keep
the Queens on the board with a move like
queen d8 or maybe take on B2 first I
mean this looks like ruins with the king
so open and the dark the light Square so
weak Tanya and gkes finds it he finds
the only defensive resource that you're
pointing out Knight D4 there was no
fighting the threat of Knight C5 so gkes
trying to gain more material in
compensation for this inflowing attack
Magnus immediately blitzes out Knight C5
the line that you were pointing out is
on the board uh I'm not expecting Magnus
to trade Queens anytime soon gkes had to
Sid step with his King to D1 as we're
seeing these move moves being played
really fast Peter by the players a four
sequence of moves I'm expecting Magnus
to decline the queen trade by Falling
Back yes on the other hand probably has
so many tempting options he's certainly
enjoying it and when you get a position
like this and you know that you have
played this stunning move short castle
and then everything what happened
basically gives you the feeling that all
the all the right choices had been made
yeah this gives you also so much
pleasure that suddenly the moment comes
in when you think like wow freest sty
chess is just fantastic yeah and and the
opposite side GES he lost the first game
uh with the white pieces is it correct
yes I think he had double whites and now
he is again in a nightmare kind of
scenario against Magnus Carson and this
is a very strategical position yeah when
we know exactly that Magnus has the
total vision how to make the most of it
very tough Challenge on on gash that
will he be able to survive this honestly
I believe not because this is very much
magnus's
territory and I think uh freestyle chess
also feels like magnus's territory and
the reason I say that is uh he's often
spoken about you know one of the reasons
why he did not fight for the world
championship just the preparation that's
involved the format that goes into where
the players only start fighting after a
very a very long number of moves and
it's not something that he's ever been
really happy about we see the world
number one pulling away more and more
from standard classical chess because I
think he just finds this a lot more
challenging he finds this a lot more
creative and he enjoys himself when he's
feeling challenged so for him this is
his territory uh the sacrifice that we
saw from Magnus earlier on Peter uh in
this position it's clear that he's this
is this is why he tries well he loves it
for sure yeah if you are on the on the
side who delivers all the Beauties and
all this possibilities playing in the
spirit that's of course fantastic and
Magnus is not taking his time because
Queen d8 the move that Nicholas
highlighted is kind of once you know it
it makes perfect sense on the other hand
you have so many possibilities and
everything looks tempting how do you
make up your mind how do you choose that
exact move that you have to play because
you can only play one uh this is kind of
a challenge and let's point out these
different possibilities that you're
pointing out right you want to start
with either you trade Queens fall back
the other another really uh tempting one
that you're highlighting on the board
Knight takes P2 coming in grabbing a
pawn with the check there are other
checks on the board but perhaps Knight
F2 is not as attempting as uh uh
grabbing that B2 pawn and it's not an
easy decision that's clear with the
amount of time Magnus is taking in this
position uh also we know what a maestro
he is with Queens off the board The Rook
on E1 is hanging you can start getting
greedy with a trade of queens and then
eventually picking up the Rook what are
we expecting what do you think if you
had to predict what will be mag's final
decision here I think it's very
difficult to to highlight anything here
that could be because look at look at
his pose he wants to make a move because
he knows that probably every single
decision is good I have to just stick
with one but the Temptation yeah there
are so many good options this is one of
the nightmares for for the player yeah
that you have a good position you would
love to have only one good move I can
Blitz it out put the pressure on my
opponent yeah let's take a look yeah
Magnus is trying to make his decision
about to move he reaches out Peter he
does grab the B2 Pawn so he decides not
to touch the queen for the moment comes
in with the tempo the the problem of
Plenty when you've got so many good
choices it's never easy to make uh to
make one of them Nicholas what do you
think about magnus's approach here he
goes for the greedy one yes he does take
the pawn on B2 which was definitely one
of the attractive options in The
Possession here Knight takes B2 the king
will go to E2 very likely
and now Queen d8 maybe this is his idea
to to First Take the pawn because it is
a free Pawn he can take with check and
now to bring the queen back to d8 and
this also looks very very sensible
because in the end if we count the pawns
white is only up two pawns and they're
not beautiful pawns let's be real
they're all isolated they're all weak
the king is being chased in the center
of the board so why does doesn't really
have a lot to show for his weak King and
and the attack that he's suffering so I
think this is a very sensible approach
as we pointed out black should
definitely absolutely not trade the
Queens because this would just he does
it he does he does it wow really wow no
way I'm shocked I'm very much shocked
because now the king feels much much
safer immediately the queen is the
strongest piece and chess and the
strongest attacking piece and most
dangerous for the king so once you take
it off this King on E2 it is it briefs a
sigh of relief it's it's so happy that
the king is not getting checkmated now
I'm really surprised guys what do you
make of this trade of Queens by magnos
is he so confident in this end game well
the big question is how does he intend
to follow it up did he make a move to
see it we've got action coming in as the
players blits out he does come in with a
Tempo against the Knight so Queen takes
Queen Knight takes Queen we see Magnus
developing The Rook attacking the Knight
and isn't the A5 Pawn on pre what am I
missing here Peter well uh honestly I
would like to stabilize the position but
let me try to make those moves yeah King
E2 takes takes Rook C8 on the board yeah
this is the current position Magnus is
going after the C3 Pawn Yeah and he's
trying to combine it with Bishop H5
check I think that's the reason why he
opted for the trade of Queens because
this is a very direct approach hitting
the Knight where do you go if you go
then you might run into Bishop H5 check
King E3 Rook takes C3 check and King E4
if that's not Checkmate after Bishop G6
actually it's not because if the king
Journey continues then to D5 yeah for
example just to highlight yeah if white
plays a move like Knight D4 but also
maybe black can just afford simply to
capture on C3 first and then again the
bishop H5 moves Bishop DC checks are
hanging in the air it's so devastating
and Gish plays the only move to stay in
the game and this is probably what
Magnus had missed the move
E6 E6 a Counterattack Against The Rook
on F7 if the Knight had moved if the
Knight had Tak on A5 moved to D4 it
would have been completely over the
position would have been lost but gkes
finds E6 very importantly and The Rook
has to keep being connected to the pawn
on E7 because otherwise there's a
potential Fork against King and Rook so
first Magnus gives a check the king
steps up now Rook to G7 and now what was
played nothing was played yet now there
are different options the Knight can
come back to E5 G4 is a potential move
very difficult but there are options
also Rook ab1 white is out of the out of
the woods here gkes can survive this
game if he finds the the Right Moves now
going forward but the worst seems to be
over Tanya
he's definitely relieved after that
Queen trade so much pressure on that
white king uh and now Magnus has to do
it all over again in this end game but
we know all about the legendary Magnus
touch in the end games gkes falls back
with the Knight so he is finding all the
right defenses here not getting greedy
with that A5 Pawn because you need as
many pieces closer to your king to keep
squares guarded to keep your king
protected Magnus meanswhile continue
chomping off the pawns eventually the C3
Pawn will also be under attack if white
steps up with that King to F4 attacking
The Rook I think black can make a small
move like 86 speeder just defending the
rook and then with a killer idea of
sliding the other Rook to f8 with uh
some threatening checks coming in yes uh
we also see that suddenly this Knight on
E5 is so nice because it kind of
restricts Black's Knight on B2 yeah just
couple of moves ago I wanted to
highlight that that monster Bishop on G6
was the soul of Black's position yeah so
I really believe and I agree with
Nicholas that Magnus must have missed
the move E6 yeah this inter medo was
missed because otherwise he would have
never have chosen this then we are also
looking at the body language of the
players gkes suddenly seems like he
knows that he has a chance yeah he has
something to play with and he plays the
move King D4 which means that after Rook
d8 check he wants to block the check
with Knight D7 and uh he's getting
active Okay Magnus could eventually fall
back with Bishop to eight targeting the
Knight on D7 but uh it looks much better
than before for
white yeah and you have to the check is
on the board and he does block it with
that Knight again coming back to the
point of E6 being not only an attacking
move but a key defensive move in the
position of taking control of some very
important squares again to block up all
the files that the black Rook is
attacking on uh this is anyone's game
it's a game it's a position for all
three results give white a couple of
move give g a couple of moves that
knight from D2 jumping on to E4 hitting
that Rook uh The Rook from A1 going to
B1 hitting that Knight on B2 also
attacking the pawn on B5 Bishop B8
Nicholas is that the critical move in
this
position so what I would say is that
like you guys pointed out already Gish
must be very happy to even reach this
this position to begin with and I think
Carlson will be kicking himself right
now that he did not keep the Queens on
the board did not go for the attack and
that he missed this intermat move E6 I
would like to go to another game which
we really haven't seen much at all right
now and Vincent might be upset with us
because already in the last round we
didn't cover his game that much and the
reason is that we're just having much
more exciting games going on right now
but I would like to take a brief look at
his game against leavon aronia so we are
in this current position here after
Bishop H3 just to briefly see how we got
there because we really haven't covered
it in the in this round so far after the
middle game the the queens were traded
off early just like in the game against
Carlson
and here slowly both players got their
piece into game we again saw this long
short Castle as Magnus also played and
Karana and fuza as as well and now we
slowly get updated here black traded the
bishop against the Knight so white has
the bishop pair now and I would prefer
white here white has a little bit more
space has the bishop pair the computer
doesn't give a lot of advantage for for
white but I would definitely prefer
white black has some potential play here
on the B file also it feels a little bit
loose not clear yet what to do with this
king the king I would rather have it
somewhere else than on C1 so I think
some practical problems for white but
overall Vincent seems to be in decent
shape and he plays C5 instantly now and
it seems the position is getting more
sharp the bishop is opened up the Knight
is attacked will probably go to F5
and one has to see what to do with this
King this is a big question for me
because I feel like cannot stay there
position is opening up and there might
be some pressure for this King pet what
do you what do you make of this yeah
it's a big strategical battle I also see
that Vincent has only one and a half
minutes left against four yeah that's
but on the other hand with C5 now he's
also opening up the diagonal for the
bishop there are some ideas like Knight
F3 to G5 using that pin hitting that
Bishop on H3 one concern I have also
like what do we do with this King do we
Castle but then the king Still Remains
on C1 slightly awkward a lot to play for
but I feel like maybe in the magnus's
game we might be having now some Direct
action because there was direct
confrontation will this will be a much
longer struggle yes I think this one
wincent in Drive SE the king can perhaps
step to D2 connect the Rooks we will
keep an eye out on this one but let's
head over to the Magnus game which has
been quite exciting from the start even
this end game that we have Queens have
been traded off but the Fire doesn't
stop we see this last move on the board
Rook to G6 it was hitting that pawn on
E6 and a trap being set up so clever by
gkes this move threaten a big discovered
check on the board you're pointing out
all the Dynamics speeder if black takes
on E6 there's Knight to F6 check picking
up that Rook on d8 U Magnus needs to
watch out yeah he needs to watch out and
gash probably feels like okay finally
this is real chess yeah this is where
when I know my where my pieces belong
his King on D4 is not vulnerable at all
his Rook on it was incredible yeah
because first with E6 then Knight E5
Knight D7 he activated his Knight now
he's making use of the E5 Square by
activating his look all the way to
D5 incredible yeah this is even hard to
now to assess is is Magnus still safe or
is he still pressing or is white not
taking over what's going on the good
news of Magnus is he's got an extra
couple of minutes so he can slow down
and think and there's a big traffic J on
the defile we see the black Rook the
White Knight the white Rook the white
king and the White Knight all lined up
tactics Galore is it time for black to S
side step with the King perhaps a little
more with the King to uh make sure there
are no checks uh what are the options
for black here Nicholas in fact gkes is
slowly taking over he has really
defended this end game massively after
Magnus gave him the chance to come back
even trading the queens and now as you
guys pointed out there is the strong
threat of Knight F6 check winning The
Rook on on d8 so King G7 or King h8 were
pretty much
forced and now Gish can drop back with
the kn Knight to
C5 protecting the pawn on E6 and you
would think that this Pawn would drop
off eventually but now it's protected if
the if the Rooks are traded the king is
active why not the Rook is still coming
in Via B1 why is still up a pawn after
all let's not forget that so GES might
in fact have winning chances here in
this position yeah the Rooks should be
traded after all even though I wouldn't
be happy about it with black and now the
king before it was always a weakness and
was chased around now in the end game it
can really be a huge Trump for white and
I think GES has winning chances here W
the king is a piece in the end game and
what a piece it's turning out to be on
D4 always eyeing the queenside Pawns of
Magnus Carlson just one step away from
trying to attack them any peace trade
suits white perfectly uh Peter I think
Magnus is in a bit of a trouble here
he's down upon Pawn White's King Super
Active those queenside pawns are in
extreme danger meanwhile that rook and
Bishop yes it's eyeing E6 okay I'm
slightly surprised with this move
because I was expecting Knight to C5 it
looked like a very natural move but this
one also hits the rook and the bishop if
black was to trade on D5 I I want some
help from you point out the tactics to
us what happens after Rook takes Rook
King takes rook and Bishop takes Pawn
coming in with a check yeah I think we
just fall back with the King to D4 for
example and we just enjoy this Knight on
E5 we are hitting the Rook The Rook
isn't really doing much and we already
coming with a Tempo with Rook B1 and if
the Knight moves the B5 Pawn will be
falling and uh we have been discussing
about seeing Magnus before leaning
backwards enjoying the situation now
when I saw him he was leaning back from
Total frustration you now he's back at
the board he is just so angry with
himself that how did how did I let this
happen from that marvelous position
and now it's white L absolutely nothing
so that gash is done to a minute he if
he keeps the control then the clock
won't be such an let's not forget it's
10cs increment which is a lot of time to
start gaining on the clock a 10c
increment but GES has to keep control
not only on the position but his nerves
as well undoubtedly he's feeling that
he's the one who's pushing in this
position every single initiative that
Magnus had has been neutralized the
Queens have been traded off white King
and Knight Super Active uh the only
thing that g needs to do is get that
Rook into the game and the good news for
him is it's coming in with a Tempo the
line we were discussing is on the board
GES now thinking about where to move his
King King to C5 does invite to move Rook
to G5 pinning on the fourth rank but
there might be ideas of the other Knight
jumping into the attack with a Tempo
with Knight F3 can King C5 be considered
here yes but he's done to a minute yeah
the these are his problems yeah if
suddenly there are many tempting options
that's that's a total nightmare scenario
and just somehow stabilize make sure
thato yeah cemento you know that nothing
can happen to you I'm going to press the
clock I'm going to get the 10 extra
seconds and I know Rook B1 2 B4 and King
D4 on the board it is team cemento for
gkes he keeps things protected not going
into any crazy lines allowing the pins
The Rook comes into the attack Magnus
Carlson is in trouble in this end
game absolutely yeah basically now the
point is that it's kind of a one-sided
Affair and now Magnus is the one who
needs some miracle that maybe somehow
his Rook will be in time to get to D6
deliver a check in time to limit the
damage yeah like Bishop takes a to
followed by Rook D6 check I'm not sure
if it's enough but that's maybe kind of
the defensive res he's lying
on Magnus can pick up that pawn on A2
gkes can pick up that pawn on A5 and the
line that you're pointing out it does
allow some checks but right now Magnus
is on the thing and we look at him on
our on our camera on our screen he is
not looking happy with what has happened
in this game he was so in control
playing for the compensation playing
against that white king but it all came
down to the decision of trading off the
Queens perhaps we'll highlight that CR
critical moment once this game is ended
both players now also fighting the
clock Magnus has to make a move he has
to keep the pressure on he's thinking
what to do what is he going to go for
now how does he keep fighting in this
position do you think he's going to grab
the to pawn Peter Well if there is no
direct tactical reputation then it's
very tempting yeah you want to eliminate
something I'm also wondering that some
C3 C4 trapping that Bishop on A2 is that
the problem yeah because let me just
highlight yeah Bishop takes A2 we play
C3 C4 and after Rook D6 check we simply
fall back with the King to E3 and the
Knight on D2 and Knight on E5 are
beautifully protecting the C4 Pawn we
are setting to go Rook takes A5 putting
tremendous pressure on those two
awkwardly placed the pieces on the queen
side wow but if Magnus can't grab the
pawn on A2 then what does he do yeah
what kind of options he has and he's
struggling yeah he goes for it he goes
for Bishop A2 Will C find C4 this is
such a beautiful idea trapping you've
got Rook A5 you've got Rook uh attacking
the pieces and we're seeing this line
being played out uh Bishop into Pawn on
the board and GES finds it yes of course
he finds it he's he's just incredibly
strong player he was struggling at the
beginning of the event now now he is
very much in his
Zone can gkes finish this job off uh
Nicholas we're analyzing this position
and we're trying to find these ideas how
easy is this for a conversion cocan
drive his seat but what are the things
that he needs to watch out for yeah
what's difficult for him is of course
the time situation he is clearly better
maybe even winning or close to winning
but he has 20 seconds as I'm talking
right now and he's only getting 10
seconds with every mood move Carlson
took another Pawn on H2 and now the
correct reply would be to bring the
Knight back defending the Knight on D2
hitting the rook and next you can just
take this Pawn on A5 hit screw the the
Knight and the bishop on the a file and
well something's going to drop omma
mistaken here it looks like something is
going to drop but what is Gish going to
do has he moved has he played a move
yeah he he
Knight what yeah I think he played
Knight D2 F3 the more natural looking
move you want to move forward you don't
want to move backward yes that's
unfortunate because now you keep the
Rook on the second rank also defending
the bishop on A2 so now that after Rook
G2 for example Rook takes A5 the
difference is the Knight can go back to
B6 and the bishop on A2 is defended if
you had the other Knight now on D2 you
could just take this bishop but still he
has very good chances however there is
now this idea for example to take on C4
and go and trade trade off everything so
we see another rook and Knight against
Rook end game even though the line
continues here with the marvelous move
Knight H4 threatening suddenly Knight F5
and Rook A8 Checkmate let me just show
you to you if the Rook moves somewhere
let's say here then it is suddenly a
Checkmate all right well before we get
lost here we got to go back to the game
what is the current position what what
was played he played Luke H6 uhhuh was
played and D6 check the king comes back
and G at 22nd Magnus Carlson under a
minute on the clock there's still a lot
of pressure on that a file the Knight
and the bishop hanging by a thread here
can white go Rook to A3 eyeing that
Knight on C3 the key
Defender that looks very logical and
very
strong gkes he's reaching out he's about
to make his move he needs to play on
time it's on the board I think Knight D1
is the only move here
yes and we see the evaluation bar is
creeping up
Peter wow what's going on in this
position it's crazy yeah this Knight D1
check but it also doesn't feel nice yeah
the Knight will be kind of uh stranded
there it it might get trapped yeah we
were talking about the bishop being
trapped on A2 maybe the bishop survives
and then suddenly Black Knight will get
into a lot of trouble and that last move
by gkes was made with 2 seconds on the
clock he's on 12 seconds it's a
10-second increment so the players have
to watch out Magnus also makes a move
the check on the board the bishop goes
to B1 and now the C Pawn is advancing
it's going down the board the Knight on
E5 guards the C6 Square it's not going
to stop at
C5 L D5 trying to okay but yeah the
Knight is trapped the C Pawn is
running
the bishop falls back taking control of
the queening square but Magnus is
clearly on the defense he's hanging by a
threat the material is equal but the
problem in Black's position is the
Knight you're highlighting it's just not
coming back to fight the C6 Pawn yeah
not at all and also white still has this
Monster Pawn on C6 the only good news is
that White's Rook on A3 can't really
move because then the Knight jumps back
C7 played but what does he want after
Rook C5 then the Knight is l
oh the Knight on D1 is just hanging so
he needs to first move the Knight which
he does Knight B2 played Rook C5 is the
idea next but will you have time maybe
he'll just pursue that Knight with the
move Rook to A2 and he does it he's
attacking he's not giving time to Magnus
Carlson no and look at Magnus yeah he
knows that yeah this is not not going
according the plans and this is not
terrible because he might have to give
up the piece yeah you can't because the
the C Pawn is about to Queen yeah so
Black's Bishop is
overloaded and the big question is what
do you do do you go Rook to B5 tying
down your Rook to defend that Knight or
do you go Knight to D1 again tying down
your Rook to that Knight Magnus you can
see the hesitation in him he knows it's
no Pleasant choices and wow Rook C2
played after Knight D1 because the
bishop is overloaded you can't take on
C2 because of C8 Queen and not Knight on
D1 has nowhere to go you have to fall
back and I think I it's on the board
Bishop C8 cuz C8 was the big threat on
the board but how do you finish this off
Peter there has to be and he
obstructs he comes in the way of that
rook and the Knight Magnus Carlson is
about to lose that piece on D1 but still
the Knight on D3 is also hanging yeah
but he can follow it up with Knight F3
to E5 get the stability and everything
is protected uh basically we might be
talking about the scenario where nothing
can go wrong because everything is super
and the pawn on C7 is a monster
and Magnus trying to bring the king into
play and we see the Rook now coming to
attack because the Knight on D1 is
trapped that Knight on D3 takes away key
squares Magnus Carlson look at him he
looks like he's close to reignition but
he's throwing in the punches E4 coming
in this guy never gives up no of course
never yeah you have to fight and it's a
Time scramble if you can somehow create
some even go threats yeah something that
is objectively losing but you confuse
the opponent it's fine gash takes that
pawn and Knight beat her the Knight is
out how does Magnus find find these
ideas it's
unbelievable
wow look at one check and the point is
that the White Knight can't take the
Black Knight cuz the Knight on E5 is
hanging in seconds Magnus finds a way to
survive hanging it's a tight rope he's
walking on but he is walking on it night
check the king will step over attacking
that Knight on C6 he needs to stay
connected to the White Knight yes he
needs to King D6 and where does it end L
F6 check King C7 white collects the
Knight yeah Knight takes B2 is there
some trick does not seem like it seems
like gkes has just managed to survive
all this time scramble he's now also
very well uh up on the clock yes 34
seconds stability if there is some more
crazy scenario you can spend some time
to find the solution
and Magnus there he's feeling Shifty in
his chair he's down a piece if he can
somehow trade or grab that G3 Pawn it's
still a draw but it's far away because
White's King is so close to defending
that pawn on G3 uh Magnus trying to
think of ways to trick his opponent
right now he first puts pressure on that
Knight to
C6 yeah Knight B4 looks like a tempting
option yeah just to go back get
stability get the other Knight to D3
King to F2 yeah Magnus goes look
H5 Knight B2 to D3 would be kind of very
tempting just to coordinate the pieces
Knight C4 ambitious move going after the
black king yeah l f seven check wow
these youngsters are fearless he wants
to give Checkmate even in this position
the Knight on B4 C4 taking away all the
squares from Black's King so not only up
a piece but going for a mating attack
here GES putting pressure on the bishop
on B7 Magnus goes all the way far away
from those whes threatening Knights and
maybe the Knight can start jumping in
Knight A6 check you have to go to A8
with your king yes but it's not
Checkmate yet so maybe you just protect
that pawn first because white black is
not not running away what yeah Magnus
resigned wow Checkmate real and we did
see a Checkmate in the end with the
Knight coming back Rook to A7 s was the
big threat Knight to C7 is the other big
threat gkes gets it done he wins against
the world number one in freestyle chess
what what a game that was just amazing
yeah what a turnaround a and yeah Magnus
will be very upset with himself from a
dream scenario turned into a complete
nightmare scenario these are the things
these are the losses that are the most
difficult to digest yeah because you
have only yourself your yourself to
blame
uh 17-year-old gkes uh a big win for him
a huge confidence boost for him he's
definitely one of the players who who
wants more experience in this format he
wants to play more a freestyle chess so
to get that win against Magnus uh
especially after the start he had in
round one wow but look at sorry to
interrupt also the game between Vincent
K and Leon Aron has ended Vincent has
beaten Leon Aron and they are discussing
the game right now and let's head over
to the last position as well wincent
who's been on fire lately winning the
division two of the chessel Masters
comes in holds Magnus Carlson in game
one takes down Levon aronian in game two
and the point in this position is that
A7 Pawn is so strong and Levon just
doesn't have the time to capture it if
you fall back with your king to B7
stopping it from promoting the other
Pawn gets the job done C6 incoming yes
and look at this what a fascinating
position C6 check King A8 for example
you push C7 you box your own Bishop on
B8 black can play the move King Knight
D6 but then white has all the freedom
King D4 white picks up the D5 Pawn then
continues the journey can travel to D7
but even can just go towards the king
side and collect everything black is
completely tied on nothing else than to
resign for black here fantastic finish
there by Winston what a round this was
and uh still thinking about all the
turnarounds that we witnessed in the
Magnus GES game what was the highlight
for you Nicholas well I want to point
out that we saw three white wins in this
round not only did Vincent beat mag did
Vincent beat Leon ronian and GES
beat Magnus but also nybeck beat dingly
Ren so this was really a round of the
Jacks beating the Kings nck beating King
Ding and Vincent beating leevon and um
Gish beating Carlson the only game that
was drawn was between alira and Fabiano
so another exciting round we didn't
really even have it chance to see the
finishes of the other two games as we're
so focused on this really captivating
game between GES and Magnuson for me
that was the game of the round because
the way that GES managed to defend then
take over and then in the time scramble
keep his nerves together and find the
only way to to when when Magnus still
POS problems he found the only way to
keep to keep the exra piece or to win
the peace and then bring the the point
home against the number one in the world
for many the the golden chess that was
very very impressive so Gish definitely
has arrived in the tournament after the
loss in the first round and Magnus with
half a point after two rounds will not
be happy guys yeah definitely he's not
going to be happy but the one player who
will be very happy is the 18-year-old uh
gkes and what a game it was seizing his
opportunity he had that King out in the
open uh but then eventually in the end
game after Queen trades when he did get
the chance he did not back down he did
not neutralize the advant he did not
just bail out of the situation took that
opportunity and that's what makes these
youngsters so dangerous there are two
more games coming up freestyle chess is
not only usually entertaining and unique
but also a very grueling format for the
players we're going to go into a short
break and we'll be back with more chess
action in just a few minutes stay with
us
this format is completely new this is
classic uh longtime chess for freestyle
chess and so we want to begin a new era
of Chess and we are looking forward what
will happen in the next days here and
then also probably we can make a tour or
something like this Yan won't always to
make the best event ever and zo it was
very easy he did me give me the chance
that I can make everything like the best
team and with the best location here at
wison house and he build it in such an
exciting way that is really the best
tournament ever magnos met uh Yan at
Qatar at the open in October and uh he
was completely committed with Yan about
this tournament and to enter new GS in
chess everybody is a radiant of joy and
looking forward that the games will
begin and I think this is so amazing
here and every player taught to me
Sebastian great I'm here and so
fantastic and I'm in the good mood and I
think I will play my best chess
[Music]
ever
a
[Music]
d
[Applause]
[Music]
we
e
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
welcome back everyone we've got two more
rapid games coming up it is round three
of the round robin and big fight as
we've got some juicy juicy matchups for
everyone Peter yes it is Magnus carang
alja we know exactly how Magnus feels if
he loses a game and this game was was
really painful for Magnus Al I don't
remember the last time we saw this Peter
it's been a while yeah yeah how many
hours 24 or 48 I'm already completely
confused yes okay this is this is just
fantastic and also dingling after losing
his first two games defin itely will be
looking to to come back against Vincent
kimer Leon alaga against gkes well gkes
had had a slow start he was suffering he
lost the first game with white then he
was lost and there is also the ceremony
but now winning back uh against I mean
coming back against Magnus from there he
he will get all the energy and we're
seeing the visuals com in from our
spectacular playing Arena we're going to
head over to Fiona to reveal our
position for game three of the round
Robin okay so we just saw a very
exciting second round it is time now for
round three and I'm once again going to
ask collie and Teresa Sara to join me on
the stage please um as you can see there
are now four numbers which are out of
the pot which means four Jokers one more
chance uh to get that donation welcome
back Holly I think as always whenever
you're ready let's
go
and it is number
292 thank you
much thank you hly thank you thees Sarah
we'll see you later for the last time
today and I think the position will be
ready any minute now so uh for the
players this is yq and good luck uh
we'll see you in 10 minutes for the
start of the
round and we're back and we've got our
Marky match up right in front of us Nas
Peter and I were discussing we did see
an epic battle between Magnus Carlson
and ala fuja in the finals of the
Champions chest chessable Masters just
less than 24 hours ago Ali Resa managed
to win a set Magnus striking back in the
final set a bit of a grudge match for
alira when these two Play It's always
fire on the board Magnus has often said
how much he enjoys playing against Ali
RZA style uh not long ago he wanted Ali
Resa as an opponent for the world
championship match yes Al has a very
Dynamic style very aggressive and it's
basically thanks to his Clash of styles
it it always guarantees some fascinating
battle now however it's going to be
their first ever free style chess game
against each other and I I really want
to see how this going to work out I'm
going to make an early prediction
Nicholas and Peter I'm predicting the
first move shots side
Castle you think so yeah well looking at
the position yeah let's let's actually
talk about the position a bit yeah that
uh what we are seeing yeah that uh again
the king is between both Rooks it does
make sense yeah it it does make a lot of
sense to to Castle but on the the other
hand you might feel that you can do it
any moment and uh you have to also judge
the the other pieces yeah that is the
priority of opening up the the queen
position for example something like B4
that is C5 B takes C5 Bishop takes H2
winning an exchange just to highlight
this for example for a second yeah
because the H2 Pawn is vulnerable the
same applies for Black's H7 Pawn so
there's also this temptation that white
can maybe push C4 here hitting the pawn
on H7 getting one extra big Tempo these
are one of the scary type of positions
that you are very afraid to be in with
black because if it's a bad position
it's a bad position yeah you lose a
Tempo yes and very nicely pointed out
again we've been saying this that In
freestyle chess from the starting
position always look out for your
hanging pawns the ones that are not
defended H2 and H7 in this position
often easy to miss especially in online
freestyle chess because the that that
Bishop is on B1 and not the Knight on B1
which can be attacking the pawn on A7
that you're highlighting you have to
watch out for these threats we see the
players who will be uh playing I believe
from the black pieces they're discussing
uh how to counter these threats these
attacks it's the younger generation on
the screen gkes nck wincent figuring the
position out Nicholas break it down for
us what are your first impressions well
I would definitely like to take white
here and I'll tell you why we see this
fir power lined up on the queen side
Queen Bishop and the other bishop and
there is this potential that these
pieces are pointing towards the black
king Peter already said it if the pawn
comes forward maybe this Pawn comes
forward
immediately this is direction towards
towards the black king and yes black can
Castle let's say like this but it
doesn't change the fact that all of
these pieces are pointing in this
direction so I be scared and I think it
really makes a difference here to have
this extra move with white uh to to
immedately go for the initiative and
start start maybe creating threats and
attacking uh the black king all right so
I lost the position here so let's bring
it back where you maybe still have it so
what do what are you guys expecting as
the first move here well first of all I
want to highlight that yes the youngster
the Jacks are in a very awkward
situation and we see all of them
Gathering there and and trying to figure
out how do we survive the first couple
of moves yeah because uh facing the
Kings they know exactly if they give the
upper hand for their opponents then then
it will be very difficult to come back
they need all their creativity to
somehow stabilize but how do you
stabilize after C4 and also let's tell
everyone who are the kings the experien
lot the very very established the lead
of the Chess World the CR de here Magnus
Carlson the world champion dingler and
Leon aronian Fabiano Carana they are the
Kings while the Jack Jacks Are the
younger generation who are shaking up
the world's Elite making their Mark into
the very top of the Chess World right in
front of our screens there some of them
gathered analyzing and that is not be
Abdu satro Ali Resa fuja wincon Kaa gkes
are all the Jacks in this tournament uh
Peter they are doing a bit of a deep
dive here and I see that Nicolas ideas
of the Advance on the queen side with
the pawn rolls is exactly what they're
looking at right now yeah it's very
logical very tempting and also from the
black side this is what you are most
afraid of yeah you have to have an
antidote to C4 I was very happy that
Nicholas highlighted that actually black
can castle and thanks to castles we can
actually protect that H7 Pawn how cool
would it be if we had miks in there just
to hear that
thoughts okay but we don't know if the
players would be so happy yeah because
okay they are before the game they are
in the relaxed mode yeah and they want
to chill this is their moment of yeah 10
minutes that they have to get ready but
also there's no tension yet yeah once
the clocks supressed it's a different
story and I think G makes a really nice
point there that that Knight on h8 and
H1 will come out from that G3 Square it
needs to develop at the edge of the
board and very often we might see black
or white in that case push that g Pawn
may be at some point trying to block the
knight from taking control of the
central squares there are so many Rich
Dynamics in these positions white
starting on move one can look at opening
up the queen side pieces the Bishops and
the queen diagonal can think about
perhaps getting the Knight into the game
I feel that every position that we've
had has gotten
incrementally more complex in uh the
freestyle chess yeah my feeling was that
the first two positions were kind of
dynamically balanced yeah I I really
felt like there is no clear obvious way
how white can get the advantage that's
why I got scared like wow not that
somebody who is playing now from the
black side after C4 gets into a lot of
trouble I do hope that the players will
figure out the way yeah Nicholas
highlighted the move castles at least
this was also the move that you
mentioned Tanya know that was your first
instinct that if you get a chance you're
going to Castle then already looks are
in a good position and who knows for
example white can't really occupy just
like this blind in the center because we
have this Counter Strike with C5 after d
takes C5 Bishop takes H2 we might be
winning the exchange yeah thanks to this
we might survive and then we get a
normal
game yes absolutely well I'm going to
make a prediction that out of four games
I think in one at least we will see a
shot Castle we'll find out if I'm right
or wrong about that one but right now we
see the Kings on the board as well who
are having a discussion and I see that
they're looking at a similar structure
as you're pointing out stop with the
move C4 opening up that bishop and then
eventually making the move C5 with black
as well you have to watch out for that
87 Pawn to start with so I think there's
a castle on the board in their analysis
position and we see Levon scratching his
head what a crazy position we have in
this one all right first move
predictions I've said we're going to
have a shot Castle on at least one of
the games Nicholas I'm going to start
with you what are you expecting well
first of all I'm I'm willing to bet
against you the short
Castle I I think I think this can wait
but it would be it would be it would be
stylish let's be real to Castle on the
first move if you have the chance it
would be nice to do this this move here
oh I cannot do it for some reason right
now but I
would I would ex I I mean there are a
lot of attractive moves also E4 makes
sense to me but I still think C4 opening
up the bishop e would be my choice what
do you think yeah I also feel like if we
have the chance to play C4 then we would
love to and also let's not forget that
uh the Kings yeah both leavon and Magnus
had lost their previous and also dingan
has lost yeah so all the kings are
burning for Revenge they want to come
back and they want to be aggressive yeah
so you want to really make the most out
of this position the Jacks have been
doing pretty well against the king so
far in this event and we see two of them
in front of us Vincent kaima with the
GES analyzing the prospects of this
unique starting position 960 positions
are possible 58 the number 518 is the
standard chess position and we saw the
drawing of positions with those uh balls
which have a number each earlier on the
ceremony of revealing the position
earlier on uh we have removed the
position number 518 which is the
standard starting position and also one
more the one which in which only the
king and the queen Chang their place the
King goes from E1 to D1 the queen from
D1 to E1 and that has been removed so
this is minus two positions so still 958
positions possible yes exactly and
basically every single position that are
played out is also removed from the
machine and it's compensated by a joker
yeah which uh which if actually that
joker will be pulled out the German
chess F the German use uh compartment
will get 500 from Yan Henry Butner as a
special gift so there is also some
Intrigue there Yan bner is the founder
The Mastermind behind this event he's
put it all together with a vision to
popularize Freestyle chess and we're
having so much fun calling the action
because after a very long time it feels
like from move number one Peter we can
start our discussions and we've got
Fiona there uh we're waiting for the
players to start we are playing round
number three good luck to all of you
start the games oh and the D has been
rung there by Fiona I think it's go time
Peter and there it is Fabiano Carano
playing against nbec Abdu
satov all right someone Castle all right
not on this board what does he start
with is it
C4 wow but uh yeah there we see black
answers it with C4 was that was AB Abdu
satov yeah C4 castles we got the first
moves right at one we're all good well
you said White Castles right I said
number one Castle okay that's good yeah
that's good so let's see but this was
critical because 87 was hanging exactly
yeah C4 cast was was kind of forced and
big question yeah C4 some more games
right C4 Castle in three of the uh games
so far yes oh wow and which which is the
game which haven't started yet
officially uh oh you're right Carson and
F are both castle of the first move I
did say white will make the first move
Castle it has happened and it's by none
other than world number one he starts
with Castle uh this is going to be
awesome and fua also castles in return
Yes and look at look at Al yeah okay I'm
in sleeping mode it's just everyday
business right fantastic love it and
we've got some more moves this is our
bird's eye view to take in all the
opening action so we see very similar
pawn moves in all the boards that's what
strikes to me with the white pieces
except on magnus's board where we see
the move B4 opening up the queen that's
the third board uh from the right right
here opening up the Queen instead of
opening up the bishop the other players
going for a similar approach Peter yes
and there is also this vulnerable spot
on G7 and G2 yeah so now Magnus going
for C4 now black can play the move
Bishop C8 to B7 no he first plays the
move C5 I just want to highlight that
yes one has to watch out yeah because
both have Bishop B2 and after Bishop B7
Mutual craziness Mutual problems
are are really happening and it will be
a big question how does white react to
it or black against Bishop B2 idea but
for the moment Magnus is taking his time
he has to decide what he does with his
B4 Pawn does he include uh the move
Bishop B2 immediately just to get some
feeling that how black is really trying
to to protect that
weakness big question here Nicholas what
do you what do you make of this thought
because from move number three uh I
think I'm allowed to say this it's an
Absolutely Fresh position that we have
on the board but Bishop B2 are you
expecting that on the board now Bishop
B2 would be a very logical move to line
up the battery against the pawn on
G7 and well black needs to defend this
Pawn for sure so the only two sensible
options that I see are either to play F6
or to play E5 but E5 is not really a
move that you want to play because it
weakens some squares so in another game
that we saw or that I've seen at least
already that is happening F6 was played
and F6 also has some advantages that you
can put maybe develop the Knight on the
other hand it is also weakening move so
it is also something which you don't
really like to do however you have to
deal with this threat in one way or
another you cannot allow that the bishop
takes on G7 and if I can consult a
computer there is another way which I
didn't see besides F6 and E5 and that is
the move Knight to
E6 Knight to E6 also defending the pawn
on G7 and maybe this is the most
harmonious or the the least weakening
way because you're not pushing any pawn
move and maybe the most sensible so I
think the next few moves will be
critical in in deciding if White can get
some initiative going can use this extra
move that white has Peter yes in the
game I think B takes C5 B takes C5
Knight G3 Knight G6 had happened this
also one of this type of positions I
feel like ARA feels like okay it's
symmetrical but at least as long as
there are no direct threats I can make
those moves instantly I'm winning time
and uh the big question is yeah that is
in long terms white able to pose
problems or if white misses the chance
of on capitalizing on something early on
the game then black will just be fine
that's that's a very big question I do
feel that Alias is feeling quite
confident he's in every single game
playing the opening phe quite quickly
again up on the
clock an absolute symmetrical position
but now it has to be broken because
white comes in with the first threat in
the position lining up with the bishop
and the queen G7 is a tender spot alian
needs to make a decision how he wants to
defend
Knight E6 the move that you were
discussing earlier it looks very logical
can maybe think about F6 with pawn moves
I'm not really sure how quickly you want
to make them commit yourself to this
Pawn structure of F6 maybe you're
creating some weaknesses uh wow and Ali
RZA goes for it yeah he goes for F6
because he wants to somehow get that
Knight to F7 and he also feels that
maybe it will be very important that I
trade that Bishop uh that dark s Bishop
with Bishop E5 or maybe we even say that
you know what uh look at this
white has this incredible battery on the
on the long diagonal but if black simply
blocks it with F6 then then this battery
brings absolutely nothing so it's very
interesting and refreshing to see how Al
are quickly yeah basically after 10
seconds makes a decision like F6 this is
the strength the power of the use yeah
you are not feeling any ghost you you
don't think about is this a we no it has
also a lot of positive things yeah it's
there are a lot of arguments why this
moov is is strong I love this
determination and he's got to be feeling
determined especially after the match
that they just had what do you think
about those Dynamics these two have just
played quite an epic battle in uh the
grand final of the chessel master and it
was fireworks from the start Ali RZA
taking the first uh set Magnus bouncing
back to take the championship in the
final set with the games are full of
fire do you think that's on their mind
Peter I think not first of all because
the match was incredible yeah so I don't
think that if you lose an incredible
match like this when you can be so proud
of yourself like ala played a brilliant
match finally Magnus prevailed but uh
it's it's more like he feels that okay
yes I have played enough game with
Magnus but this is our first freestyle
chess game against each other so it's a
completely fresh start and uh so far I
feel like you know there are two things
the the older generation loves to play
freestyle chess fish random chess
because they have been studying already
for more than 20 years with super
engines all the theoretical lines and
they are kind of tired and they are
exhausted they have been exhausting all
possibilities and the youngsters they
feel like we still have so much to learn
in classical chess but we love we enjoy
you know not learning just playing and
they are very fresh so I I also find it
very nice that we have this Clash of
generations and so far the Jacks are
doing extremely well they really are
things are having a tough time the other
Dynamic into play the fact that you know
we've got the most important event of
the chess calendar coming up the
candidates in two months and very often
in classical chess they have to watch
out for what openings they're playing
leading up to the candidates and that
always stops them from showing their
best hands but that is something having
some of the very crucial candidates in
this event participating that's not
something they need to worry about In
freestyle chess they can bring on the
creativity from the very start and we
see a mirror image here the Symmetry in
the position continues uh the players
are playing copycat chess yes but here
now the copycat chess was played by
Magnus which shows that actually the
move F7 F6 that we were debating that is
it the weakness or not it had a huge
impact on Magnus yeah he didn't dare to
play F3 himself before black played the
move F6 but now he under okay it's a
nice idea wow very
nice and it wasn't only the bishop and
the queen lined up on the attack the
Knight could have jumped to key Square
as like F5 F4 putting more pressure so
at some point you needed to blunt this
diagonal it's been done by both the ball
is in Ali razar's Court what are you
expecting here uh Nicholas now he has to
change things up or does he continue
with Bishop B7 achieving the perfect
symmetry yes ala could play Bishop B7
then would be a perfectly symmetrical
position but he doesn't have to he could
also do something else and in general I
think this opening phase has gone pretty
well for the French player he plays
Knight to F7 now developing the Knight
he's up 5 minutes on the clock he's
playing with confidence he's playing
fast and that's this is a very important
factor when playing rapid chess
obviously and Carson we also saw him on
the camera we see him right now he's not
looking so happy and I think if I may
point this out this decision to play B4
earlyer on to grab more space might have
backfired a little bit because
eventually as opposed with the pawn on
on
B3 eventually you cannot play D4 as
nicely since if you do for example let
me do it here then you always end up
with an isolated Pawn here on C4 whereas
if the pawn was still on B3 and on B6 it
would be a different story and we have
seen actually a lot of the other players
to put the pawn on B3 to not go for B4
not grab that space and now we are in
this position after Knight F2 once again
Bishop B7 would lead to a completely
symmetrical position but it seems like
the bishop is not really achieving that
much on this diagonal right now
so I expect fua to continue in a
different fashion and you feel like
slowly it's heating up slowly the pieces
are coming closer to the king what a
what a strange strange situation Peter
what do you think yeah it's a very slow
Affair I I think that white has missed
on the chance of capitalizing on the on
the starting position believe that ala
can be very happy with everything and it
might be a good opportunity to jump to
some other games because uh this is now
slow Affair it might be a very
interesting strategical game later on
but for the moment it it takes a slower
pace and cl you said strange strange is
the new normal when it comes to
Freestyle chess because the starting
positions themselves are so unique
completely fresh chess and that's what
we love about this format we will pull
up the bird's eye view we will zoom out
for a moment and get an update on all
our other games as the players are
deciding where to place the pieces how
to begin the game so let's bring up our
bird's eye
view and then perhaps we can jump into
and deep dive into a
position and there we have it we see the
start of the games and so far every
everything is level and once again we
see on our extreme right board Fabiano
Kwan's Queen is out early on with
perhaps a lining up of the bishop and
the queen but in the right way where you
then start threatening a mate on G7 the
F Pawn has moved forward it promises to
be an exciting fight so far level
meanwhile we've discussed a lot about
the Magnus game and then a really
interesting development in the world
champion facing your prodiger uh Vincent
kimer would you like to take a deep dive
into that one Peter yes the reason why
I'm actually very interested in this
game and also in Fab's game I'm
comparing the two positions yeah if we
look at that we see that it's almost a
mirror but with opposite colors yeah so
Fabiano opted for quick D4 and activated
his Queen with Queen takes D4 and
Vincent made also good use of the chance
to to to go D5 and queen takes D5 uh
very interesting to see which approach
uh along this D5 move was a good good
idea from dingo not for the moment from
a distance it looks like black should be
happy well the queen is out it is
developed the white King still uh in
that diagonal maybe there might be a
check but the bishop on B2 controls a
key D4 Square meanwhile leavon and gkes
also continues to be very interesting
taking a similar approach like the
Magnus alira blunting the diagonal uh
the long diagonal A1 to h8 with that
move F6 what catches your attention
which one should we go to First I think
all the games have their own uh own
finesses it's it's up to us whom did we
cover the least I think that would be
not a very fair thing Vincent Vincent
okay that's it dingan against
immediately Peter jumps into the game no
surprises there okay also Vincent has
activated his Queen to D5 yeah he's also
aiming towards the marot structure yeah
that's the the the Mary bind if black
also gets the move E5 in maybe he does
not even need to because this E5 sare
can also be used maybe for Bishop E5 or
Knight E5 ideas I want to also pass it
to Nicholas Nicholas what is your take
on this
position yeah after Queen B1 we have
this lineup of the bishop and the Queen
on this diagonal hitting the pawn on H7
and again the question how to deal with
this you could play Move Like G6 but
it's also weakening up the king a little
bit further and vent Vincent actually
opts for the strongest move Queen H5 not
only defending the pawn on H7 but also
watch out the bishop and the queen line
up for almost a Checkmate threat on H2
so now white has to deal with this
threat on his own and probably most
probably will play the Knight out to G3
hitting the queen you don't want to give
up your Bishop so you just move to Queen
forward to H4 and still this looks a
little bit uncomfortable with potential
threats that black can maybe take on G3
and also here the action feels like
slowly heating up the bishops from the
back they are long R range pieces
they're pointing towards the respective
Kings and it seems to me that well this
could become very sharp very soon
potentially Tanya very sharp very soon
you're pointing out all these tactical
ideas the one thing that strikes to me
in this position Peter is that white has
a nasty threat look at Black's pieces
that Rook on E8 doesn't really have a
square to move to you move your queen
can white start getting greedy already
my Bishop on D3 Queen on B1 yes it was
eyeing the king side but suddenly I
shift my focus I want an exchange Bishop
to B5 yes but actually this light Square
Bishop is kind of a monster bishop and
uh we do see sometimes there were some
lines in the English opening where uh
black can sacrifice an exchange like
this in Mar structures and get an
overwhelming initiative I also feel that
maybe that's the reason why Vincent has
paused uh because Because he believes in
the attack yeah Queen H4 and if you go
okay let's just put it on the board yeah
because Queen H4 Bishop B5 that's what
we are talking about yeah Vincent I
believe from his hand movement it he had
to play Queen H4 the luk on E8 is tra
but black gets some incredible activity
I don't know something like Knight G5
going for Bishop takes G3 a G3 Queen
take G3 and then already crazy ideas
like Knight H3 check are hanging in the
air would be very scared from the white
side to enter something like this and
what a day wincent has had right he
starts with a draw against Magnus he
takes down Leon aronian in round two and
now in this fighting position by the way
we are seeing this being played out so
this as well is going to be quite the
explosive fight as wincent has gone all
in sacrificing The Exchange Bishop B5
has been played yes Bishop B5 on the
board now uh which means that wincent
has to go for white king now wow okay so
Bishop B5 played yeah Vincent will be
forced to go for attack I however want
to caution it don't don't jinx it I mean
let wincon do his job I'm here as a
commentator I'm clearly rooting for him
I'm very happy if he does well but yes
let him just play yeah this is also we
haven't mentioned that we are treated
here magnificently in this wisen house
luxury resort the players have
everything the commentators have
everything we are enjoying our time and
I think that also the players we see
these crazy games these fantastic
fascinating battles are also in
extremely creative mood because of all
these incredible settings this
environment the organizational team with
Yan Henry Butner is making sure that
everybody feels at home it's just so
nice to be here it's super nice and vion
house is one of the world's best nature
Retreats it's all about the calm and the
peace that you feel here but the chess
the freestyle chess has been absolute
chaos from the very thought and this
position promises to bring on more of
that chaos as the world champion dingin
is in fact going for that exchange
wincent has to prove his compensation
has to prove his initiative in this
position uh is this a good moment to
zoom out and get an update from uh on
the other boards uh just for a moment I
think maybe we can ask Nicholas because
Nicholas knows the truth let's
ask well I have of course a little bit
of help and it is quite interesting to
see how the different variations can
play out here the computer is just
saying zeros which means equal in chess
terms and you have different options as
Peter said you can bring the Knight
forward to G5 you can also take on G3
immediately if you want to they are also
moves maybe like Knight E6 but let's
look for a very concrete line here
Knight G5 all right white takes the Rook
what else to do black can take back or
even already think about trying to go
for draw draw in combination with Knight
H3 apparently takes and now take on G3
and if white takes back then it would be
a Perpetual check because the queen just
gives continuous checks and black cannot
further strengthen the
attack so here white could play
something else but apparently even after
Knight F2 Rook takes E8 it should end up
in an equal position but I wouldn't go
for this Knight H3 immediately it looks
more sensible to just take back to keep
all the threats in the position maybe to
take on G3 first since white cannot
really stop that anyway and I would be a
bit concerned here with white the
computer is saying Knight C3 and now
okay many many options black definitely
has a lot of compensation and Vincent
seems to have judged it correctly that
he can sacrifice his Exchange in that
way now he just tries to find the best
way forward after Bishop B5 I think he
will probably spend some more time so if
he want to we can go to another game and
I I think I know exactly the one that
both of you would love analyzing we have
to rush over to Levon versus gkes
because it's absolute Chaos on the board
and Nicholas we have to take this I
think from the top because it's
impossible to understand all the pieces
hanging in the current board as we see
it so show us how we got here and break
it down for us
absolutely so I don't know if we saw
this already I don't think so we see the
story moves now again quite similar to
the other games in early D4 now black
didn't take on D4 allowing the capture
we see the bishop lining up and now let
me maybe slow down so we can really
understand what is going on so the
Knight is coming into his Center and
here interestingly Queen C6 was the
response and gash actually did not or he
ignored or maybe didn't see the white
threat which was to take on F six to
break open the black king position so if
black was to take back which Gish did
not do then the Knight would take on F6
it's a fork to the rook and the king and
well either way white is getting this
getting one of the Rooks and here white
has two pawns plus The Rook against two
minor pieces and important thing is that
the king is pretty open so white would
be in good
shape which is why Gish did not take and
maybe this was the move he had in mind
when he allowed this capture on F6 which
looks quite scary to play D5 hitting the
Knight on e4 and only if the Knight
moves then to take the bishop on F6 but
white can react and has different
captures can take on G7 can take On d8
and Here Leon took on d8 and now it is
actually GES to move and to decide which
minor piece to take the Knight on e4 or
the bishop on d8
apparently he is supposed to take on
d8 but then well why do up a pawn if I'm
not mistaken I think he has just
captured yeah he he took on d8 however
this guy is also hanging but well
there's a checkm Fred watch out always
these long range Paces here out of the
corus so there's a checkm threat on H7
now but black can play G6 it looks quite
scary for black being down a pawn and
and having an open King but according to
the computer guys this seems to be still
okay for gkes so this is probably going
to be played out it's all on the board
uh Nicholas the exact line that you
pointed out a mate and one is threatened
right now Bishop takes Pawn a massive
threat which gkes will stop he is
reaching out it's probably going to be
G6 and I just want to point out shot
Castle is still legal for white yes it
is legal and now also let's talk about
the potential compensation for black
yeah that yeah white is a pawn up
seemingly he attacking but
black has this long-term asset the dark
Square Bishop yeah and just imagine some
scenario where this bishop is landing on
E5 targeting that Queen on A1 in the
corner yeah that would be a deadly
scenario for white and also black has
kind of this yeah cast played of course
yeah the pawn on H2 was hanging yeah
Bishop was uh threatening to capture on
H2 before uh so the move short C make
perfect sense however now black has this
extra move the big question is what do
we do with it yeah this this kind of
structure what does it remind us on the
blue manfeld Gambit right that black
sacrific the pawn yes on the other hand
white still has the pawn on C4 so it did
not have to double it on the B file but
there is I I very much sense what
computer is saying yeah Knight F7 I
wouldn't be sure at all that white
really has the advantage okay he has the
pawn but black has long-term
compensation here and there black is
trying to to get rid of his own least
developed piece that Knight on h8 for
White's most active Knight on G5 so
definitely a trade that will suit g a
lot The Rook will step up line up on the
F line putting pressure the two Bishop
the bishop pair advantage against the
pawn sacrifice gives long-term
compensation you're absolutely right it
is a lot like the standard bloomenfeld
Pawn sacrifices that we see uh so it's
far far from Clear in this position it's
going to be a fun one uh Nichol plus I
see you're also doing a deep dive into
this would you rather be white having an
extra Pawn or would you rather play to
try to prove your compensation with the
bishop here well I definitely like to be
on the attack I like to have the
initiative I like to to give material
rather than to to defend material that I
have won so I would prefer black Here
and Now git just played Knight to F7
which the computer doesn't actually
approve so much the move makes a lot of
sense to get rid of this active Knight
on
G5 however maybe it would have been
better to push this Knight away with a
move like Bishop F4 and say that this
Knight actually is not really in a good
spot anyway Knight F3 D4 to further play
in the center E5 E4 is coming the Knight
on D1 is is misplaced so this was the
direction of the computer gush takes a
slower approach playing Knight F7 I
guess the knights will be traded here
and now he can also up on the on the
file however white is still fairly solid
he just needs to find a way to get these
pieces on the on the back rank to better
squares the Knight on D1 the bishop on
B1 all don't look too great so if white
can do that if he can get his piece into
play consolidate a bit more then he has
a pawn he has an extra Pawn he can be
better what do you guys think should we
should we move on to another game yes I
think so because it's it's clear that
this is long-term compensation yeah
there will be many many dramas in this
game 11 captures on F7 okay this this
happened this gives us a chance to catch
up with I think he's just reaching out
for his next move he improves the
position of the queen and Peta as you
were pointing out let's bring out our
Bird's eyee View and see where we want
to where the action is where we want to
jump in next uh let's zoom out from this
game for the moment uh to do a deep dive
into one of our other boards and bring
up our bird's eye view I see action is
on on all the other boards
for example Fabian Oar n beab we haven't
really been looking at yet this could be
both players are on fire yeah they are
playing brilliant chess and perhaps we
could just go directly to that one Peter
uh on our analysis board we can have
that up as we pull the live board uh for
our audience as well and that is the
current position wow okay so this
already reminds me of some kind of a
queen Indian also some poen uh kind of
structure
it's uh it's very
interesting first feeling is that white
has only two Pawn Islands yeah and and
black has three so thanks to the pawn
structure white should have the better
position but in all this type of
positions there's so much activity and
we see that the White Knight on E3
somehow little bit awkwardly plays The
Pawn on E6 is beautifully dominating uh
that KN black has the semiopen f file
with good counter chances it's very much
an abdule of type of position where
there is so much potential for
aggressive play and yet it's just
starting to heat up so there are all
these possibilities we know nbec he's
such a fighter and he really thrives in
these kind of positions which are not
Dull and dry and the action it's it's
sort of like the storm is just brewing
up uh Peter you're mentioning that you
know black has all these ideas to start
putting pressure of course the doubling
up along the F line the night jumping
from G6 to F4 at the right moment comes
to mind what about Fabby where are the
trumps in his position because I also
see for Fabby that White Knight on G3
can eventually find itself on H5 and
doubling up with the bishop on B2 start
putting pressure on G7 yes I exactly had
this feeling that if yeah Knight H5
already played that Fabby is very much
the type of player who acknowledges that
yes black has nice kind of probably
potential counterplay but actually I
have a very Sun position I have a very
healthy Pawn structure this C4 B3 Pawn
structure with this lovely Bishop on B2
and if that knight from H5 moves to
knight from G3 moves to H5 and
eventually white gets a chance of
pushing F4 then things are turning yeah
then we are not talking about black
having counter play Black will be
crammed uh and uh F4 F5 might be looming
there so who is attacking whom on the
king side Lot at stake here I think that
black has to stop white from playing F2
F4 at all cost so something like Rook E8
to f8 should be played unless there is
some crazy tactic yeah we have to watch
out there are so many vulnerable squares
I think if he would ask Fabby he would
say no no everything is fine I'm
enjoying this let's turn to Nicholas for
the ultimate truth in this position
everything that we've been discussing
about this Black's ideas of doubling up
White's counterplay against G7 potential
F4 what do you make of this uh and who's
trying to push for the initiative here
well I think both players are probably
happy with this position as we both
pointed out they like these unbalanced
positions they like to attack they like
to have a lot of complexity in the
position and Knight H5 is making a clear
indication that Fabiano is not going to
watch until black is going to build up
some kind of play on the file on the
squares here against the white king but
he wants to maybe go Knight G4 maybe go
F4 F5 maybe sacrifice on G7 because the
king is a little bit vulnerable it is a
little bit open the engine is evaluating
this position as equal right now which
means that obviously both sides have
their chances and Rook ef8 looks very
logical to my eyes now to double on the
f file and to put pressure here to also
stop F4 apparently because well you just
occupy you attack the square so many
times now Knight G4 looks interesting to
me to to play with ideas of something
giving Checkmate or sacrificing but
doesn't seem to quite work yet and black
has different ways to respond Knight F4
looks looks very logical to to trade
this Knight on H5 and go from there
so to summarize after Knight H5 both
players are in good shape and this could
I think explode there could be some
sacrifices coming here so we should keep
an eye on it and look at the focus the
two players have uh on the board right
now absolutely a critical critical
moment for them and speaking of focus
the chat wants to focus on one
particular game and that is Magnus
Carlson taking on alira fuja and that's
exploding as well we've had some trades
in the center some really exciting moves
preceding the current board uh and I
think we have to back up Peter a little
bit to see how we got to this point yeah
because it had a slow pace and we talked
about this that yeah it's going to be a
fascinating battle but what I see here
that Magnus is having a wonderful
position is already jumping with Knight
to F5 uh hitting the D6 Pawn white has
this perfect harmony look at his pieces
Knight on e4 Knight on F5 Queen C3
Bishop on C2 uh the the D6 Pawn is weak
the G7 square is vulnerable AR in a lot
of trouble but just very quickly maybe
we can jump to Nicholas yeah you have
this auto mode and everything you are
doing it so professionally just let's
run through the game sure we can do that
so we stopped here in a complete
completely symmetrical position after
eight moves absolutely completely
symmetrical so let's see how the game
continued develop from here the Knight
came forward D6 protecting but yeah
somehow here fuza it seems lost a little
bit of the threat putting his Bishops on
the the side the bishop came back a lot
of Bishop moves and Carson took slowly
over playing in the center again the
bishop move here and now he plays in the
center but a little bit too late these
Knights are in very acve positions and
as you pointed out this Pawn is hanging
on D6 in general the white piece feel a
little bit better placed however in this
very moment and apparently Knight to F5
was a mistake by Magnus because in this
very moment and he missed it he could
have played
D5 putting maximum tension in the center
and making use of the fact that this
Pawn is pinned and this would have given
him a good chance for an open game but
after Queen C6 which was played Magnus
should be in front again however lot of
lot of tension here and I think the next
few moves will be critical Tanya and you
really cannot fault a player for making
a move like Knight F5 it is such a
natural human move you want that Knight
on a beautiful Square you want to put
pressure on D6 uh it looks like a very
dominating position currently for Magnus
Carlson and also we can see right in Ali
resa's position right now the queen and
the bishop are eyeing the C4 Pawn but it
feels like the forces are divided you've
got a bunch of pieces of on the king
side still finding their activity and
then there's Queen and Bishop on the
other side of the board meanwhile all of
magnus's army compact in the center
really sort of playing around the center
and with the space that you have but
there is a threat on the board Peter C4
is hanging how much of a threat is this
actually with all the Dynamics around
the D6 Pawn yes well I would feel like
yes okay you want to take my C4 first of
all I can defend it if I want the big
question is do I want to yeah do you you
highlighted yet there are so many
Dynamic possibilities one of the things
Nicholas pointed out this move D6 D5 by
the computer I'm looking at it and once
it's on the board it's so natural and I
was asking myself why didn't it cross my
mind but I also was so focused on this
weakness on D6 and how do I protect it
that the move Queen C6 looks quite
natural uh another big question does
white have some really energetic
response because one really feels that
the the position is asking for some very
special treatment yeah that's at least
my kind of instinct and Magnus is also
taking his time clearly believing that
there could be something
here I think what everyone playing white
would love it is if somehow the queen
and the Knights could coordinate because
it feels like there is a kingside attack
Brewing but also Black's Knight on G6
controls so much of the position and we
see Magnus he's going into a bit of a
think right now uh also not so easy does
he want to play a more defensive move
right now because that D5 is still in
the air it wasn't played in the last
move but let's say if you made a move
like Bishop to D3 I think D5 is still a
possibility in the position yeah very
much so and also the the Queens are kind
of pinning each other on the C file
there's so much tension and Magnus
absolutely correctly senses that this is
a very critical moment yeah he has to
find the light idea here I'm little bit
struggling to find the move which I
would shout out that okay this is what
my have because I have so many ideas but
I don't exactly see yet what is the
right way to proceed move P
move yeah and for Ali Resa as well there
is pressure that he has to deal with but
I look at the camera in front of us Ali
Resa looks pretty chill about the
position he looks very relaxed yeah it
seems like he has very good nerves yeah
he's just enjoying what he is doing he
can play chess and no openings involved
just a wonderful environment yeah I
think it's the vien House Effect yes
he's really really enjoying
himself and there we see uh Magnus
Carlson through the Rooks over there uh
he's got a big decision to make and nlas
what do you make of this critical moment
well I had a look with my friend the the
engine and the way forward the the only
way forward to have a clear advantage or
maybe even close to winning Advantage is
to take on E5 and this is maybe not a
move that instantly comes to mind but
black doesn't really have a great
response for example if I take back with
the Rook then I can use some tactics
here and take the pawn on D6 so this is
getting a little bit crazy now so bear
with me so The Rook cannot take here on
E1 because watch out there's a Checkmate
on G7 so The Rook is pinned and this is
a very critical idea in this position
anyway so now you might say why can I
not take on D6 well then I take back on
E5 I have not only one uh Pawn right now
but more importantly I'm having a very
strong attack against the black king
which black cannot actually defend
anymore and you cannot even take here
because of instant instant disaster not
only are you losing the queen you're
even getting Checkmate the next move
because the Rook is coming up here and
this is it so after d takes E5 if we go
back to this moment how should black
really take
back
and but sorry to interrupt Magnus has
made a move and he missed on this chance
he
B3 yeah that looks a little bit and Al
reaches out and he's got D5 on the board
he did play D5 I mean that that was the
move that we expecting after and Knight
C5 blitzed out by Magnus that's the
current end Alid is blitzing his move
Bishop takes C4 probably he is relieved
yeah that some direct action is
happening have the players calculated
this till the very end they're not even
blinking it it feels like a force
sequence of moves and we see some trades
there Peter which eventually ends with
oliv Resa looking away for a moment
because this is a new position a
completely different Dynamic from before
the start of the sequence of this forced
moves that we saw after D5 the Knight on
F7 is spinned the Knight on C5 is pinned
lot of pins on the board and attention
with the pawns staring at each other in
the center yes and also there is this
spin on the Knight on F7 yeah so the the
queen on C4 but black also has some
counter chances attacking the G2 Pawn
with something like Knight F4 is that
possible or not all this forking ideas
on E7 yes so then white can take Rook
takes F4 he takes F4 Knight E7 Che just
to highlight this yeah if if Knight F4
happens with the idea desire to deliver
Checkmate on G2 then white can for
example take on F4 e takes F4 go Knight
E7 check now this is a fork so we have
to take then white takes with the Rook
on E7 we are still having this spinning
issue white has this active Rook but at
the same time there are no direct
threats and who knows if black has time
to push the move uh F4 F3 openings up
some uh five against white king it can
be very messy lot of tension here but I
would be so scared as black to walk into
this position with this deadly pin on F7
there are back rank issues to deal with
as well uh a big moment for Ali razar
right now and let's check in with the
clock situation he's got some time
that's the good news because for these
kind of positions you really want to
calculate you can't play on intuition so
much Peter yes absolutely not basically
playing on intuition means that probably
you're going to lose in couple of moves
yeah very precise calculation move per
move calculation is required for me it's
very easy to highlight that yes maybe
after FC we have counterplay if not we
design yeah so it's a it's it's really a
lot of tension for them but I want to
ask you right because F3 really feels
like uh like the most dramatic move in
the position and it hasn't been played
quite yet this line no first we don't
need to Deep dive into it but I think it
would have been a chaotic mess uh Peter
instead alira goes for a more safe
cautious approach he first s side steps
any FKS on E7 he Sid steps the pin on F7
keeps the tension on the board but this
does give white the time to actually
push the D pawn attack the queen uh and
this D Pawn can prove to be a very
dangerous Pawn eventually well also it
supports Knight E6 yeah so black has to
keep the pin alive on the C file that's
at least my kind of feeling yeah that
the or well but Queen B6 runs into Rook
B1 yeah we because that would be a pin
on the Knight yeah and then we would
need just one more move to activate with
Rook C8 but we don't have this time
Queen B6 is met by Rook B1 and then if
we go back then already white invades
with the Rook to B7 we we can't allow
that wow it's it's kind of scary it's
it's obvious that white has wonderful
position but I think to understand
what's Le going on we have to pass it
back to Nicholas sure yes so King h8 was
actually not a good move because of
allowing D5 and the line that you were
looking at with Knight F4 was the
correct way to go forward because in
this position that you pointed out
completely spot on Peter and T F3 and
there is counterplay and the position is
almost equal at this point maybe a
slight Advantage for white still after
King h8 however after D5 black has to be
very careful to not be completely lost
immediately and the only way to do that
is not to move the queen back to C8 or
something like this because the pawn is
just running out the D7 is threatened
next and black is in huge trouble but
you have to play Queen B6 and what you
have to realize is that after Rook B1
which would be the natural response to
get rid of this pin along the A7 G1
diagonal you have to move Knight to D6
so this is very difficult to spot this
Counterattack on the White Queen and
even here after next moves white should
have an advantage but it is not as clear
as in after other lines so fza let's be
honest he did did not spend his time
well only spending maybe one two minutes
on King h8 and now after D5 he's in a
lot of trouble and he if he doesn't find
Queen B6 followed by Knight D6 he is in
a lost position t a very critical moment
and a very critical line resource
pointed out you by pointed out by you
Nicholas Knight to D6 after the move
Queen B6 and look at that alira fuja
with head in hands if he doesn't find
Queen to B6 he's close to losing this
one out and with Magnus you're probably
not going to get a second chance he has
to find this geometry that after Queen
B6 you invite another attack on the
queen but you don't need to defend your
own Queen you can go after your
opponent's queen and the main idea is to
make sure Magnus doesn't get that D5
Pawn to D6 yes uh wow but this queen B6
l b because your brain automatically
like I was explaining yeah Queen B6 runs
into Luke B1 and that's definitely
favors white however when suddenly
Nicholas was saying that there is
something I know of course night D6 this
off course effect yeah which you never
have during the game because nobody
signals you that aha there is something
in this direction very critical moment
for ARA he spoted on the other hand this
is very much his trademark yet to find
this unexpected resources but he needs
to invest the time I think he will Peter
exactly what you said at the very end
that it is Ali rza's style to find these
offensive ways these creative ways to
defend a difficult position it's not his
style to play Queen C8 and allow D6 and
to go into this complete passivity uh
he's thinking he needs to spend that
time he's doing it for most people I
think Queen B6 Knight D6 is a very hard
find but alira fuja is not most people I
think there's a huge chance that he's
going to find it what about you Nicholas
do you think he's going to play this
move well it is a little bit lack of
Alternatives also I want to point out
one more other beautiful line Queen C7
you could think well I'm still keeping
an eye on D6 and I still keep the pin I
don't know if you mentioned this already
but here Knight Tak G7 is just
absolutely brutal because if you take
this Knight then there is Knight E6
check and the queen is undefended on C7
and you just lose the queen against two
minor pieces and you might as well
resign so this of course he will spot
and sry one question after Knight take
G7 Knight D6 uh what is the reaction
because I was trying you can just take
okay yeah still hitting the queen and in
the end white will be up material so if
you realize Queen C7 is losing if you
realize Queen C8 D6 looks really bad
then you you have to look for
Alternatives but of course as Peter
pointed out you don't know during the
game that there is still a continuation
which is somewhat okay which is Queen B6
followed by by Knight D6 and that is the
tricky part to to even realize that
there is still a way to stay in the game
and fza I think he's still trying to
find
find his way but he he's not looking
he's not looking very um let's say
positive right now he looks a bit almost
resigned
already body language of elimination and
as you pointed out if Ali Resa sits back
which he is sitting back on the camera
right now and thinks about each of these
moves there is a very big chance that
through the process of elimination he
will come to understand that Queen B6 is
the resource and will find it but he
needs to take his time it's already been
about a thre minute think right now uh
Peter what do you think in these kind of
situations the more time he takes does
that imply that he will play Queen B6 or
does that imply that he's not able to
find anything in the position yes uh
somehow from his body language I'm not
seeing that he he has already find
something that attracts his attention
yeah this is what I'm I'm really missing
yeah because if you suddenly spot this
queen B6 L B1 Knight D6 IDE you you want
to double check you want to make sure if
it's working but then and he goes it
it's on the board Peter he finds Queen
B6 and Magnus about to play The Rook to
B1 has and immediately Knight D6 on the
board wow so that's that's about me
reading Al's Body
Language yes of course Al knew you know
I'm trolling the comment theaters I'm
also trolling Magnus cars and my
opponent I signal like I don't know
what's going to happen and then he
blitzes out the two best moves in fact
the only moves to stay in the game
wow and Magnus he he does that IR I
wonder if Magnus missed this resource
because if black did not have this
Magnus is close to a winning position
perhaps in his head he already felt that
this was close to being over and now he
has to rethink himself he has to reset
his own mind right now Knight D6 but
let's also Deep dive into this position
why is this such an important resource
uh and Peter perhaps you can break it
down for us the different threats and
ideas that exist here well first of all
that uh once we trade that monster
knight from F5 yeah and we with our
passive knight from F7 that's already
good news also if white takes on D6 then
I don't know if I should take on F1 or
not but I just want to highlight that
with Queen takes D6 I get some stability
yeah the black queen on D6 is now
blocking the D5 Pawn I know that I will
have some counterplay with Knight F4 the
D5 Pawn can be a weakness it's of course
a very strong Pawn but also potentially
it can be weak the Knight on C5 yes it
can jump to E6 but again somehow it
feels like BL black might be able to to
handle this and it changes the scenario
yeah before it looked like you are in a
very bad in a lot of trouble in a very
bad position and all of a sudden you
feel like you you have place to breede
for your pieces and there is there are
chances to come
back and it was all about making sure
that that white Pawn on D5 remains
blocked on D5 white doesn't get the time
to push it to D6 cuz that would have
been busted for black so Ali RZA fuja
finding the key defensive resource and
now it's Magnus Carlson on the T
Nicholas is there a way in this position
for Magnus to keep the tension is there
a way for him to defend the queen and
the Knight um and just keep the pressure
on there's not really he needs to trade
pieces and he should trade the Knight
and black can take back immediately
maybe it's even better to take the Rook
first on F1 because white has to take
back with the Rook if the queen was to
take then well black would take first
this Knight with check and then the
other one so this is no good so The Rook
would have to take the queen takes on D6
and still white is better here because
the pawn is still a strong threat Knight
E4 looks very very logical and here
black could gain a Tempo giving a check
the King goes to the side I would expect
and oh excuse me
well uh here we go the queen goes King
goes to the side and and it still looks
uncomfortable this Knight on G6 is not
ideally placed and the pawn is strong on
D5 black is going to suffer either way
and Carlson is definitely still the
favorite to win this but fza is hanging
on maybe he can defend this position
yeah there there had been also the the
moves had been coming in Knight takes D6
we have this position Rook takes F1
check exactly as as you describe Rook
takes F1 Queen takes D6 on the board and
now it's Magnus to
make sure yeah the move Knight E4 that
you highlighted it's such a love I'm
just loving these type of moves and you
highlighted that black has this Knight
on G6 yeah if Black's Knight would be on
F6 we will be actually saying that black
has perfectly equalized there are no
problems but this misplays Knight on G6
is a very special element Knight on e4
it's a blockading knight a lovely
structure in front of the isolated E5
pawn and then after Knight E4 it's clear
that the pawn on D5 will be still a very
important asset and that is is the key
about this position can black stop that
pawn from advancing can white get D6 in
which will decide uh who this position
will favor but it's clear Magnus is in
driver's seat he's the one who's pushing
for a win in this one let's take this
moment to zoom out and get an update on
our other boards bringing up our bird's
eye view four big games in action we saw
the Magnus alira that's the third board
from the right evaluation bar giving a
big advantage and speaking about a big
Advantage it looks like Fabiano just got
a big Advantage with a check on H5
massive things happening on around
wincent kimer he's down in exchange but
it looks like he's managing to prove
that compensation second board from the
right there yes I think we probably even
have to jump right in there we have seen
some big development I think maybe
Nicholas can uh can guide us through
sure yes I believe Vincent is playing an
excellent game right now he sacrificed
The Exchange early on as we saw and now
he opened up the the way to the white
king here playing the very powerful move
E4 and if white was to play the pawn
four which actually would have been the
best choice still for white to give up
the exchange in this way play King F2
and give up give back the The Exchange
then well black would have been also
better but here after taking Now The
Rook comes in and you see the bishop
lined up you see the Knight you see the
queen and all of the black pieces are
participating in the attack and this is
really bad news for ding who's staring
down a potential third loss in a row so
he played Rook D1 now protecting the
pawn on D5 but already I'm looking moves
like Knight H3 check or bring the Rook
over I mean this looks absolutely
horrible and I haven't even asked the
engine we see the the evalation is minus
9 oh Lord this is a lot nighted free
check apparent currently is is winning
the game King
H2 and Rook H4 over and the point is and
that's actually something that Vincent
will easily spot is if why it takes on G
on H3 there to move Queen G4 but this is
this is basic puzzle rush for Vincent he
will obviously spot that there's no way
to defend this sensibly on H3 and if you
cannot take on G3 well then there are
different discovered attacks coming in
Vincent should take this one home he's
reaching out and he finds the first move
of the line that you pointed out Knight
H3 and that is the followup that has to
happen Nicholas King H2 Rook H4 will
Winson make this move well he has to
right if you go in for Knight H3 because
otherwise why did just threatening to
take that Knight yes and he's like uh
double checking the line yeah he still
has time the big question yeah Rook H4
Queen takes F5 there's Knight F4 check
or Knight F2 check uh winning the queen
yeah that's a kind of a very nice cute
little tactic that we can no he doesn't
he doesn't wow he played Queen D6 check
well well Queen D6 also wins but let's
also show that after Queen D6 what
happens if white would have grabbed that
Knight with the King Peter if we can
just back up and show this line King
takes H3 you take the Knight but you end
up losing your king CU there's a check
on H6 forcing the white king to G3 and I
think Queen H4 Queen G4 but why is the
Checkmate here it's white is still
running the way where is the Checkmate
well I was also thinking like L H4 check
was also tempting I I did not because
there is Bishop no Bishop C8 check is
not check me I wanted to highlight that
Luke H4 takes and then check King G5 bam
check and Bishop C8 check after King F5
but there is King E4 back so let's let's
head to Nicholas
hino's it's a quiet move sometimes The
Quiet Moves are the difficult ones Rook
G4 threatening on G B3 and H6 at the
same time and there's absolutely no way
white can defend this Checkmate next
move well actually ding went to play G3
G3 was on the board already Yes G3 was
played and now it's Vincent well he's
still winning minus six but I think Rook
H4 would have been very clearcut there's
just nothing that white could have done
here and here the game continues but he
should still be a big favorite only his
time one minute on the clock is worrying
me a little bit however I I still think
he he will take this one home and the
line that Nicholas is pointing out would
have been game over in two moves had he
played the move Rook H4 and maybe while
he's thinking you can I don't know if
you have the ability to just back up and
show that because it was really quite
the moment here instead of Queen D6 the
idea of Rook to H4 and you were pointing
out why white can't take on F5 Peter yes
because I think that intuitively he
might have S like okay Queen takes F5
not going to go for it but actually
black has this idea of going Knight F4
check on Knight F2 check and thanks to
the check suddenly black black will be
able to pick up the queen on F5 because
the Rook won't be protecting that Queen
anymore yeah so it's let's just put me
like this and even Checkmate on G2
finish no it's it's it's over yeah so
wow yeah it was a missed opportunity but
let's go back to life action and now
wincon is playing on seconds he has a
winning position but no time on the
clock yeah Nicholas you have the current
position yes uh here we go so yeah ding
has to play against Vincent's time he
has to because that's his only chance so
we
saw Knight back Rook takes F5 Queen H6
check King G1 the only winning move is
Rook takes E3 was played by Vincent all
of the black piece are still attacking
the King which is completely deserted
there's no Defenders around the king and
Rook takes G3 is an obvious strong
Fred this well what what is white going
to do I don't even have a suggestion
really well he played rook df1 and
vinent down to 15 seconds there's a mate
in one threatened on f8 so watch out
watch
out oh wow now you have to really
calculate well now you really have to
calculate where he gives a check on G3
we're getting moves really quickly the
players are blitzing out wincent playing
on 10 seconds now he has to make his
move White is coming in with threats he
has to be careful
Queen H3 played wow this is one of these
silent moves yeah which are so easy to
miss and you're hitting that Rook on F3
but Rook on F5 uh right now defended by
the queen but more importantly you're
using the time that white doesn't have
Rook f8 to bring your queen to a
powerful check now Rook f8 is a threat
Knight jumps in Knight F3 check
given and The Rook on F1 is hanging
that's the key move behind key idea
behind Queen on a H3 so white can't run
away with the King to D1 and King E2
you've got Rook to G well also Bishop A6
check B let's not forget about this
monster wow
wow exactly yeah so so white has to take
on FC but that's basically a losing
position then also if you have 10 second
by the way wincent already has not 24
seconds he he should have this in and
for dingler and the night continues this
would be if uh if wincent converts this
which it looks like it's headed that way
for din that would be his third loss in
a row yes yeah it's kind of very sad the
problem is that if you keep on losing
you are not getting this confidence yeah
because I think why the youngsters are
enjoying it so much because they they
feel that the game is going yeah they
they try something they are willing to
risk going for complete sacrifices
everything and it works you get all the
energy and you enjoy you think like you
have free star ch this is the best game
in the world yeah but if you are like
dingli who gets checkmated all the time
he is getting frustrated yeah this has
been a difficult difficult start for
ding at the freestyle chess and let's
just point out the different lines white
was forced to give up give back the
material black can simply recapture on
F3 and now if we do a material count
wincent has two extra pawns and even
greater than that is White's exposed
King on E1 with the opposite color
Bishop uh Dynamics and ding design it's
all about the attack on the king and
that is ding Len's third loss in a row
for wincent a great day continues he
drew with Magnus took down lean aronian
and now takes down the world champion uh
Tingler in really needs to bounce back
in the final game of the day Peter yes
or to limit the damage and then try to
get back tomorrow yeah you never know
all right let's zoom out of this one as
the live action continues on our other
boards let's get into the Magnus Carlson
Ali razza fight that we had a lot of
trades have happened Nicholas get us up
to date with the live action absolutely
so let's see if fuza was able to defend
we left around here and to my great
surprise Carlson did not play Knight to
E4 which pet want to see so badly
instead he played Knight E6 and that
really gave all of his Advantage away in
one move here now fuza played Knight to
E7 and okay let's just quickly go
through it and the Knight on E6 six
looks pretty but the pawn it was all
about the pawn now the pawn is gone here
the queens were traded and this looks at
this point pretty safe for black the
pawns are equal King forward you can
push the pawn forward this should end in
a draw and another disappointment for
Magnus if this game draws he if he draws
this game he has still not he is still
to win his first game in freestyle chess
here in advisen house what's going on
with the Kings today Peter it well the
youngsters the Jacks are very dangerous
and and you know this is what we talked
about yeah that they are just so happy
yeah they love to play chess and now
they don't have to study Theory and so
on they have all this energy they they
are young they are fresh enjoying
everything uh but clearly the Kings will
try to bounce back and it's a long event
it's a marathon event so you can afford
to have a slow start as we talked about
dingl and also is not out at all yeah
the the The Knockout stage will be
completely different Affair and that
scene in front of us I think it tells
the full story of the game that we've
just witnessed uh Magnus Carlson having
such a pleasant Advantage out of the
opening finding all the right squares
for his pieces but when that critical
moment came and I think it all came down
to Ali Resa finding that resource with
Queen B6 Knight D6 changing the Dynamics
of the position and that took Magnus by
surprise taking away all his Advantage
the D3 Pawn how dangerous is that in
this position well I think it's not
about being really dangerous white is
covering that pawn well enough but it
will distract White's forces and in the
meantime black whe somehow organized
it's still a question Rook d8 would be a
natural move but it might run into Rook
h8 check let's just highlight this yeah
that it could be a trick Rook d8 Rook h8
check takes Knight F7 check and then
this Knight end game with White's King
very close to the Deep one can be
tricky all right so tactic still on the
board and Ali rzza is tactically very
sharp he throws in a check first on f8
inviting white king to actually step
closer to that pawn uh and I'm just
wondering if after the move King to E3
we're going to see more tactics with
that black knight jumping onto D5 and
watch out king E3 Knight D5 do not pick
up that pawn on D3 yes because then then
the fork is coming on F4 and it shows
that yeah Lu was a very well timed check
Nicholas is is a ring it it means that
yeah it it was a very yeah L F3 had been
played and now the question is now your
idea maybe now you can move the Rook
because there are no more Rook h8 tricks
if that was important we don't know I
was just uh uh making things up or or
was it really in the
position well um Rook f8 was one of
several moves but you're absolutely
right that Rook d8 could have been a bit
dangerous even here the computer still
says the position is equal after this
nice interu this nice tactic here but it
feels a bit dangerous yeah now the the
evalation is going up a little bit okay
also put a king on on G8 instead of G7
but in any case there was no need to
allow this and fusa Rook f8 very smart
move Rook F3 and now and now he's going
into this end game I'm bit surprised
that he's going for this because it
feels dangerous for black he could have
kept the Rooks on the board like you
said after Rook f8 Rook F3 just play
Rook to D d8 for example and he should
be fine here activate the Rook by the
fifth rank but let's get to the let's
get updated to the current position and
we are in a night end game now which he
has to be careful
fza yeah night end games are always
nightmare yeah if if you are on the
defensive side yeah because the Knight
on e4 actually dominates Black's King on
E7 black would love to jump with the
King to E5 but King E6 runs into Knight
C5 check picking up that vulnerable Pawn
the pawn on D3 is now quite a big
weakness because White's King is so
close and white can slowly like with G3
H4 build up the pressure if if black is
just and fields are down to 13 seconds
wow it is all on fuja he needs to make a
big decision at the moment he goes with
A5 he's waiting for White's Knight to
jump to C5 because then he'll start
pushing the Deep Pawn he needs to use
that as a distraction for White's King
to step over towards that D Pawn so that
his own Knight can start targeting the
kingside pawns so Magnus takes away some
key squares taking away the Knight
jumping on to F4 for fuja again the ball
is in his coat not an easy move to make
down to 5 Seconds four play a move A4 A4
yeah he wants to yeah basically he's
creating another weakness for himself
but his idea is that if you go after the
A4 Pawn then he might run on the A3 Pawn
Yeah so Knight C5 picking up that pawn
gives black the chance of going Knight
C3 Knight B1 he fixed the weakness on A3
so if he can give up even both pawns
yeah Magnus is trying to beautifully
regroup but now black gets activity yeah
because the black king can now start
stepping forward with no night folks in
the air and maybe black will start
looking for activity as well uh just
compare the white king doesn't have hope
of coming towards the D3 Pawn as the E3
square is defended by that Knight on D5
meanwhile give black two moves that
black king will land on D4 and Magnus is
down to 6 seconds he needs to play
Knight D2 just felt like a bit of a
shaky retreat by him and he needs to
make a move he does he gives a check
alas are moving forward Magnus moving
backwards but hang on this is even
dangerous King D4 yeah King D4 okay
Knight takes A4 really relying on this
Knight
C3 oh my God my heart is not taking this
just so scary no this is too scary can
you go Knight C3 now yeah then Knight
B2 and okay I'm already willing to
sacrifice my knight uh has to go back
night I think Knight B2 was the only
move by the way Peter because if white
would have traded and maybe we'll show
that at the end if white would have
traded that's a lost King Pawn ending
even though black is down upon that D3
Pawn is a monster to me it looks like
Magnus has allowed too much activity
yeah way too much but on the other hand
yeah also black needs to watch out yeah
just blindfold blindly pushing D2 and D1
would be a bad idea because suddenly
white would have two flank pawns the
Knight would be kind of overloaded and
only white could win so Knight Knight E4
check and he wants to go King FC Knight
D check and Knight C4 probably to keep
on harassing that Knight and there can
be no Knight trades in this position for
Magnus Carlson because then that King
Pawn ending will once again be lost as
ped is highlighting perhaps what is the
plan we might be seeing this played out
he first steps over is he King C3 looks
like it probably is impossible because
there's a knight D1 check uh in that
position so you still have to calculate
uh alira 7 Seconds dramatic action
because yeah down to two seconds yeah he
pushes D2 correctly my line with Knight
D2 Knight C4 run also into the idea of
Knight takes D6 sacrificing the Knight
for the pawn yeah so he pushes D2 King
C3 we're expecting
now yeah but now Magnus is back in in
control yeah he's not risking anything
anymore Knight D1 and
A4 who needs to be careful in this
position now now black now black needs
to because we have this outside passer
moving up and the point is that after
Knight C3 white trades and then the king
comes back to D1 and white is winning
that King Pawn ending so fuja has to
retreat with his Knight to stop this
Mammoth a pawn that Magnus has rolling
down the
board wow another question why oh it's
like Su Swang position yeah if you go H4
then Knight E4 and going after the G3
Pawn with check and then you lose the
control of the D1 night it's a study
like position with couple of seconds
it's crazy this is chess ladies and
gentlemen
this is freestyle chess ladies and
gentlemen and you're completely right
but it is a race you have to calculate
because H4 ight E4 A6 maybe we can show
it with arrows as the players are taking
a think here and the line that you were
mentioning earlier A6 you take with the
check the king moves anywhere you grab
the Knight on D1 and you're just in time
with the D2
Pawn Magnus Carlson he steps up with his
Knight to
E3 aliar is's taking a pause he has to
keep that a pawn under control but does
this give Magnus enough time to push the
H Pawn now H4 G4 yeah but then Knight B4
and he is going for Knight C2 on Knight
D5 depending yeah Magnus immediately
jumps back to D1 what a dramatic end
game and it's still not over no not at
all what is Ali rza's resource here he
reaches out he attacks what a move he's
putting pressure on A5 and that Knight
is jumping to D4 with a Check Yes double
attack he needs to create threats and
now Magnus also needs to calculate with
20 15 seconds on the clock where does
this lead A6 Knight D4 check and then
King takes
D1 and everything's falling apart around
us as well in this crazy position Knight
F2 played and Ali razza snaps up the
pawn I think Peter this now will end in
a draw yes because Magnus I think
correctly understood that yeah he he
just can't rely on his a pawn he makes
sure that he controls the D Pawn creates
the a H passer black has to watch out he
has to activate that Knight the Knight
has to I don't know from C6 E5 to yeah
this is kind of natural the Knight is
heading towards the F7 Square Knight E5
Knight F7 and white will also always
have the idea of Knight D3 Knight B4
checks to grab that D2 Pawn eventually
Ali RZA starts with a check he wants to
control it with the F5 Square take the
86 uh Square under control little bit
strange for me to invite that King
Knight F5 King F4 because it's known
that the the flank Pawn the H Pawn and
the a pawns are very dangerous against
the Knight he really believes that this
is still all fine it should be because
the pawn is still far
away and ala knows exactly what he's
doing we're going to head into a king
versus King position what a dramatic
fight this was another roller coaster
battle and that's what we've come to
expect when Magnus Carlson takes on
alira fua eventually ends in a draw but
the game was not peaceful at all Peter
not at all it was fantastic incredible
action but it gives us the chance to
jump right into Fabiano against n ABD
satov it's also Kings versus King and
perhaps Nicholas you can break down the
last few moves I think that was the
final remaining game of this round what
happened in Fabiano versus nck well
let's go back a few moves but I think it
has been equal for a long time uh kanana
see to be pressing but could not really
get anywhere so I think it was a well
fought game by both players we didn't
cover that much but from my from what I
can tell is that it was a pretty even
game throughout and a draw was a fair
result and so the third round has
concluded we have once again had two
decisive results and two black wins once
again and one thing I want to point out
so far the Kings have not not been able
to win a single game against the Jacks
wow wow once again also in this round
Vincent kimer Jack here in this in this
tournament and GES um they beat the
experienced players the Kings here
aronian and ding so the kings are
struggling overall and the Jacks are
like you're saying enjoying themselves
having a lot of fun we have one more
round to go and I'm looking forward to
this one guys which is so ironic because
when we talk about the jacks or the
younger generation we're always thinking
about this great opening preparation
that they have Peter and I would think
that you take that out of the equation
you take opening preparation out of the
equation and you're talking about you
know creativity from move number one uh
just that understanding that feel of the
position in my head I would feel that
that experience would count so much for
the Kings but the Jacks are proving me
completely wrong here yeah they are
inspired they are full of energy they
are just enjoying they handle the
situation the nerve nervous situation
ation also extremely well with little
time on the clock we have been seeing
GES beating Magnus Carson with couple of
seconds showing tremendous Precision
Vincent is doing extremely well but
let's not count the Kings out I think
that the the older guys because the
kings are the older guys they need to
adjust yeah so maybe they also kind of
very smart they know it's a marathon
event you can't immediately you you
can't be showing your best chess in all
this eight days yeah of of fully packed
chess uh they are using it as a warm-up
and they will be bouncing back tomorrow
or today's last round or if not then in
The Knockout
stages pet you're the eternal optimist
at some point you want the Kings to
bounce back well they've got to do it
really soon we've got one more rapid
game that is coming up in this round
robin uh the last the final game of the
day and there we have our standings
going into the final game and someone in
our studio is extremely pleased to see
the standings right
now yes of course I'm very happy for
Vincent but it's a long event the most
important he should enjoy what he's
doing and and just uh it's really
fantastic to be here to have this
tournament to have this experience of
playing against the best players in the
world in freestyle chess let's continue
in The Same Spirit to me what stands out
in this leaderboard uh uh Nicholas is
that Magnus is yet to win a game in
freestyle chess yeah that is something
we're not used to seeing but Peter also
said earlier Magnus often has a bit of a
slow start he will really still kicking
himself for this loss that should have
been a win against goo cash and that
would of course paint a completely
different picture but there are still
four rounds to go and in the end for
Magnus I think of course he wants to do
well but he will also Focus his energy
for sure for the clal portion for The
Knockout portion and take this as a
practice round so he is very ambitious
he of course wants to win some games but
I think at the end of the day he will
not be so down right now and and just
try again in next game but it's just
it's not easy because every every
opponent is so strong here and we'll see
if he can beat aronian in the next round
this is the freestyle chest go challenge
we saw the results that we had in this
previous round two decisive games two
games ended in a draw there is a big
fight coming up with some really big
juicy match ups in this final round of
the day and while the players it's all
focused for them it is all getting their
final bit of energy going into this
final round it's going to be extremely
competitive we're really really looking
forward to it but yesterday the players
had a lot of fun before this intense
action started take a look at the
opening
[Music]
ceremony
[Applause]
[Music]
B
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
he
he we are in the beautiful beautiful
Resort of wison house it's I think all
of us are waiting to perhaps go to the
spa and enjoy everything that's around
us but not before a final round of the
day as the chess action continues which
has been absolute chaos which is what we
expect when it comes to Freestyle chess
Peter Exactly yeah we are treated to
some incredible games uh it's just so
nice to be and there are the pairings
for round four Vincent kimer takes on
Fabiano caruana Al a Losa against n Abdu
satov so the Two Jacks facing each other
gash against dingan and Magnus Carson
against no no no no Magnus Carson
against Leon Aran that's a mistake we
know exactly that the two stars Magnus
Carson and Leon Aran are facing each
other nck is not giving a simultaneous
there it will be Magnus against Levon so
the L Classico of Chess these two have
faced each other a bunch of times and to
reveal our final freestyle position of
the day we're going to head directly to
f
oh this is it round four uh the last
round of the day is about to start so
for a final time today please welcome
Holly and Theresa
SAR I think you know the drill already
when you
are there's one ball still stuck oh
there one ball
stuck
don't and we have
number
791 so number 791 thank you so much
Holly thank you so much harar we should
get the position in just a second uh so
the players have 10 minutes now and then
they games will start good
luck uhuh that's the
position and we are back this is our
position going into the final round
there we see Magnus Carlson levon's
board is set up we will have the players
soon discussing uh the first thoughts
the first impressions let's discuss our
first impressions Peter what do you make
of this one well the King on D1 is a
very unfortunate piece the same applies
for Black's King on d8 the good news
that I see is of course the bishop on H1
I'm a big fan yeah so whenever we play
G3 or G4 we already opening up the long
diagonal for that Bishop but finding the
harmony also this look on F1 the knight
from G1 and E1 if he jumps to F3 then it
jumps to the same square I can't really
imagine knight from E1 jumping to D3
because that would block some other
terrain I feel like this is a very
challenging position probably the most
challenging position of the day because
we see an alternate between a heavy
piece and a minor piece for the first
time the king in the center uh the last
couple of positions we've seen King
already on one of the either sides and
perhaps now we can highlight also the
Dynamics that exist on our analysis
board when we get the chance the other
thing that stands out to me is that not
only the bishop on H1 can be included
into the game with the G Pawn moving
forward but even the bishop on C1 and
the Queen on B1 with that B Pawn moving
forward they will find themselves as
well uh coming into the game early on
and there we see the jack Jacks the big
Jacks of the day uh CES and Vincent
being joined by who is that is that
Fabby I see the blue jacket could be
Fabby but is it yeah maybe the Kings
this let's let's learn from the Jacks
yeah what are they analy what are they
talking about yeah because it's clearly
working for them exactly yeah we we saw
the very first run it was Fabby mag I
think yeah Magnus also wants to be part
of
this and we see Magnus stand behind gkes
also looking at the analysis uh as the
players are getting ready these are the
players who will be playing from the
white pieces in this coming round ah yes
exactly makes perfect sense and what are
they looking at so they're looking at
the starting position different ideas
it's so interesting how they come to the
realization of what to play on move
number one they're trying different
setups
here certainly there are so many idea
but I I feel like here there is no
Clarity yeah this is such a mysterious
type of position yeah that to understand
what is the way to
go it's it's so difficult so challenging
all right and as we see the players
discussing Magnus there perhaps pointing
the move B7 to B6 uh trying to develop
fan chatwing his own Bishop if white
gives the chance uh after the first move
so it's going to be interesting to see
to me it looks like one of the natural
moves in this position is
perhaps oh gosh so hard is to start with
either the G Pawn or the B
Pawn well let's involve Nicholas into
the conversation Nicholas what is your
take on this position yeah I absolutely
agreee it is definitely a challenging
one also because the knights are
fighting for similar squares and the
king is awkward in the center and the
first move I was looking at was again
this move C4 also to have a little
threat already take on H7
but of course black wouldn't wouldn't
comply and then I was thinking well
black probably goes G6 and this bishop
is quite strong on this diagonal now we
cannot develop this bishop so easily the
bishop controls the center so then I was
thinking well like Kan was saying maybe
either first bring this guy into the
game by going G3 or maybe also to go B3
to to to to develop this bishop but it
is quite a difficult Choice you're not
going to Castle anytime soon there of
pieces in between King and Rook so I'll
be quite curious what the players come
up with what do you what do you think
Peter what would be your first move yeah
I also somehow feel like G3 is the most
natural move but uh after G3 G6 then
what yeah it's it's kind of the the big
question and this is what we are talking
about that the challeng is there not
only finding the first move but finding
the followup finding the harmony one
thing I was looking at that event
eventually white could try to set up a
short castle with the king from D1
moving to G1 in order to get that I only
only it's not easy but I only need to
develop the two knights then I could
castle and then try to play in the
center and I think you can highlight
that with your uh arrows and your moves
that you're talking about you know you
get one Knight to F3 one Knight to D3
and suddenly the castle will be possible
on the king side also yes but the
problem is then imagine that black s
does something like D6 E5 and my Knights
will be so vulnerable it's it's I just
wanted to highlight that yeah it would
be a nice scenario to get the king
safety uh to King The King to the safy
square but it comes at a cost and I'm
not sure that I'm willing to pay that
cost when the players are deep into
their couple of minutes analysis before
they have to start off and there we see
Fabby and is that not a back yes I think
so I know the jacket yeah the Green
Jacket is notbe yes n backck in his
green jacket and these jackets have been
specially designed for the players each
with their own color uh and they are
handcrafted uh and Peter they look very
Dapper indeed yeah it's it's beautiful
Yeah we actually have to talk about this
also yeah the jackets have a special
meaning every player has his own color
and uh he's kind of fighting for this
color yeah the
it I I think it's very nice and Visually
it's of course very pleasing and as the
players discussed we've been discussing
this position in great depth as well uh
as much as one can get into and we see
wincent we see them laughing we see them
enjoying this position this is so unique
about this format you do not get to see
this anywhere in the world any
tournament in the world and we see
Magnus giving his insights into what he
feels the depths of the position are
and I'm trying to understand what are
the moves on the board what is that
piece on H5 is that a
knight yeah something got activated yeah
Knight F6 Knight H5 they're looking at
Knight jumping onto the edge of the
board wow yeah it's uh well the point is
that here there is nothing to hide yeah
these players are all Explorers yeah
it's like like Columbus Kristoff was
traveling and trying to discover the the
new world yeah you you don't know where
you are going you already moved one you
have to be thinking while in classical
chest you already have your established
repertoire check with super engines uh
the seconds are working day and night to
finalize to make sure that every single
detail is taken care of uh complete
madness here you can just share all your
vision and everybody has his own and you
have to be up to the challenge right
from the very beginning and the only
thing that's guiding you are basic
principles of Chess where you want to
try to find Harmony between pieces you
want to develop the pieces you want to
control the center it's sort of like the
north guiding star to Christopher
Columbus right there exploring as you
said and this is what we see the players
uh trying to understand perhaps the most
complex position of the day the most
challenging one and I see in G's board
with some analysis the 87 Pawn has
fallen off yeah just like Nicholas
highlighted yeah that there is still
this kind of effect that white can play
C3 or C4 targeting that pawn on H s but
when you do something like C4 you also
have to eventually in the long run count
with some B5 Counter Strike when black
could potentially activate the queen
from B8 of course there are so many
different scenarios because we already
talked about if white first develops or
starts with G3 opening up the bishop
it's basically a developing move because
the bishop is automatically developed
after G3 very intriguing
position uh and what what do you make of
this uh Nicholas we've been seeing the
players analyzing we're trying to break
this position down the more you look at
it what would you predict as the move
that we're going to see on the board
from White yes I would also be very
curious to hear your predictions I would
probably go with G3 first of all I mean
this looks very sensible to open up the
bishop and if we can get something like
Knight to G Knight to F3 and then the
castle then would be pretty normal
faneto situation position so this looks
sensible then if black copies us let's
say going G6 now the question is what to
do next maybe even play a slow move like
C3 first of all I'm I'm not really sure
or the Knight could be brought out here
to F3 and then slowly getting the castle
getting the piece into play but it is
very tricky what do you guys expect as
the first moves T completely agree with
you I think there's a consensus in the
studio that white needs to open up that
Bishop on H1 and we've been talking
about the classy chest that we've been
having In freestyle chess and The Classy
jackets that the players have been
adorning let's take a look at the vision
behind the Jacks and the Kings and them
dressing
[Music]
up
and the players with their different
color jacket loving that look uh Peter
loving the chest that we've been getting
what was your favorite
color wow okay I like dark blue actually
I think Magnus is having dark blue but
so far it hasn't really B him any
success and uh the the Jacks the
youngsters with their uh Dynamic jackets
are doing very well
it's it's interesting yeah but I think
we also have now lift off some direct
action we have to jump right into the ah
the gong is about to that was still
because suddenly we have seen some
mysterious moves and we are not sure if
that's already life action the gong is
about to be hit just any second now it
will be lift off and you spoke about the
Jacks the younger generation with their
uh combative jacket colors gkes is
wearing red and he's been going for
blood yes absolutely ever since he BNS
came back against from that horrible
position he has been Unstoppable also
beating Leon AR in the previous round
what's been your favorite color so far
Nicholas I I personally like dark blue a
lot so I'm also wearing a dark blue
jacket myself right now but I have to
say the red looks good yeah the red
looks it has it makes an impression but
in general I love the idea of uh
choosing different jackets for the
players and now we do have lift off and
we have seen C4 and G3 here in the game
between gash and dingly ren with which
game do you guys want to start well I
see that Vincent actually opted for D4
and he goes Knight FZ I wanted to
highlight yeah that this would be my
setup and Vincent goes for it that D4
Knight F3 then Knight D3 already makes
perfect sense yeah that black is not
able to occupy the center like we talked
about without the pawn on D4 and Knight
DC then come muscles and play the move
GC and it's a very classical D4 type of
position and really nicely highlighted
out because the pawn in front of the
Knight is a very good construction for
the Knight rather than the knight in
front of the pawn you control more
Central squares you take away the
advances of your opponent's Pawn so D4
followed by Knight D3 is what you want
rather than rushing with your own Knight
to D3 the bishop on C1 would have felt
claustrophobic in that case so this is
the structure that wincent has gone for
Peter you said you approve of it we
might be seeing that early castle that
we were talking about in this game uh
and uh Nicholas what are your thoughts
we were expecting G3 not in this one but
it's perhaps going to happen at some
point well well can one can obviously
see the influence of Peter over Vincent
that they think alike and this makes a
lot of sense now that I see it G3 Knight
D3 castle and you get into a very normal
kind of position as normal as it can be
for freestyle chess
so Fabiano just played D5 himself
mirroring uh Vincent for now I would
expect now G3 or Knight D3 do I have to
watch out for G3 Bishop H3 is this
something that might be annoying maybe
here a little bit could be yeah exactly
because then we might lose the right to
Castle yeah if if we move that Rook we
will never be able to Castle short and
after we committed the move d4 going for
long castles it's kind of almost out of
question because how do we develop those
pieces at all yeah and at the same time
we don't want to put a knight on G2 and
we also don't want to trade our Bishop
but maybe this might be still the the
least evil here so this is something
that Vincent is considering right now
and what I noticed Vincent is usually
taking his time in the first few moves
and has served him well he is the leader
in the tournament right now he has two
and a half out of three points so he's
doing quite well and we see
Fabiano in the picture right now and do
we have another move after yeah G3 has
been played so he's consider it's it's a
London system no no he played Bishop F4
London system Knight F3 Bishop F4 played
Peter and I think all these lines that
were being discussed the problem with G3
allowing the light Squad Bishop into the
game is what wincent was not happy to
get uh so he avoids it for the time
being and Fabby goes with the same idea
improving the night once the bishop on
C8 has been activated yes it's sensible
it's kind of some
symmetrical London symmetrical r with
Knight FC GC and then black going for D5
G6 one of the most reliable setups it's
a big strategical battle but little slow
Affair I think this also gives us the
chance to jump to the other games I'm
pretty sure that there is some more
Dynamic action somewhere let's bring up
our birds eye view and there we have the
opening moves of all the position we've
discussed well the London so to say in
the wincent board uh with the setup D4
Knight F3 Bishop F4 meanwhile on the Ali
Reza versus nck no pieces have been
developed only pawn moves by Ali Rea as
well as nck but we are expecting the
Bishops to come into play the Knights
moving ahead after that a very similar
approach on our other board as well with
gkes holding back with the peace
development Peter what do you make of
these uh different lines that has been
chosen by the white player yeah it's
very interesting it just shows that how
reach the is this game is yeah everybody
can have his own take what I'm very
excited to explore and to to have a look
is Magnus carag against Leon Alan this
is two incredible greats are facing each
other let's not forget yeah leevon has
been in the top 10 and like top five in
the world for like 15 years there was
always this debate that yeah Levon could
be the most unpleasant Challenger for uh
Magnus Carson and now fighting it out in
a freestyle chess game I want to see
this let's do it let's head over to
Magnus against Levon as wincon is having
a think on his board and wow we see a
really interesting Dynamic here that
white started with this D4 C3 setup and
Levon in his true artistic creativity
decides not to put the B Pawn on B6 but
on B5 taking control of the C4 square
and he wants to put that Bishop on B7
eventually challenging the light Squad
Bishop on H1 once you get G3 in yeah now
Magnus is also trying this slow approach
yeah slowly step by step building up
yeah D4 C3 I I really love this
construction of fighting against that
very powerful Bishop on h8 we talked
about this that yeah we want to play GC
and black clearly wants to play G6
making sure that that Bishop is kind of
blocked and I do Envision Magnus also
eventually going for Knight FC and then
short Castle is is something like going
for some very ambitious trying to get e
for him but I think black is controlling
the B4 Square uh enough but one angle if
black plays a move like Bishop B7 we
have some Knight C5 move jumping and
attacking that harassing that Bishop I'm
liking White's position and that is a
drawback of the move B5 right you've
left some holdes behind and immediately
Magnus trying to take advantage of uh
that weakness also after B5 you're
hesitant to push that D Pawn controlling
the C5 Square there are many reasons for
that you don't want the d Pawn on D6
because that's a square one of your
Knights wants to land into secondly you
leave a lot of light Square weaknesses
on the board so an interesting decision
by Lon Nicholas to go for B5 but it has
its own set of drawbacks absolutely and
it's something I want to ask you guys
about because it is always the question
in these beginning Moves In freestyle
chess whether you push the pawn one
square forward or two squares forward
Arona in here decided to put his Pawn on
B5 he grabs more space he controls more
space here and maybe even has a
potential push of B4 but the clear
downside is there are more squares that
are weakened for this especially the
square C5 and he can never really play
D5 or it would come at a huge cost
leaving the square completely undefended
so when I've played freestyle chest
myself has always been a question where
to put the Pawns in the beginning of the
game we see that Carlson took a more
cautious approach and playing against
this bishop and here it seems to make a
lot of sense at least when I look at the
computer right now already giving a
clear Advantage for white and I think
this is one of the tricky decisions to
make how far do you go with the Pawns in
the beginning of the game yeah and just
look at the picture look at it it tells
it all yeah Leon is in kind of state of
horror State of Shock that we have just
played two moves from black side three
from White and I already don't see how
to continue at the same time now Magnus
in his in his element feeling like okay
now it's time to start the tournament
I'm enjoying what I'm doing and this is
going to be the first game that I going
to win here and that's a critical game
for these two players who are actually
coming out of not a great start Levon
lost the previous round to gkes and now
fighting it out against Magnus who's
also had uh well we haven't seen him
find his rhythm in the first three games
so really important end to the day for
these both these players speaking about
Nicholas's point about how far do you
want to really push your pawns I've got
an update for you guys Ali Raza fuja is
is going absolutely berserk with his
Pawn pushes and he might be leaving some
squares behind as well so if we just
pull up that game and look at that five
moves by white all pawn moves Peter wow
okay this is like a close Sicilian
almost yeah like occupying all the space
and perhaps Nicholas we could start from
the top uh and take us through this
fascinating opening so G3 the move that
we expected also which has been played
at least in one of the games alongside
with D4 now C6 was played immediately
trying to limit this bishop on a long
just second Nicholas we had some we
don't see you yet just a second yes we
will just have uh so maybe you play
through then slowly the analysis board
yes okay so G3 C6 yeah C4 G6 now F4
quite a bold decision by fur R and just
grabbing more space and there you are
all right sure so
E4 T already the computer is liking
black so you really have to be careful
with the pawn moves and D6 was played D3
and Knight C7 and a queen C2 Castle wow
here we go there's a castle all right
just let's see this again for many
probably watching here who haven't seen
this so it is possible to Castle on
freestyle chest this is the short Castle
now the king just jumped over because
the Rook is already in the right place
and I don't know I mean black has played
sensate moves developed two pieces has
castled what has white done at the same
time not developed a single minor piece
played the queen to C2 I'm not sure what
this was about so the computer is giving
a clear verdict here and is saying black
is an excellent shape already with the
potential uh lever here of B5 and fza
really has to hurry I think before the
position opens up to get his King out of
the center so this was maybe a case of
too many Pawn pushes in the beginning of
the
game yeah and also really
masterfully uh kind of reacted by Abdus
satov yeah that he did not get fooled by
that okay white is very energetic white
is oying the center he felt like if I
get my own Harmony yeah if if everything
falls into its place and black knight
was going to C7 it's such a lovely
Square we know this regrouping in this
kind of structures I will be uh
commenting on that right away Queen C2
short Castle knight ef3 uh we are
expecting somewhere something like B5
but also this Knight on C7 had this
incredible potential of eventually well
the E6 Square to have access to D4 it's
it's a question black pushes E5 or not
the same problems white is faced with
that if you develop that knight from G1
to E2 there might be this bishop H3
trick stopping any kind of short castle
and then very is white king running and
B7 B5 is coming as well pawn moves are
the most committal moves in chess they
don't move backwards so you have to be
extremely careful and we see all these
holes that are being pointed out by UPA
that put aliar in a bit of danger
long-term danger where does he find his
King safety if you go with a longside
castle with taking out your Bishop from
C1 putting that King on C1 and The Rook
on D1 that Bishop on h8 is a monster
eyeing the B2 Square B5 break will put
white in tremendous danger but if the
long side if Queens side castling is not
a possibility kingside castling looks
also like a farway dream because the
moment that Knight moves from G1 nck
will throw in the move Bishop H3 before
you get your king to G1 so it looks like
things have gone wrong long from the
very start for Ali Raa in this one he
needs to still fight to equalize he's
fighting to equalize with the white
pieces let's zoom out let's bring up our
bird's eye view and get an update on the
other openings uh that we've got going
on tremendous action on all the boards
so let's zoom out for a moment bring up
our boards and Nicholas which game
catches your attention well we have a
lot of different positions so we saw in
the game of Vincent against kaana it
really resembles uh a normal D4 position
and the game I was looking at right now
is the game between gash and dingly ren
where if you see this evalation this
means bad news for dingly Ren who is not
in good shape in general in this
tournament as he Lo has lost his first
three games so far and he's in trouble
once again in this game so let me take
you through the first few moves so you
can see how this happened C4 also move
we considered immediately hitting this
Pawn on H7 and now G6 G3 this makes a
lot of sense C5 Knight F3 Knight comes
out D3 F5 Knight C2 Knight F7 Castle
Knight F6 and Knight
F6 allowed for gach to play B4 because
the bishop is not uh attacking The Rook
anymore and the king is not really
feeling safe of course black can Castle
but still white is taking over here
bringing the queen into play I honestly
I'm a bit surprised how bad this
position already is the computer is
giving a winning Advantage But Here For
example you cannot Castle right now
because if you did then this Pawn could
be just taken on E7 right maybe there's
some Rook E8 Rook takes E2 but it looks
very very bad bad
and so what did ding do
D6 and now Bishop B2 looks very logical
now Castle finally Knight E3 maybe gkes
didn't play the
most powerful way but still his position
looks very very sensible the king with
the move F5 is weakened this looks like
an English gone wrong for black right
Peter Exactly yeah this is like some old
school wisdom yeah that you manag let's
let me just highlight the pawn structure
we have C4 D3 E2 F2 G3 H2 we are
basically playing the banker Gambit
without sacrificing anything we have
this intact blovely Pawn structure black
does not have the C Pawn anymore this B7
Pawn is kind of a Target because of
course black wants to play some B6
Bishop B7 it might also run into some
Knight D4 Knight C6 some conrete
problems but even let me just highlight
some slow strategical idea like A4 A5
and we already going going after that
vulnerable queenside structure the
bishop on B2 is beautifully uh developed
on the long diagonal the bishop on H1
does not need to move it's already doing
a perfect uh job let's even not forget
about somewhere even some idea like
Bishop takes F6 Bishop takes F6 Knight
D5 some complete shocker can be in the
position of course we're going to only
do it if it's really winning otherwise
we just enjoy everything what we have
already yeah it's quite a dream position
out of the opening for G shoes had quite
the start in the freestyle chess
meanwhile dingler and really struggling
and do you think that also makes a
player a target for G he wants more out
of this game he knows he's playing
someone who so far has not had a great
day he gets this position out of the
opening and that would make GES well
he's always ambitious but perhaps more
ambitious well I think he's just
enjoying that after that horrible start
to to doday yeah because let's not
forget yeah he lost the first game in
the second game it looked like he going
to lose the second consecutive wi game
and then we will be talking about a
terrible start for gkes but he BNS back
against Magnus and then he beat leevon
and now he gets the upper hand he
clearly has the flow yeah he he gets
this feeling that yes I'm good yeah and
and this is one of the most important
things it is a lot about momentum and
and also the fact that this is a
grueling difficult brutal format for the
players 25 minutes with a 10-second
increment this is the fourth round of
the day you're over 4 hours of play
Peter stamina energy you know you have
to start thinking from the very first
move on the board you have to use your
gray cells from the very start of the
board this is brutal yeah and then why
are we surprised that the youngsters are
doing so well yeah they have the energy
yeah that's that's why I'm also sitting
here in the studio yeah because okay I I
have chess wisdom but it's one thing to
have the chess wisdom and another one
your clock is ticking and you always
have to make the right decision keep
your nerves under control that there is
so much challenge it's just chess is not
just about Chess knowledge yeah there is
so many other aspects as well yeah
absolutely perhaps that is the key to
the secret of the performance that we've
seen by the Jacks today just their
energy their stamina level they've been
so on a point in this one we see dingler
in trying to develop his pieces trying
to take that Bishop out uh but there are
ideas with the Knight jumping to the
center of the board Knight D4 comes to
mind we will keep an eye out on this
position as GES with a very pleasant
outcome of the opening but let's zoom
out for a moment and get an update on
some of our other boards and bring up
our bird's eye view and there we have it
we see Magnus Carlson on our extreme
right already playing with a big
Advantage look at that beautiful Bishop
planted on G5 eyeing that King on d8 and
that Knight on C5 meanwhile leavon
pieces struggling Peter yes I feel like
we have to jump right into that position
because it it's an illustration yeah
that how fast things can escalate and go
wrong if if you are not careful enough
leavon has blitzed out his first two
moves ever since he has slowed down look
at this Magnus is having like almost 10
minutes time Advantage he's enjoying
this fantastic position and what we
talked about the question that do you
push this Pawn to B6 or to B5 well in
this position clearly it should have
been B6 should have been played because
this monster Knight on C5 the bishop on
H1 is already alive and if you have to
play a move like C6 to protect your Rook
look at those cramped pieces that Bishop
on C8 how do you get
Harmony I think we have to turn to
Nicholas uh for an insight into this
position because things are looking very
bad for black right now they do and it
really started with the move B5 in the
second move already already here
immediately the engine is giving a clear
Advantage for white and also the
position just becomes very difficult to
play with always the Knight looming to
go to C5 being quite close to the king
restricting the black pieces and it
really has only gone downhill from here
for leevon because if we arrive at the
current position F5 F5 also a move that
Ding played but a move that further
weakens the position especially where do
you put your king you play B5 you play
F5 the king will not feel safe anymore
neither on the king's side nor on the
queen side so F5 is also a move that
weakens to position another pawn move
here no pieces have really been
developed this Knight moves again and
Knight G5 and now we reach this position
the current one Bishop takes G5 eight
moves have been played but look at the
pieces this bishop is great this bishop
has developed the Knight is well placed
you can only say that about one of the
black piece here the bishop on G7 white
can Castle uh King side and E4 can come
this looks like absolutely gone horri
wrong for Ronan who's staring down a
potential thir loss in a row if I'm not
mistaken and Magnus of course wants to
get that first win for him in the
tournament and so far it's looking
really good and it just goes to show we
have three games where somebody already
has a decis or clear almost decisive
advantage and these are the absolute
best players in the world just goes to
show how difficult this freestyle chess
really is and especially this position
we said it from the beginning is a
really challenging position and really
has um shown itself in the game so far
and we often taking your point forward
there Claus we often talk about how in
standard chess playing multiple games of
Rapid in a day can be more exhausting
than playing one long classical game and
Peter imagine having to do that in
freestyle chess that really steps up the
level of exhaustion that the players are
probably feeling right now yes on the
other hand they also have this thr yeah
that every single game is a new new new
discovery yeah and we see that this
Gathering you don't see that Gathering
we talked about this yeah that that
special gathering before the game and uh
trying to find ideas to to put pressure
on the opponent to limit the damage when
you are playing from the black side it's
it's all connected it it's just so nice
to see that yes there are many
challenges but you also get a lot of
energy because it's fresh yeah and you
are so
excited and the positions are getting
very exciting and look at the clock
situation as well Magnus with almost
double the amount of time on the clock
there Levon struggling early on trying
to get his pieces out right now maybe
even hinting at trying to push that away
that Bishop from G5 at a potential 86 at
some point but there's a lot of exciting
stuff going on on our other boards as
well so if my eyes are drawn to the GES
versus dingler and B and I know we've
been discussing that for a while Peter
but there have been a lot of changes and
if we can just pull up gkes taking on
ding because something has happened Whit
SN has landed on E7 uh we have to I
think back up a little bit there's a pin
on E5 what on Earth is going on
Nicholas yeah it's uh there has been a
lot of changes actually gkes has
sacrificed The Exchange so it is an idea
that Peter was pointing out already to
give up the bishop on F6 to get access
to the square on D5 and quite a powerful
idea because black doesn't want white to
take on F6 but at the same time you
cannot move the bishop you cannot take
the Rook or actually can take the Rook
excuse me I thought there would be an
immediate pin but you shouldn't have
taken really he did take but now after
Knight takes E7 check King G7 Rook takes
A1 white has taken his Pawn this Pawn is
weak and white has beautiful beautiful
conversation for the exchange I mean if
if you ever want to call something a
positional exchange sacrifice this would
be definitely it a weak King the dark
squar Bishop is missing which was an
important Defender for the king so
Knight E5 and now Queen C3 and Rook E8
was played well the obvious reply would
be to bring the Knight back gukesh with
a really powerful exchange
sacrifice and especially the king is
worrying me so much here the king will
be weak for the rest of the game why has
a beautiful structure what not to love
here Peter yes I'm loving it yeah okay
everything which is position is so
sunand and so promising it's it's very
much to my liking uh the one thing I
don't like is clearly ding's position
yeah and and also we have been having
ding on the camera he's in a State of
Shock yeah this day has gone horribly
wrong for him and Bishop C6 Knight D4
are we seeing these moves Knight D5 on
the board and I think ding is still
having a thing he's still having a thing
okay
so so tough yeah how do you the queen on
B8 yeah let's uh let me yeah let me
update so this is all happened Knight D5
the queen on B8 The Rook on A8 they they
are not participating in the game white
simply can improve the position by going
Rook B1 that's why my feeling is that
black kind of has to play the move
Bishop C6 get rid of that Knight on D5
but Bishop C6 Knight D4 and this is what
I was expecting that maybe it already
happened because then suddenly let me
just put on the board Bishop C6 Knight
D4 Bishop takes D5 Bishop takes D5 we
are not only getting this incredible
beautiful Bishop on D5 but we also
threatening to push F4 and then bust
open the long diagona if that Knight has
to move from E5 black will be checkmated
after a double check with Knight E6 and
queen G7 check and this is this is is
such a shocking position that P dingl
especially after losing three games in a
row how can he fight here and you can
see uh that Ding is he hates his
position right now this is not something
that Ding wants to fight this is not
something that Ding wants out of the
opening a very difficult difficult day
it's been a very difficult position in
the final round as well he finally makes
the decision to move that Queen from d8
so the Knight on D5 still stays alive
now the idea of bringing the Rook to the
open line Rook B1 attacking targeting
that pawn on B7 or perhaps even a knight
jump Knight D4 like you were pointing
out again keeping the idea of f4 on the
board uh dingler and in big big trouble
in this
one yeah Nicholas do you have some some
good news for ding fans or is it really
so hopeless as we are describing it is
very very much so hopeless as you're
describing and I think for ding also to
find the motivation now you can see it
in his body language he is he is very
much frustrated and he cannot believe
how this day has gone I mean he is a
world champion and him potentially
losing all four games here is of course
very very tough however the opposition
is pretty much as strong as it can get
and now we see he has moved the king to
F7 the computer is giving a decisive
Advantage here F4 is certainly a move
one can look at but probably also just
improving The Rook to B1 first of all or
some other moves are completely fine
where's the where's the black
counterplay what can black do that that
is the problem there are some positions
where you lost and you have some chances
you can muddy the waters you can do
something but here I don't really see it
what black can even do because there are
no Targets in the white position and the
black king you always have to watch out
this move F5 really longterm weakened
the black king so I would clearly expect
GES who's been in great shape the last
two games to take another win here
Tanya and I think our camera view also
tells the story that we're seeing on the
board ding looks absolutely devastated
with the position that he's landed
himself up into out of the opening he
had to make the move Rook to B8 to
defend B the B7 Pawn B6 would have
opened up that Bishop on H1 with a
tremendous diagonal so the move Rook B8
it's not a happy Square for The Rook but
you have to be on the defense the King
on F7 always has to watch out for a
check on D5 once white moves the Knight
away but I'm seeing all of White's
pieces gk's piece is beautifully placed
he's managed to get the Rook into the
attack he's managed to get the knce to
the center of the board the Queen
looking good it's all about how does
gkes wrap things up how does he actually
find the way to make progress and while
he takes a thing to do that while he
finds his way forward let's zoom out of
this position and jump into some of the
other action that we've got
uh let's bring up our bird's eye view
and uh take a look at what is happening
and the first thing that strikes me is
on
our first board from this extreme left
that just looks like a normal position
out of a standard chess
game it's the most normal position we've
had all all day Peter wincent versus
Fabby yes uh but my eyes are not that
good to see everything it looks good
yeah but we will take a closer look then
I can better explain what I'm thinking
and Nicholas you've got another game up
for us we will jump into the standard
position between Winston but take us
through Magnus versus L we need to go to
Magnus against aonian because Magnus
just sacrificed the piece and he's
really it looks like going to crush
aonan here completely which let's be
honest looked like this already after
the first few moves we we last stopped
here Bishop F4 hitting the queen
provoking D6 and now Carlson simply took
the Pawn on
C6 of course this is something that
Arona anticipated now deflecting the
Bishop from pinning the the pawn however
this is costing some additional pawns
and now Queen to D3 and we will see
probably the queenside castle in the
moment where the king steps to C1 and
The Rook will come over to D1 lining up
perfectly and this king is not getting
out of the center anytime soon black if
black was able to play Knight F6 and
then Castle but well first of all
there's a bishop and also the Black
Knight has to move then well we could
talk about it but here it looks really
really difficult the computer is saying
pretty much the only move to even try is
King to C7 Bishop F4 you still have E5
white can take on A8 and now follow up
with Bishop F4 or take the pawn on
B5 and it's on the board King C7 had
been played by leavon all right so he's
fighting the board he's fighting
but I cannot I cannot uh believe that
Magnus will let this one slip it looks
just too good for him plus okay he's up
a little bit on the clock not as much as
before however it looks really really
difficult for
leavon big pressure on leavon but making
the accurate defensive move Sid stepping
any checks on the D line and once again
the problem of Plenty for Magnus there
are so many choices that can be
attractive in this position you can grab
the Rook on eight8 you can first give a
check on F4 you can grab the pawn on B5
and Magnus slows down yes well I feel
like I even don't want to look at The
Rook on A8 because that Rook on A8 is a
horrible piece Black's Queen on B8 is
terrible yeah if if Black's most active
most active piece is Black's King on C7
that already tells the story yeah then
something
horribly wrong had happened Magnus has
opted for D4 D5 I I very much like this
move it it feels like a brutal move to
me uh we are setting up some Bishop F4
check ideas we are also going for long
Castle I do see the evolution but
slightly dropping like the computer is
not exactly sure what to think of this
move but humanly it makes perfect
sense yeah there's a massive threat on
the board the one that wasn't as strong
in the previous move because black had
the move E5 now there's onp pasan so E5
will not be possible for Bishop F4 check
so leavon stops the diagonal the bishop
jumps onto E5 wants to plant itself onto
that defensive square of D6 The Rook on
A8 is not going anywhere the bishop on
C6 a really nice piece but give leevon a
couple of moves and maybe bishop B7 is
coming next yeah and uh we are talking
about Levon you remember this very first
game against Abdu saturo it also looked
like wow he will get checkmated and he
find finally the perfect harmony I feel
like this move Bishop E5 is some kind of
a game changer in a sense that black is
trying to get stability the big question
is uh will he be able to because I'm
pretty sure that Magnus will do
everything in his power not allow black
to
stabilize we were talking about the
problem of Plenty and we discussed many
moves D5 was not one of them but we were
impressed with it once it was on the
board Magnus with his own ideas Bishop
B5 Nicholas Peter feels that this is a
stabilizing move or at least aims at
stabilizing for black how does Magnus
keep the pressure on here yeah Bish
should be was very necessary to stop
Bishop F4 and aronian also played this
move rather quickly and it seems that
one p potential approach is to play A4
to open up some more files for the Rooks
and get to the king let's not forget we
can move this King to G1 in just one
move this Rook hasn't moved yet so white
can Castle so don't worry about the King
still being here yes white would need to
take one move to get it out of this the
center but it is not a problem so A5 A4
looks looks pretty strong to me because
you try to get more heavy pieces
involved and open up the king
further and let me see what how can
black respond
well okay black can take white can maybe
Castle first then take on A4 double
up the king is a it's a it's it reminds
me of the game between uh aronia and
abto tur in the first round where two
the turf also sacrifice a piece for
long-term compensation and here it will
be a similar story I mean white already
has two pawns well this Pawn on A4 will
fall any moment then it will be two
pawns plus white could maybe take the
Rook but the bishop is a stronger piece
anyway right now so I think if Carlson
goes well A4 is one option let's see
what else is there B4 is also an option
he has to play here for sure he has to
play an open the king and then it should
be a very difficult defensive task for
onion I have to ask you what about well
a move that many of us would consider
natural just grab that Rook on a you
want to neutralize the material you're
also seeing this B5 Pawn at some point
coming on the fire and you mentioned
that's not one of the top moves here but
how does that affect White's Advantage
white still has an advantage but it's
not as big and especially becomes easier
for black to play because suddenly you
feel a bit safer with the King you have
to Bishops you can you have some more
room you have some more squares for your
pieces and you don't have this this
bishop right in inside of your position
so I think that helps black and that
goes to show sometimes we shouldn't um
focus so much on the material but rather
how well are the pieces placed and if we
compare the pie just a breaking news A4
on the board A4 on the board all right
well that was one of the choices by the
engine so just to to conclude that the
bishop is a much better piece than this
Rook right now which is completely
passive and has not even moved and
cannot even move so Carlson is not
giving up the bishop and instead he has
played A4 and he's upping up the
pressure Peter yeah I have to add that
when I saw this bishop E5 I felt like
yes there is some hope that black is
stabilizing and then when you mentioned
the move A4 I thought yes okay that's it
I don't know where do I get any safety
yeah because this key idea that you can
steal C short yeah this is so important
let me highlight it that yeah we have
the chance of jumping with that King to
G1 any moment yeah leevon is challenging
that Bishop on B7 but look at this
bishop B7 is a extremely desperate move
probably a good one because doesn't
matter what's happening you have to
eliminate that monster Bishop from
C6 A4 so impressive Alpha zero suggests
A4 Alpha Magnus plays A4 he's not
getting greedy with that Rook on A8 Leon
Aran still in big pressure here um
Magnus responds he goes he gets his King
to safety and yes you want to get rid of
that Bishop on C6 but you really cannot
take that Bishop on C6 I feel that
allows so much activity down on the
defile but let's show this line Bishop
takes Bishop Pawn takes Bishop if black
was to capture with the King I'm already
looking at ideas like Rook D1 Queen F3
check and it looks like it's going to be
an extremely difficult uh position for
King safety with all the lights squares
out uh for white for the taking Queen D7
is such a big threat yes there are so
many threats uh okay Bishop D6 is the
only defense that I can rely on in this
type of positions I don't know how much
it is a defense because the position is
falling apart and a takes B5 and I can't
take on B5 because of Luke A6 check
winning the queen yeah in this
circumstance so many problems so I would
okay let's go back to the position I
would not really like to take on C6
unless I see exactly move P move that I
can somehow get out Nicholas and his
thoughts yeah that's completely right uh
your intuition is spot on if black takes
on C6 opening the defoul uh the position
is is over this is winning for for black
there just too many weaknesses to the
pieces are not coordinated to defend the
king so this is lost instead black
should he takes on A4 we have a move on
the he takes on A4 well this is also not
a good choice according to the computer
was at least not one of the top three
choices and well I think seems obvious
that white should take back
so yeah and uh Dev varation is rising
and Rising the other Rook comes into
play and once again we also have to
remember the Practical aspect this
position is so much easier for white to
play to attack is usually easier than
than to defend and the position plays
almost itself
T really nicely pointed out there by you
that with this trade black spawns get
even weaker there's another open file
for the the final piece to join the
party The Rook from F1 to come to A1
let's also point out there's a C5
weakness we can sometimes imagine and I
think Magnus has made the move Rook
takes Pawn if we update our analysis
board right here uh after Levon went
pontic Pawn The Rook has jumped into the
attack there are ideas of even Rook C4
B4 opening up the C file maybe directly
B4 leavon King is going to be in big
danger for a long amount of time in this
one and maybe this is our as this game
heats up let's just zoom out for just a
moment get a quick update on all our
four other boards that are in action and
of course we'll jump straight back there
we have it uh we see on our extreme left
the position that we thought was the
most standard chest position Winston
continues to put the pressure on Fabiano
Carana but there's more space on the
king side look at that nicely planted
Knight on the E5 Square the Rooks in the
center wincent with a pleasant position
here meanwhile Ali Resa in big trouble
nck has the bishop pair but Ali razar's
down upon PA why is this so bad The Rook
on D1 is not hanging what's going on
there well the dark squar Bishop I think
that's that's the key the dark squares
the Knight on F2 is far away of trying
to control the D4 Square let me just
highlight that this Knight on F2 a part
of Defending The Rook on D1 and
protecting the D3 Pawn doesn't do
anything black is also threatening
simply to invade with the Rook to C2
then already some tactics like Rook
takes F2 Queen takes D1 will be in the
air it it just feels like without the
dusk F Bishop if if that Bishop would be
on E3 we would be talking that okay
white has more or less a stable position
but but the Knight on F2 is is just dead
Bishop on G2 is doing absolutely nothing
black has an overwhelming position we
talked about this that alias aggressive
approach of pushing those pawns forward
heavily backfired and we are seeing some
incredible Master Class by n back Abus
off here yeah how to play against
overextended pawns playing on the
weaknesses and a big threat on the board
The Rook comes to the second round Rook
takes Knight taking away the defender of
that Rook on D1 a threat that Ali Raza
counters by attacking NB back's Queen on
H5 what's a good Square I'm thinking
about Queen all the way to the other end
of the board starting to Target the A2
Pawn yeah it's it's a very good
possibility I was even thinking like the
position is so good that Queen C5 is
also a tempting option yeah just to
highlight that of course white will not
take but if white takes then after d
takes C5 the black Bishop lands on D4
and it cuts everything off White's
position is falling apart despite being
an end game so I would expect that after
the move Queen C5 white has to push D3
D4 no matter what uh it but but it just
shows the superiority of Black's
position that he can even afford to play
a move like Queen C5 being Pawn done he
can trade Queens the two Bishops and the
active Rook are just uh controlling
everything NC Abdu satov is down upon
but looks like a dominating position
Nicholas what is the actual evaluation
here and is it as bad as we think it is
for ala
whoa Bishop to D4 oh Bishop D4 wow
powerful and yeah what a crushing move
we didn't see that coming at all but
that's why we're here there down there
Bishop D4 amazing resource this just
game over pretty much so um the idea is
if white takes the queen then black
takes the queen on E3 hits the Knight on
F2 the bishop is attacked Black's
winning material and winning the game so
really the only move that white has is
to take the bishop this yeah it's it's
already played Queen takes F3 Queen
takes F3 and you look at look at the C
just a second that I haven't seen so
nervous already for a long time and
Magnus Carson has probably just crushed
through against Le let's quickly get up
the final position of the Magnus Lev on
board how that finished it looked
dominating for Magnus from the very
start and there we see Magnus finally
getting his first win on the freestyle
chess in in the very final round uh
Nicholas this was the end of this
one-sided game yes let's see the last
few moves to understand what happened
but as we said it was just too difficult
to defend practically and also
objectively it was a tough spot B4
opening up the king further to open up
the C file and now C takes B the bishop
was taken black really didn't want to do
this because now this Pawn is also quite
uncomfortable for the king and there's
no no defender of the light squares
anymore and Rook takes B4 wow what a
what a beautiful finish here hitting the
Queen the The Rook wants to come in and
if if um black was to take on B4 it's
not immediately obvious to me how the
finish is looking but probably Queen D7
check King B6 and and then probably just
Bishop E3 check and then the Rook joins
the party as well E3 check looks looks
very good
and yeah this this is going to be over
very soon King A6 Rook Rook A1 and the
King cannot come forward because then C7
is hitting the queen and giving a check
so Arona didn't want to see this being
played out anymore beautiful game
Beautiful Finish By by magnos and he'll
be very happy to have won his first game
and also equalize his score he's on 50%
two out of four
and tomorrow there have three more
rounds to go but we still have a few
games going should we go right back into
the other one that we saw between nybeck
and fuza let's do it let's just jump
straight into that a 19 movement Nature
by Magnus Carlson against Levon aronian
and it looks like this one might be
ending any moment as well yeah it's
horrible yeah let's just highlight yeah
that Bishop takes this is kind of also a
simple tactic because there is no way to
capture it if white captures with the
Knight then black delivers checkmate
with Queen G2 immediately and queen
takes D3 runs into Queen takes F2 check
and then black can even choose how to
finish the game with Wich mate uh and
white is kind of struggling to find the
move the big question is there any
direct threat like Bishop yeah exactly
like Bishop takes E4 seems to be a
threat yeah taking the pawn which is
triple protected but there is no way of
capturing it because Queen takes E4
Knight take C4 runs into the exactly
same issue like before and if Rook takes
them there's a new twist with Rook C1
check delivering Checkmate on the back
Rank and I don't see what white can do
here I think resign would probably be
not a far away option for ala I mean
Bishop takes Pawn comes in not just
picking up a pawn but you're threatening
a mate in one after that Queen G2 would
be a big threat and look at our screens
I think Ali Resa also realizes just how
difficult this POS position is Queen E3
the only defensive move immediately
picks up the E4 Pawn n back playing
confidently it goes into an end game and
from being down a PA nbec is up a PA but
that's not the biggest strength of his
position look at that Bishop on F3 look
at that Rook on C2 tying down White's
Army tying down that White Knight on F2
and Rook on E1 to keep the back rank
defended Al aliar is going to end up
losing all his pawns on the queen side
eventually yeah it's completely hopeless
we also in his body language yeah that
he knows it's not this type of position
that I'm Pawn done and I have chances to
survive as we see many times in some
Rook end game or whatever this is just
completely hopeless also I think some
moves have been played H4 Rook takes A2
he collects another
one white would love to yeah he he yeah
he white plays G4 but let's just show
that if white takes the pawn on E7 then
he is faced with the problem of check
King H2 and L F1 one brutal attacking
that Knight and if the Knight moves the
Luke H1 will be Checkmate and there is
no way of protecting that Knight so I
believe that this is technically over
two pawns up and a winning position
that's two extra pawns to the boot and a
really cool Bishop on F3 a even more
cooler Rook on A2 it's a matter of
technique uh but looking very hopeless
for alira we'll see if nbec manages to
do what we think he will get this win in
let's jump over to some of the other
action which is still pretty unclear to
my eyes what catches your attention
Nicholas on our current boards
well up to theur should win and my
attention is of course drawn to gcash
against dingly Ren where we last left
when gash had sacrific to exchange and
we see still pretty much similar picture
that white has beautiful compensation
the King on F6 now G5 has been played it
is looking pretty Grim for ding but he
has a Time Advantage he's
fighting but it is still looking very
very difficult and the engine bar agrees
gives a huge Advantage for white through
out so guka should take this one home we
expect yeah I think that leaves us with
Vincent game against Fabiano and we
should be jumping in right there into
action because it's a very double kind
of position uh my first impression is
that it's looking promising for white
but we should not be forgetting about
that lovely Bishop on D4 the Knight on
E8 on the other hand is uh misplaced
white should be better but there's so
much to play
for absolutely and uh I won't be
surprised if at some moment you're
talking about this bishop where wion
decides to sacrifice his Rook for this
bishop uh at the right moment of course
when you can take control and make the
most of the dark Squad weaknesses around
Black's ging while Winston finds another
way another really nice sacrifice and
it's all around that queen move on E7
you've got to show this move you've got
to show this idea Peter break this down
for us yes so Vincent has played the
move Rook
B1 kicking the queen away it's very
difficult kind of to find a good spot
because if the black queen moves to A6
then there are problems with Knight D7
trapping The Rook on f8 so it's clear
that the black queen should be keeping
an eye on the D7 square and then Vince
and suddenly uses this T tactic with
Bishop E3 Bishop takes E3 runs into Rook
D7 trapping the queen so before we have
seen a team trapping The Rook on f8 now
the queen is trapped all of a sudden so
clearly Fabby won be falling for that I
believe that most probably he will have
to leave that Bishop on D4 let's just
also highlight that Bishop takes E5
Queen takes E5 is an absolutely noo let
me even put it white has some incredible
domination on the dark squares
black will not be able to hold on to
this for too long I'm expecting that
even with the pawn sacrifice or
something but black has to keep the
bishop on D4 I think Fabby completely
missed this tactical idea we saw him
slow down after Bishop B3 he looked
really surprised after this move and
great tactical sharpness there by
Winston taking advantage of the fact
that Black's Queen was boxed up on E7
the center of the board uh Fabby decides
to keep the bishop on D4 for now plays
the move Queen Queen to D6 eyeing that
E5 Knight trying to trade off some
pieces uh Nicholas what do we make of
this bishop B3 really impressed us has
Fabby managed to keep things under
control with Queen D6 Queen D6 was
absolutely necessary to protect the
bishop because otherwise you're just
going to lose a Pawn on D4 and as Peter
pointed out you cannot take the bishop
since your queen is strapped so Queen D6
was strong and now the question is if
Vincent has a strong followup he has
some different options here he can take
the pawn he can take the bishop on D4
and now after C takes D4 maybe invade
with the Rook there would be one
possibility or just play Rook to B3 in
general to double on the defile and and
win the pawn in this way in general the
big big problem is this Knight on E8 is
just horribly placed and even if it went
to G7 or C7 it really doesn't hasn't
improved all that much and this Knight
on E5 on the other hand is very well
very well placed so Queen D6 is the last
move that we see I believe right so no
he has he has taken on D4 Vincent has
and the question is how can he continue
there several options I think for him
it's important to keep control of the
time because he is getting low on time
so he should move quickly Rook B3 Rook
B7 maybe even Rook B5 and he's clearly
better and he could extend his lead even
further so Vincent looking good Tanya
wincent looking good and this one it
looks like gkes is looking very strong
in his game from the very start we might
be close to the Finish Line in that one
as Black's King is under Fire with the
queen on B1 the Knight on G3 the pawn on
G4 eyeing that F5 Pawn this has gone
from bad to worse for ding yeah this is
basically game over yeah King F7 Knight
takes F5 hook C7 this is the current
position white already has three pawns
all the positional compensation the
bishop on C6 is beautifully cemented
with this Pawn on B5 the Knight on F5 is
eternal yeah basically both light pieces
are eternally placed black has no
counter playay look at the pawn
structure that we highlighted right from
the beginning yeah that ever since white
played this B4 C takes B before Queen B4
everything is just perfect how is he
finishing it off Queen B4 attacking D6
black had to push the pawn the only way
to keep it defended he goes D5 the queen
penetrates further after D5 Queen A5 and
Black's pieces are just overloaded
trying to keep that King defended you
can't move the Rook from the seventh
Rank and denen has had enough he loses
his fourth game in a row of the day it's
been an absolute nightmare for the world
champion today GES with his second win
in a row no third win in a row already
wow yeah he is on fire he beat leevon in
the previous magnos yeah Magnus first
and leevon and I think yeah that's
that's good Cas he beat the world number
one and the world champion in the same
day yeah and the
legend just an incredible start for the
17-year-old youngster and we see him on
our screen as he uh very much in G
trademark sits arranges the pieces
calmly gets up nerves of Steel there of
course the action is continuing on the
other boards uh a great start for the
Indian youngster we will quickly move
over to the wincent the Fabby board we
saw quite that move Bishop E3 that I'm
still thinking about and this last
little move this little Rook LIF it eyes
to double up on the dile the D4 Pawn is
weak you want to start targeting it
Nicholas yeah absolutely let's also
point out that up to the as we expected
also won his game with the black pieces
also being in great shape and now we
have one final game remaining here
Vincent against Fabiano and Rook B2
similar ideas we talked about Rook B3
doubling on the dile and I don't think
that black can really hold this Pawn he
can go after the Knight on E5 by going
Rook C5 but white just cements it Rook
D2 next going after this pawn and this
Pawn should drop so Vincent is in a good
spot however his time situation 1 minute
13 against almost 5 minutes by kaana is
the only thing that is worrying me but
so far Vincent has shown that even with
little time on the clock he is able to
play good chess and maybe he can
continue to do so however Fabiano is
also a very tricky player Peter yeah
absolutely yeah Fabiano will be fighting
like a lion and these are tricky moments
yeah that you have the better position
but if something goes wrong yeah then
you are stuck with your little time and
you get very nervous so yeah Fabby will
be looking how to create chances on the
other hand I know Vincent that if he
feels that he's in control then he
doesn't really mind going down on the
clock yeah because he knows that there
is the increment as long as I know
what's going on and I'm on the on the
right side of action then I going to
handle any kind of time management and
it feels like the kind of position where
White's moves are flowing you've just
played Rook B2 almost regardless of what
black plays next I think the next move
is Rook D2 for white and then it's Fabby
who needs to think how is he planning to
defend the move the pawn on D4 and
you're pointing out the one move for
which white shouldn't play Rook D2 Rook
C5 would put pressure on that Knight on
E5 and the more I look at it the more I
like it because if the Knight moves the
C4 Pawn is hanging would Rook C5 Force
Winston to either go for F4 or Rook B5
how does he keep the balance then yeah
that's a question I think that's also
the reason why he spent quite some time
for Rook B2 yeah he had to have the
answer ready after Rook C5 and if he has
to play a move F4 that would be kind of
scary with Lam on the clock because then
you soften your structure I think we
have a move on the board instead of
going for Rook to C5 Fabby plays a more
cautious approach he's uh defending that
D4 Pawn he's preempting Rook D2 so
instead of that Winston jumps in and
attacks another weakness in the position
the Knight and the Rook lined up against
the F7 Pawn but also the A7 Pawn is
hanging so The Rook on f8 is really tied
down to defending that pawn long term
yeah Queen A6 fabbi is hoping to
activate that Knight somehow jumping to
D6 will he be able to do that Vincent
goes Rook D7 like this move Yes again
the same team but look D7 Knight D7
Queen A4 be careful takes takes Queen A4
but luckily we have Knight F6 check
because otherwise it would be a double
attack I almost got a hard attack Knight
F6 Knight F6 oh yeah Knight F6 then what
is happening whoa what am I a rook takes
D4 just just come yourself done Peter
yeah that's the way yeah wow so Vincent
with 20 seconds on the clock is is
calculating things like this very scary
but he knows what he's doing and we are
talking about youngsters they they are
fearless just just incredible stuff here
uh the defa pawn that was hanging
earlier can be picked up in this line
for which it is a big
defensive resource and uh you can't
trade on D7 right now as you pointed out
the f8 Rook will be trapped or you lose
the D4 Pawn Fabby thinking right now and
as uh as he does so as he tries to
defend this very difficult position one
of the Jacks one of the young players
who's had quite the phenomenal day here
taking down the world number one Magnus
Carlson defeating Leon aronian and then
winning the final game against world
champion while he's joining us in the
studio with Nicholas gkes
congratulations and quite a start yeah
thank you very much for joining us after
this long game first of all
congratulations on a really great
performance I think after the first game
uh you came back with three wins in a
row is that right and probably the turn
Turning Point what's your game against
Magnus I could
imagine yeah um the first game um yeah I
guess I wasn't warmed up and I played a
really bad game but um but after that
the Magnus game was quite a quite a good
confidence boost for me especially
because you were coming back from a lost
position if we can go there maybe
briefly
so Magnus was sacrificing pawns left and
right against you and and you're really
on the defense and then he decided so
this was maybe one of the critical
moments he decided to trade Queens did
that surprise
you um I actually thought I wasn't
losing at any point but but um okay now
I now I see the engine and it's uh it's
quite clear that my king is quite big
but during the game I thought he has to
trade and just try to defend this in
game ah okay so you thought you were
ahead uh I thought it should be a draw
but I thought I was the one pushing so
appalation Queen da would have been a
strong move yes sorry no I just I just
want to say G we want to Deep dive into
this game but perhaps we'd love to first
get your insights into the live action
that we have on Nicholas because things
are really heating up on the
wincent uh Fabby board gkes your
thoughts on the position right now
uh well but Vincent is done to N9
seconds so that should be added okay
white is surely winning
but uh if he can win is the
question okay I don't know why this
jumped now but yeah apparently there was
uh Queen F4 was not the most ideal move
taking on d8 and then playing Queen D2
and collecting the pawn oops sorry that
was me uh was better but Vincent has so
little time and now after Queen F4 black
is back in the game it seems
but I don't see a difference for
black
um and there was FY under a minute yeah
so he doesn't have this comfort of
having too much time so Rook F7 is the
big threat how is Knight D6 apparently
must be
played Knight D6 uh Rook D1 he has
checks uh I mean 9 D6 Rook D4 he has
checks on E11 yeah right yeah that's the
TR a little bit the king is a bit Airy
here and white has to defend yeah Knight
C6 also Queen A4 is a nice trick so yeah
so for to play Knight D6 you have to see
Knight C6 Queen A4 as GES points outby
play6 F6 okay this should be b g takes
F6 F7 is coming yeah this is completely
lost and Rook
F6 um Queen H6 is it a move yes Queen H6
is very strong Rook D7 Knight D7 and the
G6 Pawn Falls yeah G6 Falls and just 8
seconds for Fabby wow Vincent is he
going to take another he takes on D7
first takes on
D7 and Rook FS on Queen B8 is there ooh
that's full board awareness by gkes the
queen comes in from the other side of
the board well and is there a defense
after that because I don't see I think
it's the yeah Queen B8 is over and
Vincent is double checking and he's
going to go for it
he is going to go for it isn't
he yes wow and he does and Fabby resigns
wincent with a big win and Peter with a
sigh of relief on that one Queen V8 a
really nice move yeah but we have been
talking about the Jacks yeah the Jacks
are just way too
dangerous G how was it for you first day
here at the freestyle chess how was the
experience um it was quite nice um I
really enjoyed first all um and also I
mean I was a bit uh upset after the
first game but but after that I I
managed to play some really good games
so yeah maybe let's have a look at your
last game which was very very convincing
I would say yeah um against the world
champion ding L Ren so let's go there
what do you think where did it all go
wrong for him
already already the opening was like
very shaky by him so maybe already here
the move F5 or maybe even earlier Knight
D6 I thought was quite quite ugly for
black yeah he lost some time uh also
moving the Knight again yeah I mean I
was analyzing uh with Magnus and in one
of the positions like I suggested Knight
D3 or Knight D6 and it was just so bad
because you block the pawn and mhm like
it's just a very ugly move so yeah he
soon moved KN again but he also weakened
his King here now so yeah because I
think he the point was that he wanted to
Castle and if he doesn't go F5 for
example Knight F6 runs into Bishop
H6 exactly that's also a motive that we
saw again again I mean instead of so in
yeah Bishop H6 and then you cannot
Castle anymore and then long Castle is
never an option
exactly but okay um after this I thought
I mean I can just uh play some normal
chess and positionally squeeze him on
the queen side yeah we were saying this
pretty much looks like an English
completely gone wrong for black and then
this was a very nice uh transformation
of Adventures going for this Knight D5
to exchange sacrifice yeah in standard
chess like this is every English English
player's dream I guess so yeah yeah was
there any moment where you felt like he
had a chance to come come back or was it
pretty smooth after that I don't think
he had any chance like throughout the
game so I mean the opening went wrong
and I think I didn't go wrong at any
point it was just a very clean game I
think well congratulations very
impressive performan on the first day
Tanya Peter do you have any questions
for we were all watching uh well all of
you analyz in those moments when the
position is revealed when the next game
position is revealed what was that like
discussing it with well your competitors
but also at that moment trying to
understand these uh new
positions yeah I mean there is a very
short time to fully understand the
position so I guess uh one or two more
Minds like really helps yeah to
understand the position better and also
I got to like analyze with the Magnus so
that that is quite fun I mean apart from
the preparation it's just a very nice
thing in general so uh yeah that's a
nice nice feature you know to Oneal with
the with the other players well I would
like to add one thing because after you
lost the first game we have been seeing
you in the second game sitting alone and
analyzing then and suddenly it turned
out afterwards that it was a real
turning point and in the end in the
before the last game already Magnus
Carson was coming to you and to wincent
and was following your kind of
discussion do you feel like there was a
psychological turning point in this
regard or what did you think after to
losing that first game and going
separately analyzing the
position um it was actually not
something that I wanted because I mean
the before the first game I was
analyzing with Magnus and Leon and then
the second game both of them had black
so I didn't have any analyzing Partners
so I was analyzing alone but okay I
guess it helped kind kind of in a way
that I had some alone time after after
the loss to just uh like pull my
thoughts together
and G today we saw the youngsters the
Jacks in this position have a great day
have quite a good performance here uh
while well the kings of the tournament
were struggling for quite a bit of time
do you think there is something about
this format that perhaps uh suits the
younger generation a little
more uh I don't know um maybe since
there are like lot of tricks that you
need to watch out from move one it's
like in general younger players are more
tricky I guess so I don't know if that
helps but uh yeah maybe it was just a
good day for the youngers I don't know
did you enjoy the process of thinking
for move number one something that in
standard chest just never happens yeah I
I really love uh love
960 I'm uh apart from the results I'm
just really enjoying myself here like
just thinking from move on I something I
really
enjoy well thank you so much for joining
us and we hope that you enjoy yourself
also a lot tomorrow we wish you a best
of luck yeah and looking forward to your
games tomorrow thank you
thanks gkes with a fantastic start there
well he started slower first round loss
and then recovering with three backto
back retries against the very best in
the world Peter yeah stunning
performance and uh and the reason why
everybody likes gash is that after the
three wins he comes in and he's so
modest he quietly explains everything
and he doesn't know exactly the reason
why he's winning those games well
because he's extremely strong and he has
also nerves of Steel he's handling all
kind of challenges like like a true
master I'm I'm a huge gcash fan so I'm
very happy for him you're not alone in
that uh it's been a fantastic day for G
and there we have our results from round
four we see Winston kimer with a big win
against Fabiano caruana not a be with
also a phenomenal performance today he
also takes down Ali Rea in the last
round and KES winning three back-to-back
games finally taking down the world
champion dingler and Magnus Carlson with
a power performance against Lavon
aronian a miniature a 19 move Victory
getting his first win in uh speaking of
Jacks and kings in this tournament we
are being joined by another back who had
quite a performance who ends the day at
the top of the leaderboard uh we're
being joined by Winston kimer in our
studio Winston a good start
congratulations thank you very much yeah
thank you for joining us you had a
pretty much Perfect Day drawing against
Magnus then winning all of your
remaining games what is the secret to
your success today yeah no idea I mean
first of all kind of comfortably thrwing
Magnus in the first round with black is
like a really good start to the
tournament and then yeah I had the very
fighting game with levelon where I'm not
sure what happened but I felt like most
of the time I had the upper hand so that
was kind of like a huge fighting win
after which I also felt that yeah I'm
quite good shape for some reason ding
seems to be not at his best currently so
I mean I'm not sure but maybe he lost
all games today yeah and that's also why
I went for maybe rather risky approach
in the opening with f because I felt
that I mean of course I'm not playing
something extra bad but something very
complicated and it worked out in the end
and now the last game I'm not sure I
mean I felt after the opening it should
be basically just equal and then the
moment he started to do some like had
got issues with his Knight on D6 and E8
and then it uh it's kind of weird yeah
that normally you will never have such a
knight but in ch 960 like all the other
pieces were normally placed but this one
piece kind of cost him the game yeah
made all the difference we see it still
here in the final position on E8 your
game against D Len was quite impressive
you sacrificed The Exchange early on
that's probably what he meant that he
took some risks and then well you
attacked him and crushman attacked
pretty much um what do you think were
the key moments there do we have time to
get into this or yeah all right so let's
have a brief look if you would like to
um in your that was the third round I
believe or second round a third round
here so this was the final position
so yes maybe let's let's walk through
here in this position you decided to
sacrifice The Exchange Queen H4 B I
already all right you already committed
one move earlier so what was your
thought process there because for a lot
of people watching at home they they
would just think all right I'm giving up
an exchange where's my uh compensation
for that maybe you can say something
about that yeah well first of all I get
the pawn which is not nothing and then
this bishop on V2 gets kind of bad
because I get to place all my pawns on
black and I will have very beautiful
light Square Bishop on C8 and I think
King safety is also a very important
issue here yeah like Knight D6 Knight F4
F5 Knight G5 Knight F3 Bishop B7 or also
Bishop H3 are hanging in the air so I
think it's kind of very tricky to to
play for white and yeah here somewhere I
felt that probably I missed something
clearer than what I had but I'm not sure
I ever really messed it up but yeah I
mean here it's just that you can see
yeah like his Queen on B1 is still kind
of stuck of course D5 was a good try and
I'm not sure that I played everything
correctly like okay F4 Rook E4 has to be
winning yeah he should not have taken he
should have played F4 gift exchange back
and HED to hold it somehow I think it's
still pretty much lost yeah know like I
calculated these lines yeah like Knight
H3 King H2 Queen D6 King H3 Rook G4 is
kind of for IM made yes and G3 I think
Rook H4 here was okay oh there's Queen
C3 still out of nowhere going for are so
yeah I mean it's you know if you look at
it with an engine it's probably easily
winning but still there's something to
calculate so I understand that at least
he went for the line where I had to
prove something mhm and after D1 yeah
and you you didn't have that much time
but that was the problem yeah Rook H4
Rook H4 would have been G H3 Queen G4
that was the that is the The crucial
detail we thought you would find it yeah
yeah no it's absolutely findable yeah I
was just so on this queen D6 there
because I was ring on it against Queen
D3 well to be fair Queen D6 was also
winning and you didn't step a foot wrong
in the end and it wasn't yeah because
like after Rook takes E3 at some moment
I thought maybe Rook D3
it's here no this all still winning
Knight H3 Rook E2 because it's like okay
not yeah it's
only yeah but it Rooks yeah I saw this
Rook e to Rook H2 and thought yeah we'll
just we'll be winning no I think uh this
is also kind of an example that like
maybe engine is not extremely happy
about this exchange sacrifice but if you
you already have one pawn and you have
very nice positional compensation and
it's way easier to play For You
especially in rapit that gives very good
chances to win the game and it's also
the kind of position that is very easily
losable for white simply because there's
like my moves are coming logic normally
yeah and I think it's a very important
factor to consider the Practical play
especially in Rapid so this was a very
convincing win against dingler Ren and
then the final game now against Fabi
yo that was also quite exciting because
you were both low on time yeah uh in the
end and it was quite sharp but you found
some very powerful moves there um yeah
maybe walk us through here a little bit
the critical moments I me here was very
happy already all right here we're very
happy yeah not sure yeah Knight G7 this
was of course I've expected him to play
this and I wanted to play Knight
G4 yeah and it's like let's say because
this is I think just losing because here
I will have like this Knight F6 Knight
F6 and I'll just Rook D4 and he can't
keep the squares
okay okay so I have to start with taking
on D4 yeah then but okay but it looks
very dangerous for his King definitely
understand that he didn't want to get
into any of this so he went
H5 and here this was a very interesting
idea with Bishop E3 and also very strong
idea um most likely yeah I thought maybe
I mean taking was an but I was not
entirely sure like yeah no Queen D6 was
best and here Rook d8 Rook B7 Queen A6
Rook D7 was very strong for a moment
Peter had a heart attack because he
thought that black could take and queen
A4
Rook work for me yeah no otherwise life
would be very bad and here maybe black
can get back into a game of Knight D6
but also a very difficult move to to
allow Knight C6 and um but Queen A4
there D6 is possible I think I wanted to
take on d8 but yeah and yeah no I mean
it's very complicated yeah it looks
really really bad for black but you know
if you get out my king is kind of weak
so yes there always some kind of
Perpetual checks that I need to watch
out for and also you know once black
gets some attack it's not that easy but
simply with the side on E8 it will take
quite a while to generate harmonious
play here yeah and after he played F6
then it was uh that was pretty much over
very powerful performance by you today
um what was your approach going into it
you checked before game with the other
players you analyzed together a little
bit how how did that go was that helpful
yeah for me it TR was helpful uh I think
you know not break we talked a bit for
him at went well also with C so at least
our approach to the games can't have
been that wrong at least from a human
perspective and yeah I think you know
like this I can really enjoy the next
day and see what happens yeah I mean you
you've been you've been putting up great
great performance and I think T and
maybe P have some questions as well yeah
wincon talking about your approach it's
really interesting because we're also in
the studio sort of exploring these new
positions as they're revealed the round
that you're going into so as a player
what what is it that guides you towards
your first couple of moves what is it
that all of you have in mind to try to
achieve in these possessions Yeah so
basically one first needs to check where
are the pieces yeah let's say if you
have a bishop in the corners then it's
very logical to move like G or bwn
because it's basically like fiano one
move then if you have like a queen on
the outside it basically means you need
to move some pawns you normally wouldn't
move at the start because once your
queen gets stuck you can just lose the
game for nothing then of course you have
to think about castling a bit but I
think normally that's like a factor that
doesn't really change that much of
course first of all yeah like check that
you don't blunder any pawns there was
some position where I think like D4 was
a move and C5 immediately would have
been like nearly winning for black
because Bishop H2 G1 would have won an
exchange or something so these kind of
things can be very tricky but yeah I
think this is the thing and then of
course you know we all still from normal
chess have this tendency to occupy the
center so of course we have to think
about okay how do we occupy this scch
and I think if you're looking from the
white side there are two different
approaches because like normally with
the pieces set up there's like one
square in the center that's easier to
control and the other square is less
easy and you know sometimes it can be
much better to try to control the less
easier Square because then you like with
the uh advance of having the first move
you can like exploit this weakness but I
still think that from a human
perspective it might have made sense but
if you look at it from an engine
probably made a lot of very stupid moves
but yeah I still feel like it had really
some logic behind it not at all you guys
were doing great out of the opening and
those are some really really nice
insights right there do you think
eventually freestyle chess will have its
own set of
theories it's a different kind of theory
yeah like nobody will be able to learn
960 positions full Theory by heart but I
think yeah like you will learn some
motives yeah like let's say if Knights
are in the corner Bishops are in the
corner Queen in the corner there can be
like different motives that are coming
back and then of course you will have
some idea of how to use those and while
that's happening while that's still a
farway reality and every position is
unique and fresh did you enjoy that
process did you have fun today yeah sure
I mean as long as you win life's great
yeah I think the other players for them
who didn't play so well it's different
yeah not that they couldn't enjoy but if
result doesn't go the way it is whole
life normally is a bit worse than normal
yeah so yeah yeah one question that I
would like to ask is we have been seeing
these gatherings and analyzes before the
game can you reveal us that a part of
having some wonderful atmosphere and
enjoying the process did any in any game
concretely move P move have this
preparation or everybody has its own
take and it's more about just discussing
General feelings no we agree on quite a
few things yeah for example I think like
second game another B we both had this
idea of going with D4 C3 and trying to
push E4 and I think we also both won the
games and now against in this ding game
we of course we're seeing it this H7
Pawn hanging C4 C5 Castle so there were
all those kind of motives yeah I mean
this is also was one of the cases with
the queen and the corner I think yeah so
then of course for me like from the
white perspective we check this D4 idea
or lot because let's say CD4 Queen D4
you will get kicked away but then your
queen is the game and queen on8 is still
stuck so that's of course where this D5
idea was already in my mind playing from
black so what we discussed from White
then I could use from the black side so
I surely think that it was not just uh
funny talking and enjoying the moment
because then at some point we would
realize that okay this is not the way to
go and we should really focus on
ourselves yeah one one extra question to
this same topic we have been seeing
Magnus controlling the first three
boards the the analyzes the discussions
and everything and on game for which he
went on to Wi against Leon he joined on
you guys the youngsters the Jacks from
outside and uh what is your take did you
feel that suddenly Magnus is also
starting to disp you guys extremely that
you guys are doing something phenomenal
here I don't know at least I think he
felt that he needed to change something
because for him like okay for everybody
else it would be maybe kind of a fine
result but that's surely not his
expectation to be like on minus one
after three rounds so yeah and I'm not
exactly sure yeah it was very
interesting that like he had a very
different approach TOS because they were
like trying to make normal things happen
and he was trying to find the crazy
genius ideas and yeah I think probably
if you check with an engine engine will
give some genius brilliant ideas but
that's kind of the thing that we can't
really make work ourselves at least for
now and like you know you can one move
can be brilliant but it could also be
just losing yeah let's say that's kind
of very tricky I mean I remember yeah
this like in the first game this bishop
takes G2 motive that
like basically could have cost two games
in the first three or four moves yeah
it's like those things you really rarely
see yeah it was awesome to see all these
Dynamics in the opening and Magnus
chilling with you guys before the game
worked out perfectly for him and for uh
everyone involved including yourself
great performance today Vincent and we
look forward to seeing you in action
tomorrow great thank you thank you thank
you Winston K there with some really
nice insights about how the ERS approach
these positions with just 10 minutes uh
to really think about their first moves
yes and Vincent did mention that with
ABD there that was the second game when
they decided on D4 and C3 and in the
last game it was Magnus Carson we
against leevon used this D4 C3 which we
understood that it was so clever
psychologically clever because he also
knows leevon leevon likes to do
something very special and he got
provoked into this B5 which went on to
hunt him right after move two fantastic
win for Magnus I'm pretty sure we know
if Magnus starts to win he gets
extremely dangerous so I'm already
waiting for all the action tomorrow you
know Magnus is a dangerous player with
his back against the wall and he's an
angry player today because he finally
managed to get a win in but what a win
that was this was the result of our
final rapid game of the day Winston K
with a fabulous win against Fabiano Ali
RZA goes down to nbec Abdu satov gkes on
fire today eventually taking down the
world champion dingler and and Magnus
with a 19 move Victory against Levon
aronian let's also bring up our
standings at the end of the day this is
day one of the round robin four rapid
games tomorrow we will have another four
rapid games the players have gotten
their warm-up in we're expecting more
Fighting Chess tomorrow and leading at
the top of the leaderboard we saw there
the Jacks wincon kimer gkes uh in the
top two positions followed by NC Abdu
satov the Jacks are really the Kings
today
yes absolutely no they had some
incredible
performance uh but let's not count the
Kings out they are burning for the
desire to bnce back and uh the the
things are just heating up they might
need a little bit of more time to get
used to the used to
the Fisher random Stu you you know this
all this kind of craziness right from
the start Vincent did mention that
Magnus was somehow in too much
brilliancy mode yeah maybe is also
taking a more pragmatic approach yeah
there there is so much Intrigue and
definitely the Kings will be thinking
how to adjust their strategy it is going
to be a lot about strategy and Before We
Say Goodbye I'm going to open the floor
to you Nicholas who's been really
keeping us true to the position what was
the one big highlight for you
today well thank you Tanya and uh it's
very difficult to find one big highlight
but the performance of the youngster has
been really really impressive we just
saw it on the Le leaderboard the first
four places are occupied by the
youngsters by the Jacks here in this
tournament and especially Vincent's
performance has been incredible three
and a half out of four against this
field is just magnificent and in general
the Highlight for me has been just
enjoying this freestyle chess so far we
had just tremendous games we had
beautiful attacks and ideas and just
high high high quality chess so I don't
know about you guys but I'm looking
forward to tomorrow and looking forward
to commentating with Tanya and Peter so
really looking forward to that we're so
excited about tomorrow as well but it's
now time for the players to enjoy the
hospitality of the vion house they've
earned their rest for tonight the Peter
we will be back tomorrow with the final
four rapid games before moving on to the
knockout the classical knockout of the
freestyle chess it's been a fantastic
day of Chess a big thank you a big shout
out to every everyone who's joining us
for the event in chat it has been
awesome once again Peter a goodbye to
chat from us we will see you tomorrow
bye-bye
[Music]
byebye
[Applause]
[Music]
Bab
oh